TODAY WITH THE US SPECIAL
HEARING.
THIS IS A SPECIAL ASSEMBLY
BUDGET COMMITTEE.
SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBER TWO ON
EDUCATION FINANCE AND ASSEMBLY
HIGHER ED COMMITTEE.
TALKING ABOUT TO IMPORTANT
COMMUNITY COLLEGE ISSUES WAY TO
THE BUDGETS OF THESE ARE BUDGET
LATE ISSUES.
AND OF COURSE ONLY THAT THE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE WILL BE
VOTING ON THESE MATTERS I
ACTUALLY TODAY WE DON'T HAVE ANY
VOTES IT EITHER WAY THIS IS JUST
AN OVERVIEW OF THE TWO PROPOSALS
AND WILL. THAT WOULD HOLD
ACTION.
UNTIL LATER IN THE BUDGET
PROCESS
AND THE ARE THERE OTHER
COMMITTEE CALLED ISSUES TO
DISCUSS IN THE BUDGET BUT EITHER
TO THAT HOW SHOULD ONE TALK BUT
TODAY. THE ONLINE BECAUSE
PROPOSAL WHICH WE GO TO HEAR
FIRST AND THEN THE.
THE NEW FUNDING.
NEW FUNDING FORMULA PROPOSAL AS
WELL FROM DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
SO. I'D LIKE TO THINK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA FOR CO HOSTING
THIS HEARING I WITH US HE OF
COURSE IS ON THE SUBCOMMITTEE AS
WELL. AND IT JUST DOES RATHER IT
GOING IN YOU KNOW IN IN THE BIG
PICTURE CERTAINLY WE ALL HAVE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THAT THE
LARGEST COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM
IN THE NATION IS RIGHT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA ARE COMMITTEE CALLED
SYSTEM SERVING MORE THAN.
TWO MILLION STUDENTS I'M
IMPORTANT ADMISSIONS SERVING AS
A GATEWAY FOR THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS SEEKING A BETTER
LIFE THROUGH THE POWER OF
EDUCATION. PROVIDING WORKFORCE
TRAINING.
COMMUNITY SERVICE PROGRAMS FROM
ENGLISH TO CITIZENSHIP CLASSES
THE BACHELOR'S DEGREES THERE ARE
CERTAINLY A VITAL PART. OF OUR.
OF OUR CALIFORNIA LANDSCAPE AND
WE CERTAINLY WANT TO MAKE SURE
THEY ARE ABLE TO TO THRIVE WEEK
WE ALSO KNOW THAT.
THE.
LANDSCAPER THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY IS CHANGING WE NEED MORE
INDIVIDUALS WITH DEGREES AND
CERTIFICATES TO FILL THE JOBS OF
TOMORROW WE ALSO KNOW THAT
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO HAVE.
GOOD PAYING JOBS
AND BE ABLE TO AFFORD A HOME AND
SO FORTH NEED MORE EDUCATION
BEYOND HIGH SCHOOL SO THOSE TWO
THINGS.
ARE CRITICAL AS WE LOOK AT THESE
PROPOSALS THAT WE DO HAVE A. TO
DO HAVE MANY QUESTIONS ON BOTH
OF THEM ESPECIALLY THE ONLINE
PROPOSAL. I WITHHOLD MY
QUESTIONING UNTIL WE START THE
HEARING. PASSWORD THAT I'D LIKE
TO INTRODUCE
OUR CULTURE TODAY MR MEDINA FEEL
LIKE TO SAY A FEW WORDS.
STEWART DID THANK.
THE CHAIR FOR HOSTING AND FOR A
HAVING THIS TODAY I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT DISCUSSION MUCH NEEDED
DISCUSSION. AND.
BOTH ITEMS SO LOOK FORWARD TO A.
HEARING FROM A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM.
OKAY THANK YOU SO WITH THAT WILL
SPRING UP.
THERE ARE COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
OUR CHANCELLOR.
FROM THE FINANCE REPRESENTATIVE.
AND MR CABRAL FROM THE LA UP.
YEAH.
I BELIEVE IT CANCERS GONNA.
STARTED OFF THIS MORNING.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR GOOD
MORNING.
TO MEMBERS OF OF BOTH
COMMITTEES THANK YOU FOR THE
INVITATION.
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO TALK ABOUT TWO VERY IMPORTANT
PROPOSALS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMMITTEE COLLEGES AND FOR THE
FUTURE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
IT.
AS YOU MENTIONED THAT YOUR
MCCARTY.
.
WE ARE THE LARGEST SYSTEM NOT
ONLY OF. MANY COLLEGES BUT WHERE
THE LARGE SYSTEM OF HIGHER
EDUCATION IN THE NATION.
AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE.
OF THE MAGNITUDE OF THE IMPACT
THAT WE HAVE ON OUR NATION.
NEARLY ONE IN FOUR OF EVERY
COMMITTEE COLLEGE STUDENTS
IN THE NATION IS A CALIFORNIA
COMMITTEE COLLEGE TO DO SO THESE
ARE VERY IMPORTANT ISSUES.
NOT ONLY FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BUT FOR THE NATION.
SO BEFORE I GET US STARTED I DO
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT.
YESTERDAY TODAY THE CALIFORNIA
THREE COLLEGES BOARD OF
GOVERNORS.
OUR MEETING.
AND MANY OF THEM ARE HERE TODAY
SO I'D LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
MEMBERS OF THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS ASK THEM TO STAND UP.
VERY QUICKLY.
FOR BEING HERE.
I BROUGHT HIM AS WITNESSES.
.
I ALSO WANT TO RECOGNIZE OR
BOARD PRESIDENT'S TO SEE IF THE
LLANO AND.
IF.
IF YOU'LL ALLOW ME MISTER CHAIR
I WOULD LOVE FOR HER TO COME UP
IN CASE THERE'S QUESTIONS
REGARDING THE GOVERNANCE AND SHE
IS WITH US TODAY.
UP OR PRESIDENT DILLON.
THANK.
UP SO.
BUT LET ME BEGIN.
BY AGAIN THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK ABOUT THESE
IMPORTANT ISSUES.
.
THE OTHER DAY WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
LEVERAGING.
THE
SCALE AND THE SIZE OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM.
TO BUILD A STRONGER MORE PART
PROSPEROUS CALIFORNIA.
THAT'S WHY WE'RE ALL HERE
EVERYBODY IN THIS ROOM WE WANT
TO SEE.
A MORE PROSPEROUS CALIFORNIA.
AND I THINK WE ALL RECOGNIZE.
THAT THAT REALITY IS CHALLENGED.
CHALLENGED BY THE THINGS THAT
YOU MENTION TO BEGIN WITH A
CHAIR MCCARTY.
THAT.
.
THE STATE OF THE CURRENT ECONOMY
THE STATE OF THE WORKFORCE NOW
REQUIRES.
PARTICIPANTS IN THE WORKFORCE TO
HAVE SOME SORT OF CREDENTIAL
BEYOND.
HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA.
THERE WAS ONCE A DAY WHERE HIGH
SCHOOL DIPLOMA WAS.
THE.
.
THE DEFAULT TO GET INTO THE
WORKFORCE.
THOSE DAYS ARE GONE AND THAT'S A
REALITY NOT JUST FOR THE
STUDENTS IN THE PIPELINE.
BUT ALSO THE WORKERS.
WHO ARE CURRENTLY EMPLOYED?
AND WHO ARE STRUGGLING.
THE CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE
COLLEGES.
ALL OF US ALL HUNDRED FOURTEEN
COLLEGES WE DRIVE TO THAT
MISSION EVERY DAY TO SUPPORT.
ALL CALIFORNIANS.
IN THAT'S CAPTURED IN THE
SYSTEMS VISION FOR
EXCESS WHICH BOARD OF GOVERNORS
ADOPTED.
LAST YEAR.
A KEY PART OF THIS EFFORT.
IS THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
GUIDED PATHWAYS FRAMEWORK WHICH
YOU ALL HEARD A LOT ABOUT LAST
YEAR AND SUPPORTED.
TO CONTINUE TO STREAMLINE THE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CALIFORNIANS
IN OUR SYSTEM TO ENSURE THAT
THEY HAVE A DIRECT PATHWAY TO
THEIR EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES.
OR TO THE JOB THAT THEY WANT TO
BE SKILLED AND TRAINED FOR.
SO I'M EXCITED TODAY
TO TALK ABOUT THE PROPOSAL ON ON
THE AGENDA.
.
CREATING A FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMMITTEE COLLEGE SYSTEM.
A PERSONALIZED LEARNING
PLATFORM.
IN AN ONLINE ENVIRONMENT.
WHICH IS DEMAND DRIVEN.
WHICH IS STUDENT CENTERED.
COMPETENCY BASED.
AND FOCUSED ON SCALABLE JOB
SKILL ACQUISITION.
I TOOK MY TIME HIGHLIGHTING
THOSE WORDS.
BECAUSE THIS IS SOMETHING
DIFFERENT.
IN THE CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE
COLLEGES.
CERTAINLY WE HAVE ALWAYS BEEN
STUDENTS
CENTER.
BUT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE
HERE IS BUILDING A PLATFORM.
PLATFORM TO REACH WORKERS.
AN ADULT LEARNERS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND PROVIDE THEM THE OPPORTUNITY
TO GAIN JOB SKILLS.
THROUGH A COMPETENCY BASED.
ENVIRONMENT.
ONLINE.
THAT ALLOWS THEM TO HAVE.
BETTER OPPORTUNITY TO FOR WAGE
GAINS AND FOR ECONOMIC MOBILITY.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HERE.
WELL WE ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT IS
CONTINUING TO BUILD OUT.
OUR ONLINE PRESENCE FOR
TRADITIONAL UNDERGRADUATE
EDUCATION.
THAT IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
CONTINUE TO DO AND SUPPORT
THROUGH THE ONLINE EDUCATION
INITIATIVE.
AND WE WILL CONTINUE SUPPORT
THAT WORK AND WE WILL CONTINUE
TO BUILD UPON THAT WORK.
BUT WHAT IS DIFFERENT HERE.
IS THE NOTION OF REACHING
WORKERS AND GIVING THEM THE JOB
SKILLS THEY NEED.
DEVELOP AN ON RAMP.
TO R. HUNDRED FOURTEEN COLLEGES
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS.
WHO HAVE NOT YET BEEN ABLE TO
ACCESS?
ONE OF OUR HUNDRED FOURTEEN
CULTURES.
.
I'VE TALKED TO MANY OF YOU.
ABOUT THE ONLY COLLEGE IN ABOUT
THE CHALLENGE IN GENERAL OVER
THE YEARS.
ONE OF THE THINGS I'VE TAKEN
AWAY FROM THIS DIALOGUE IS HOW
MUCH WE ALL AGREE.
ABOUT THE NEED TO PUSH OURSELVES
TO DO BETTER ALL OF US
THOSE OF US ON THE DIET THOSE OF
US.
IN THESE CHAIRS.
WE ALL NEED TO DO MORE FOR
CALIFORNIANS.
.
THE OTHER THING I WANT TO
STRESS.
IS
AND I KNOW.
MANY OF YOU AGREE ON.
THE CHALLENGES WE FACE AS A
STATE.
WITH.
THE FOR PROFIT COMMUNITY.
WE KNOW WHAT THE EXPERIENCE WAS
LIKE.
CORINTHIAN SHUT DOWN.
WHEN I TT SHUT DOWN.
AND SEVERAL OF YOU ON THIS DIETS
WERE CHAMPIONS
FOR THOSE STUDENTS.
WE WANT TO CONTINUE TO CHAMPION.
PUBLIC SOLUTION
FOR THOSE STUDENTS.
BECAUSE WE ARE LIVING IN
ENVIRONMENT TODAY.
WHERE?
THE ADMINISTRATION IN WASHINGTON
DC HAS ONCE AGAIN OPEN THE DOOR
WIDE OPEN.
IT'S PREDATORY PRACTICES.
SO WE'LL WE COME FORWARD WITH
THE PUBLIC SOLUTION FOR THAT.
I SAY WE SHOULD.
AND I SAY THE BOARD OF GOVERNORS
WHO IS IN THIS ROOM ARE WILLING.
TO DO WHAT IS NECESSARY TO
PROVIDE THE OVERSIGHT. TO ENSURE
THAT THERE'S ACCOUNTABILITY.
TO BE ABLE TO PRESENT A PUBLIC
RESPONSE
TO THAT CHALLENGE
FOR CALIFORNIANS.
SO.
AS I TRANSITION INTO TALKING
ABOUT THE PROBLEM
IF I CAN JUST ASK EVERYONE.
EVERYONE.
TO SET.
RHETORIC ASIDE.
TO SET POLITICS ASIDE.
AND THINK ABOUT WHO WERE TALKING
ABOUT SERVING HERE.
THERE ARE OVER TWO AND A HALF
MILLION CALIFORNIANS IN THE
WORKFORCE
WHO ONLY HAVE A HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMA.
OR SOME COLLEGE.
IF YOU EXTEND AT AGE SIXTY TWO
WHICH BY THE WAY MORE MORE
CALIFORNIANS ARE NEEDING TO WORK
BEYOND THE AGE OF SIXTY TWO.
.
THAT'S.
NEARLY EIGHT MILLION.
THESE ARE THE HARD WORKING
CALIFORNIANS THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
THESE ARE THE INDIVIDUALS HAT
ARE MOST VULNERABLE TO THE
CHANGES IN THE ECONOMY THE MOST
VULNERABLE TO AUTOMATION THE
MOST VULNERABLE.
TO ADVANCES IN ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE.
THESE ARE THE INDIVIDUALS.
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE
TODAY.
AND YES OUR COLLEGES ALL OVER
HUNDRED FOURTEEN COLLEGES I'M
PROUD TO SAY HAVE BEEN REACHING
OUT TO THESE COMMUNITIES.
BUT THE CHANGES IN THE ECONOMY
ARE HAPPENING SO FAST.
THAT WE NEED ONE MORE OPTION
AND THAT'S ALL WE'RE ASKING IS
ONE MORE OPTION IN THE ARSENAL
OF THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
TO BE ABLE TO REACH
MORE OF THESE ADULT LEARNERS.
WILL WE REACH ALL OF A NO.
ARE WE TALKING ABOUT BULLET HERE
NO.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ONE MORE
OPTION
TO REACH.
SOME OF THESE WORKERS
AND ALLOW THEM THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR ECONOMIC.
MOBILITY.
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS AND FOR
THAT MATTER MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS
FIND THEMSELVES STRUGGLING TO
TREAD WATER IN THE WORKPLACE.
THIS
WHAT'S CLEARLY EVIDENCED
IN THE NOVEMBER TWENTY SIXTEEN
ELECTION.
WHERE YOU SAW THE FRUSTRATION?
OF WORKING CLASS AMERICANS.
CHAU ITSELF.
BECAUSE THESE WORKING CLASS
AMERICANS ARE FINDING IT HARD.
FIGURE OUT HOW TO MOVE FORWARD
IN THIS ECONOMY.
SO WE NEED A RELENTLESS FOCUS ON
IDENTIFYING WHAT.
WORKING AGE ADULTS NEED.
CREATING A PERSONALIZED
COMPETENCY BASED PLATFORM TO
REACH THEM.
ENSURING THAT THESE INDIVIDUALS
HAVE OPPORTUNITY
ALONG THE WAY WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO BUILD OUT THE
PIPELINE FOR CURRENT STUDENTS
WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
OUR HUNDRED FOURTEEN COLLEGES.
AND ALLOW THEM THE FLEXIBILITY
TO BETTER SERVE THE CALIFORNIANS
THAT ARE ALREADY IN THE
PIPELINE.
BUT I BELIEVE WE ALSO NEED ONE
MORE TOOL.
TWO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE SKILLS
FOR THE WORKERS ARE IN THE
WORKFORCE TODAY.
I'VE BEEN INVITED TO SPEAK MANY
TIMES ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
MASTER PLAN.
AND WHILE.
THAT.
SEMINAL DOCUMENT.
REALLY DR THE LOT OF THE
CONVERSATIONS WE HAVE ABOUT.
OUR THREE SYSTEMS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION INCLUDING.
THE.
THE VERY HARD WORKING.
.
PRIVATE NON PROFITS.
BUT.
THE COMMUNITY THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE TODAY HAS BEEN LEFT
OUT OF THE CALIFORNIA MASTER.
IT DID NOT CONTEMPLATE.
UP SPILLING OR RESCALING AN
ENTIRE WORKFORCE.
SO WE NEED GO BACK AND THINK
ABOUT HOW WE ANSWERED THAT
QUESTION GOING FORWARD.
WITHIN THE FRAMEWORK OF THE
MASTER PLAN.
WE HAVE A SYSTEM.
THE CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE
COLLEGES
THERE ARE BETH POSITION.
TO DEAL WITH THAT.
CHALLENGE.
I BELIEVE AND I BELIEVE.
ON OUR BOARD OF GOVERNORS ALSO
BELIEVES THAT THE STRANDED
WORKERS WE CALM STRANDED WORKERS
AND IN YOUR PACKET YOU HAVE A
DOCUMENT.
THAT LISTS.
WHERE THE STRANDED WORKERS ARE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE?
THESE INDIVIDUALS MUST BE GIVEN
AN EQUAL OPPORTUNITY PUT
THEMSELVES IN OUR ECONOMY ON THE
PATH TOWARD GREATER PROSPERITY.
IN THAT FIRST DOCUMENT THAT YOU
SEE WITH THE MAP OF CALIFORNIA.
IT IDENTIFIES THE TWO AND A HALF
MILLION CALIFORNIANS BETWEEN THE
AGES OF TWENTY FIVE THIRTY FOUR
WHO HAVE NOT ATTAINED A
CREDENTIAL NEEDED FOR ECONOMIC
MOBILITY.
THIS POPULATION NO SURPRISE.
IT'S NEARLY HALF LATINO.
THIRTY ONE PERCENT WHITE NINE
PERCENT ASIAN AND SEVEN PERCENT
AFRICAN AMERICAN THESE ARE
CALIFORNIA.
AND AS I MENTIONED ANOTHER SIX
POINT TWO MILLION ADULTS BETWEEN
THIRTY FIVE AND SIXTY FIVE ARE
IN SIMILAR SITUATIONS.
ON THE BACK OF THE DOCUMENT YOU
CAN ALSO SEE BY ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT. THE NUMBER OF STRANDED
WORKERS AS WE CALL THEM.
THAT ARE IN THE VARIOUS ASSEMBLY
DISTRICTS REPRESENTED.
ON THE STATUS.
SO THESE ARE REAL PEOPLE.
I I AND I RECOGNIZE THAT YOU ALL
DO CARE.
SUPPORT THESE INDIVIDUALS SO
THIS IS I'M NOT BRINGING THIS UP
AT THE QUESTION OF WHETHER NOT
WE ALL SUPPORT THESE WORKERS THE
QUESTION IS HOW DO WE BEST
SUPPORT THESE WORKERS SO I
APPRECIATE.
THE OPPORTUNITY TODAY TO FOCUS
ON THEM.
THE PROSPECTS OF THESE STRANDED
WORKERS.
ARE BECOMING MORE AND MORE
UNCERTAIN.
AND THIS IS JUST NOT A SAINT.
ACCORDING TO ESTIMATES BY THE
GEORGETOWN UNIVERSITY CENTER ON
EDUCATION AND THE WORKFORCE
WITHIN TWO YEARS.
SIXTY FIVE PERCENT.
OF ALL JOB THE UNITED STATES
WILL REQUIRE AT LEAST.
SOME COLLEGE POST SECONDARY
CREDENTIAL.
IN THE GROUND IS SHIFTING
QUICKLY.
AS I MENTIONED.
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE
AUTOMATION ARE HAVING HUGE
IMPACTS
ON THE ECONOMY.
WE'RE ON RAMPS EXIST
THEY OFTENLEAD TO PROBLEMATIC
GROWTH TOO MANY OF THESE WORKERS
OFTEN TURN TO THE FOR PROFITS
AND I MENTIONED EARLIER AND
WE'VE SEEN WHAT HAPPENS THERE.
WE'VE SEEN THE STUDIES THAT
SHOW.
EVEN. IF A STUDENT.
TENDED KNOW FOR PROFIT COLLEGE
THEY WOULD STILL BE IN A BETTER
POSITION THE ECONOMY THAN IF
THEY HAD ATTENDED A FOR PROFIT
COLLEGE.
BUT I'M SPEAKING TO THE CHOIR
HERE ON THIS UP.
SO.
BUILDING SOMETHING THAT WORKED
FOR CALIFORNIA'S STRANDED
WORKERS.
MEANS ALLOWING THE COMMUNICATIVE
SYSTEM.
TO MOVE FORWARD AND DESIGN A
PLATFORM.
THAT CAN REACH THEM.
NOW.
THIS.
ONLINE COLLEGE THIS PERSONALIZED
LEARNING PLATFORM.
WILL FOCUS ON SHORT TERM
CREDENTIALS.
MICROCREDIT JULES
BUT CREDENTIALS.
THAT ALLOW A STUDENT TO GAIN JOB
SKILLS.
FOR THE PURPOSE OF ECONOMIC
MOBILITY AND IS INTENT THAT
THESE INDIVIDUALS WILL BE ABLE
TO STACK THEM.
AND AS WE CONTINUE TO BUILD ON
THEM CREATE AN ON RAMP.
FOR FURTHER CREDENTIALS AT ONE
OF OUR HUNDRED FOURTEEN COLLEGES
OR THROUGH THE ONLINE EDUCATION
INITIATIVE.
SECOND THIS
PERSONALIZED LEARNING PLATFORM
WILL PROVIDE A FULL RANGE OF
SUPPORTS.
THAT WE NO STUDENTS NEED
INCLUDING TUTORING COACHING
MENTORING.
AND HOW WILL THIS BE DONE
THIS WILL BE DONE.
BY US PARTNERING.
WITH LABOR.
WITH EMPLOYERS.
INDUSTRY SECTOR REPRESENTATIVES.
AND WITH REGIONAL LEADERS.
AS WELL AS OUR HUNDRED FOURTEEN
COLLEGES MANY OF THEM HAVE A
GREAT FOOTHOLD IN THE REGIONS
THAT WERE TALKING ABOUT BUT THEY
NEED ADDITIONAL CAPACITY TO
REACH MORE WORKERS.
IT WILL BE DONE IN PARTNERSHIP.
AND I.
.
I AM CONVINCED
THAT.
PARTNERS AND I'M TALKING ABOUT
HERE TODAY.
ARE VERY MUCH INTERESTED IN
DEVELOPING OUT THESE PATHWAYS
IN ENSURING THAT WE REACHED THE
WORKERS THAT WERE TALKING ABOUT.
ON THE SECOND DOCUMENT YOU HAVE
WE HAVE THAT.
WE DESCRIBE THE CRITERIA.
BY WHICH
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
IS EVALUATING THE POTENTIAL
PATHWAYS HAS BEEN A LOT OF
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT ARE THE
PATHWAYS THAT YOU'RE TALKING.
SO FIRST WE WANTED TO BE VERY
CAREFUL AND WORK WITH OUR LABOR
AND EMPLOYER PARTNERS.
TO ENSURE THAT WE DESIGN
PRINCIPLES
DESIGN PRINCIPLES.
THAT WILL GUIDE US IN DEVELOPING
THE PATHWAYS.
SO THE DOCUMENT YOU HAVE
OUTLINES.
HOW THAT'S GONNA WORK WE WILL
FOCUS ON IN DEMAND?
FIELDS.
IT WILL BE STUDENT CENTERED
COMPETENCY BASED FOCUSED ON JOB
AREAS THAT REQUIRE SCALABLE
RESPONSE.
BUILT ON EXISTING AND EMERGING
TECHNOLOGIES AND IMPLEMENTED
THROUGH STRONG PARTNERSHIPS
THOSE ARE OUR PRINCIPLES.
SO.
HOW WOULD WE MEASURE SUCCESS?
WE WOULD MEASURE SUCCESS.
BY WHETHER OR NOT.
AN INDIVIDUAL
STRANDED WORKER GAINS MORE
ECONOMIC MOBILITY DO THEY HAVE
WAGE GAINS AT THE END OF THE
DAY.
THIS IS ABOUT.
ECONOMIC MOBILITY DO THEY HAVE
DO THEY GET A PROMOTION DO THEY
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY INTO A
DIFFERENT FIELD DO THEY HAVE
WAGE GAINS.
AND CAN THEY CONTINUE THEIR
EDUCATION ON TO A HIGHER LEVEL
CREDENTIAL.
THAT IS
THAT MEANS BY WHICH WE EXPECT
HOLD OURSELVES ACCOUNTABLE.
SO.
WE HAVE IDENTIFIED AT LEAST
THREE AREAS THAT WE'RE GOING TO
FOCUS ON.
TO OUR VERTICAL PATHWAYS.
.
AND ONE IS A HORIZONTAL
PATHWAYS.
SO.
THAT INFORMATION IS.
IT'S IN YOUR PACKET BUT.
AS YOU CAN IMAGINE WE'RE
LOOKING AT.
.
AT AT.
THE HEALTHCARE FIELD.
.
AS WELL AS INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY.
FOR THE HORIZONTAL PATHWAY WERE
FOCUSED ON.
ADVANCING INDIVIDUALS WHO WANT
TO BE FIRST LINE SUPERVISORS.
AND HOW DO WE LAND ON THOSE AS I
SAID WE HAVE BEEN WORKING HARD.
WITH OUR PARTNERS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE TO IDENTIFY THOSE
PATHWAYS.
I WILL BEGIN TO.
TO CLOSE.
IN ORDER TO ALLOW TIME FOR
QUESTIONS BUT.
LET ME.
TAKE SOME TIME TO CLARIFY.
SOME MISCONCEPTIONS ARE SOME
MYTHS.
FIRST OF ALL LET ME BE CLEAR.
WE HAVE NO INTENTION
NO DESIRE AND THERE IS NO
THOUGHT.
TO THE NOTION THAT WE WANT TO
PRIVATIZE CORPORATE TIES OR
COMMERCIALIZE THE CALIFORNIA
COMMITTEE CODES.
I AM A PRODUCT OF CALIFORNIA
CAN BE.
THREE OF MY FOUR KIDS ARE
PRODUCTS OF CALIFORNIA ME
CAUSES.
THIS IS A CROWN JEWELS.
IN OUR NATION WE ARE GOING TO DO
NOTHING.
TO PRIVATIZE THIS IS
WE ARE GOING TO REMAIN A PUBLIC
SYSTEM. THAT.
REACHES MORE STUDENTS THROUGH
INNOVATION.
SECOND.
WE DON'T TEND TO OR HAVE ANY
DESIRE TO CANNIBALIZE ENROLLMENT
FROM OUR HUNDRED FOURTEEN
COLLEGES.
SO MATTER FACT WE WANT TO BUILD.
THE ENROLLMENT FOR A HUNDRED
FOURTEEN COLLEGES.
MANY YOU UNDERSTAND.
THERE ARE COLLEGES ARE NERVOUS.
THEY'RE NERVOUS BECAUSE WE HAVE
ENROLLMENT DECLINE IN THE STATE.
OUR COLLEGES ARE STRUGGLING.
TO GET THE ENROLLMENT THEY NEED
TO MAKE THEIR BASE
FUNDING.
PROPOSAL THAT YOU HAVE COMING UP
NEXT
FOCUSES ON THAT.
BUT WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HERE IS REACHING STUDENTS.
THAT NEED JOB SKILL CREDENTIALS
NOT THE TYPICAL UNDERGRADUATE
EDUCATION HAPPENS AT OUR FOUR
HUNDRED FOURTEEN COLLEGES.
SO WE DON'T SEE THAT THIS WOULD
CANNIBALIZE IS MATTER FACT WE
THINK IT WOULD CREATE A NEW CO
HEART.
OF INDIVIDUALS WHO THEN CAN
ACCESS MORE EDUCATION HIGHER
LEVEL CREDENTIALS AT A HUNDRED
FOURTEEN COLLEGES.
SO WE THINK THAT THIS WILL BE A
NET BENEFIT.
THE ENTIRE SYSTEM.
THERE'S ALSO BEEN A LOT OF TALK
ABOUT.
THE HUNDRED FIFTEENTH COLLEGE
BEAN.
.
THE FAITHFUL TO COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING.
IT WOULD ABSOLUTELY BE.
A COLLECTIVE BARGAINING.
COLLEGE.
THE FACULTY IN THE CLASSIFIED
STAFF WOULD HAVE. EVERY RIGHT IN
OPPORTUNITY.
CHOOSE A BARGAINING UNIT.
TO NEGOTIATE.
SALARY.
WORKING CONDITIONS JUSTICE ALL
OF OUR HUNDRED FOURTEEN
COLLEGES.
THAT WOULD NOT CHANGE AND THAT
IS OUR COMMITMENT.
SO IF THERE ARE SUGGESTIONS THAT
THIS GROUP HAS TO CLARIFY THAT.
WE'D BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO TAKE
THOSE
.
ALSO THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF TALK.
IF THESE ADULTS
CANNOT LEARN.
IN AN ONLINE PLATFORM.
.
AND AFTER I PAUSE IN CONSIDER.
WHERE THAT COMES FROM I I HAVE
TO?
?
TRIED TO RESPOND.
AS.
.
CALMLY AS POSSIBLE.
THESE INDIVIDUALS LEARN
EVERYDAY.
ON THE JOB.
THESE OUR VETERANS WHO LEARNED A
GREAT DEAL OF SKILLS. WHILE IN
THE MILITARY THESE ARE
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE MASTERED
THEIR CRAFT IN THEIR PARTICULAR
JOB THEY CAN'T WORK.
BUT THEY'VE LEARNED THROUGH
COMPETENCY BASED EDUCATION THEY
HAVE LEARNED THROUGH.
EXPERIENCE IN TRIAL THAN
DEMONSTRATING A COMPETENCY.
WE BELIEVE THAT THEY CAN
CONTINUE TO LEARN.
AND I THINK WE OWE IT TO THEM TO
LET THEM PROVE TO US THAT THEY
CAN'T MARK.
SO.
DOES ONLINE EDUCATION WORK FOR
ADULTS.
I THINK IF YOU CONSIDER THE
DATA.
ON ON ONLINE EDUCATION FOR
UNDERGRADUATE EDUCATION.
OUR FACULTY HAVE CLOSE TO
SUCCESS GAP BUT LISTEN FIVE
PERCENT TODAY BETWEEN BRITAIN
ORDER EDUCATION AN ONLINE
EDUCATION SO I HAVE GREAT FAITH
IN OUR FACULTY AND BY THE WAY
WILL BE OUR FACULTY TO TEACH.
THESE COURSES.
UP AND FURTHER MORE.
IF YOU LOOK AT COMPETENCY BASED
PROGRAMS FOR ADULT LEARNERS
ACROSS THE NATION
THEY HAVE SERVED ADULT LEARNERS
VERY WELL.
AND WE WANT TO CONTINUE.
TO PROVIDE A THAT OPPORTUNITY
FOR THESE ADULT LEARNERS SO.
.
WHAT ARE WE GOING TO DO NEXT?
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK
PARTNERS
WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO TRY AN
IRON OUT THE PATHWAYS IN THE
SKILLS THAT ARE PARTNERS FEEL
ARE THE.
A CRITICAL NEED IN CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO BUILD
COALITIONS.
AND WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
HIGHLIGHT. INDIVIDUALS WHO WOULD
BENEFIT FROM THIS.
I HAD THE CHANCE EARLIER TODAY
TO MEET.
ROCKS AND VALENCIA WAS HERE
TODAY.
AND I HOPE YOU HAVE THE CHANCE
TO HEAR FROM HER LATER ON.
SHE WAS ONE OF THE STUDENTS.
SHE WAS A STUDENT ONE F OUR
COLLEGES WHO DESPITE HER LOVE OF
LEARNING.
STRUGGLE TO COMPLETE A
TRADITIONAL EDUCATION CREDENTIAL
BECAUSE SHE HAD TO WORK.
SHE HAD TO SUPPORT HER FAMILY
AND SHE COULDN'T DROP
EVERYTHING.
TO ATTEND PART TIME OR FULL TIME
AT ONE OF OUR TRADITIONAL
COLLEGES.
SHE'S HERE TODAY AND I HOPE YOU
GIVE HER A CHANCE TO SHARE HER
STORY.
SO IN CLOSING I WANT TO
REITERATE THE APPROACH.
WE WILL PROVIDE FOR A PUBLIC
QUALITY AFFORDABLE EDUCATION TO
THESE UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES.
WE RECOGNIZE THAT THIS BODY.
CAN AND SHOULD HOLD US
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THOSE OUTCOMES.
WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT WE DON'T
HAVE FOR THE FOR PROFITS.
A AND.
THAT WE WILL LEARN FROM THE
EXPERIENCE AND CONTINUE TO
IMPROVE.
THE OUTCOMES FOR THE STUDENTS.
AND PROVIDE FOR A PATH TOWARD
ECONOMIC GROWTH AND SUCCESS.
I THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME.
TAKE THE TIME.
TO COMMUNICATE AND ARTICULATE
TO YOU WHY WE FEEL THIS IS SO
IMPORTANT.
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT.
THANK YOU WITHOUT SOME QUESTIONS
FOR YOU BUT FOR US TO ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND LA GO
TO AND TO GIVE THEIR OVERUSED.
THINK YOU I GOOD MORNING WRITE
SO HE SAT WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
I WANT TO BUILD OFF SOME OF THE
OTHER COMMENTS THAT CHANCE ROLE
WE MADE.
REGARDING THE PROBLEM STATEMENT
AND ALSO PROVIDE MORE
SPECIFICITY ON SPECIFIC
COMPONENTS OF AT THE PROPOSAL.
SO WE BROUGHT THIS PROPOSAL
FORWARD BECAUSE WE SEE THIS AS A
WAY TO PROVIDE INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE CURRENTLY NOT BEING SERVED
BY THE EXISTING COMMITTEE
COLLEGES WITH AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
SOCIAL MOBILITY. AS CHANCELLOR
OAKLEY NOTED WE KNOW WITH
CERTAINTY THAT THE SYSTEM IS NOT
CURRENTLY SERVING THESE TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION CALIFORNIANS.
OUT WE OFTEN TALK ABOUT
PREPARING FOR THE NEXT RECESSION
SO WE SEE THIS AS AN INVESTMENT
ON THE PEOPLE'S SIDE. ANTIPOPE
TO GUARD AGAINST NEXT RECESSION.
ARE OFFICE ANALYZED AT CENSUS
BUREAU DATA OF UNEMPLOYMENT OF
INDIVIDUALS.
AT IT AS PART A LAST RECESSION
AND HOW THOSE INDIVIDUALS
RECOVERED AND NOT SURPRISINGLY.
INDIVIDUALS WITHOUT ANY POST
SECONDARY CREDENTIAL AND HAD THE
HIGHEST UNEMPLOYMENT RATES AND
RECOVERED AT A MUCH SLOWER PACE
AFTER THE NEXT RECESSION.
CHANCELLOR OAKLEY ALSO MENTIONED
THE ROLE OF PRIVATE INSTITUTIONS
AND WE SEE THIS AS AN
AFFORDABILITY ISSUE WE KNOW THAT
PRIVATE AND FOR PROFIT
INSTITUTIONS AN OUT OF STATE
INSTITUTIONS CAN CAUSE SEVENTY
NINE TIMES MORE PER UNIT THAT
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
THIS ON MY COLLEGE WHAT OFFERED
AFFORDABLE OPTION CONSISTENT
WITH THE FORTY SIX DOLLAR PER
UNIT.
FEE REQUIRED OF THE COMMITTEE
COLLEGES AND THE COLLEGE WOULD
OFFER FEE WAIVERS CONSISTENT
WITH AT THE OTHER COLLEGES.
WE ALSO SEE AT THIS PROPOSAL IN
LINE WITH AN OVER. AFRI MORGAN
THE BUDGET OF ACCESS WITH
SUCCESS
SO IT'S CHANCEL YOU TRANSFER
OAKLEY MENTION AND I'M ONE OF
THE QUESTIONS HAS BEEN.
HAS HOW EFFECTIVE IS ON MINE FOR
THESE INDIVIDUALS.
I WOULD HIGHLIGHT THE MULTIPLE
STUDIES INDICATE THAT OLDER
STUDENTS HAD TO PERFORM WELL IN
A SELF DIRECTED.
SUCH AS AN ONLINE ENVIRONMENT.
AND RESEARCH ALSO INDICATES THAT
STUDENT SUPPORT SERVICES AND A
PROPERLY STRUCTURED ONLINE
ENVIRONMENTS IS A CRITICAL FOR
ASSURING SUCCESS.
WHICH LEADS ME TO IT ANOTHER
SIGNIFICANT UP COMPONENTS OF THE
ONLINE COLLEGE PROPOSAL WHICH IS
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF A RESEARCH
AND DEVELOPMENT UNIT. SO THE
TRAILER BILL REQUIRES THAT THE
ONLY COLLEGE WHO ESTABLISH THIS
UNIT. THE UNIT WILL ASSESS DATA
METRICS AS SOON IN PROGRESS
IT WILL INFORM INSTRUCTIONAL AND
SUPPORT STRATEGIES AND ASSURE
THAT THE THE TECHNOLOGY IS
WORKING OUT FOR THIS GROUP OF
INDIVIDUALS OF WORKING LEARNERS.
THE UNIT WILL CONSTANTLY REVIEW
COLLEGE PROGRAMS STUDENT
LEARNING DATA STUDENT SUPPORT
OPTIONS SUIT AND STUDENTS
EMPLOYMENT AFTER A COMPLETION OF
THE PROGRAM TO ENSURE THAT
STUDENTS ARE SUCCESSFUL IN THEIR
INTENDED INDUSTRY.
TO THAT END THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSES A HUNDRED
MILLION ONE TIME AND TWENTY
MILLION I'M GOING FOR THE ONLINE
COLLEGE. THE ON GOING FIND THE
WOULD SUPPORT.
OPERATIONS ACTIVITIES INCLUDING
FUNDING FOR THE RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT UNIT OUT LICENSING
AND MAINTENANCE OF TECHNOLOGY
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AS WELL
AS SALARIES AND BENEFITS FOR THE
COLLEGES STAFF.
THE ONE TIME FILE A FUNDS WHAT
SUPPORT ACTIVITIES SUCH AS
ACQUIRING RELEVANCE TECHNOLOGIES
AND INFRASTRUCTURE SECURING
ACCREDITATION ESTABLISHING KEY
PARTNERSHIPS WITH EMPLOYERS AND
DEVELOPING BUSINESS PROCESS
HE'S.
THE COLLEGE AS TRANSFER OF THE
MEASURE WILL BE HELD TO THE SAME
ACCOUNTABILITY METRICS AND
PERFORMANCE INDICATORS AS ALL
OTHER COMMITTEE COLLEGES.
AND I WILL REPORTS THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE ON THOSE SPECIFIED
ITEM AT METRICS INCLUDE IN THE
TRAILER BILL INCLUDING OUTCOMES
FOR THE STUDENTS.
THE ONLY COLLEGE WOULD BE AN
INDEPENDENT BODY THAT IS
GOVERNED BY AN INDEPENDENT
DISTRICT GUIDED BY THE
PRINCIPLES ESTABLISHED BY THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. WHILE THE
COLLEGE WILL WORK CLOSELY WITH
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE JUST
LIKE ANY COLLEGE IT WILL BE RUN
BY A COLLEGE PRESIDENT AND HIS
OR HER STAFF.
THE BOARD OF GOVERNORS OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE COLLEGES
WILL INITIALLY SERVE AS THE
GOVERNING BOARD OF THE COLLEGE.
NO LATER THAN TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
A DISTRICTS SPECIFIC BOARD OF
TRUSTEES WOULD BE ESTABLISHED.
I'M SO THANK YOU AND ALSO HAPPY
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
ALEJO'S.
A GOOD A GOOD MORNING I TEARS
THAT MEMBERS OF BOTH COMMITTEES
THAT GROUP BOTH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. I'M WE DID A
PATH A HANDOUT THAT I WOULD
BECOME SUMMARIZES.
BATHA BACKGROUND ON THE
PROPOSAL IN SUMMER DESIROUS OF
BEEN A RECOMMENDATION.
IF ARE CHEAP WILL SKIP OVER
DRACULA PAGE FIVE OF THAT
ASSESSMENT WHICH IS WHERE WE.
START WITH OUR ASSESSMENT I
THINK. YOU'VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT
THE SPECIFICS OF THE OF THE
PROPOSAL AT THIS POINT.
I I THINK THERE ARE ARE A KEY
CONCERN WITH THIS PROPOSAL IS
THAT.
THAT THE PROPOSED SOLUTION IS
NOT TIED TO SPECIFIC ROUTE
ISSUES.
THAT THAT THAT THE PROPOSAL'S
WITH PARTICULARLY ADDRESSED
EXOTIC IN GENERAL WE DON'T AND
CONCERNS WITH THE.
IN THE ADMINISTRATION'S
INTEREST IN PROVIDING ADDITIONAL
EDUCATIONAL OPTIONS FOR THIS
PARTICULAR DEMOGRAPHIC GROUP
THAT WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THAT IF
AMONG THE MOST VULNERABLE.
INTERSTATE THAT IS.
OF MOST LIKELY TO DO WORSE IN
RECESSION THAN HAVE A HARDER
TIME RECOVERING.
THERE ARE THERE ARE A LOT OF
CALIFORNIA WHO DON'T HAVE ANY
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION AND
TRYING TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL.
ARE KIND OF A CHANGE THE WAY WE
PROVIDE SERVICES TO THEM SO THEY
CAN INCREASE THEIR EDUCATIONAL
COMES THE DIPPING WE HAVE NO
CONCERNS WITH THAT PARTICULAR
ISSUE.
I THINK OUR OUR OUR KEEP OUR KEY
CONCERN IS THAT IT IN THE
PROPOSAL THERE'S NO
CLARIFICATION OF WHAT WHAT WE
THINK ARE THE MAIN BARRIERS FOR
THIS GROUP.
NOT NO INFORMATION THAT GIVE
THE FENCE THAT THAT THERE IS A
SPECIFIC UP PROBLEM WITH ACCESS
THAT IS THAT IS. THAT IT'S BEEN
THOUGHT BY THE ON MY COMMUTE
BECAUSE THEY THINK THAT OUR
PARTY CONCERN AND AND AND MORE
SPECIFICALLY.
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THE
STUDENT IS NOT BEING SERVED BY
THE BY THE EXISTING
COMMUNICATIVE BETTER I DON'T
THINK WE HAVE A CLEAR
INDICATION.
THAT WE THINK THAT THE COLLEGES
ARE DOING SOMETHING WRONG TO
PREVENTING THESE
STUDENTS FROM BEING SERVED
THIRTY POTENTIAL STUDENTS FROM
BEING SERVANTS I THINK. WITHOUT
HAVING A CLEAR SENSE OF WHAT WE
THINK BUT WHAT ARE THE BARRIERS
THAT THE COLLEGES FIXING. IF
IT'S HARD FOR US TO FEEL
CONFIDENT THAT THIS INVESTMENT
WHEN THE THIRTY RESULT IN THE IN
THE OUTCOME IMPROVEMENT OUTCOMES
THAT WE WANT.
PREEMPT IN PARTICULAR SO WE LET
ARE A FEW OTHER A PARTICULAR
ISSUES THAT ARE IN OUR OFFICE
ONE OF THING I WOULD I WOULD.
PLAN I WAS ALSO.
THAT IS CHALLENGING ISSUE OF
TRYING TO FIND PARTNERSHIPS
ACROSS THE STATE BALL BEING A
STATEWIDE PROGRAM SO I THINK.
WE KNOW THAT IN MOST OF THE A
PROPOSED PATHWAYS THAT THAT DID
MISTER SMITH CONSIDERING. THERE
IS SOME KIND OF A NEED FOR A
HANDS ON COMPONENT WHETHER THAT
BE AT A COLLEGE. WHETHER THAT BE
RUN BY INDUSTRY WHETHER THAT THE
BEAST I'M.
IN SOME ASPECT EVEN JUST FINDING
SPACE FOR THAT TO BE AVAILABLE
THAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN ACROSS THE
STATE.
I'M I THINK IT'S UNCLEAR FROTH.
HOW DOES? PARTNERSHIP WILL BE
DEVELOPED ALL ACROSS THE STATE
I'M IN ORDER FOR THE PROGRAMS TO
REALLY CREATE THE GIVE FOLKS THE
SKILLS THAT ARE NECESSARY WE
THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT.
BUT IF THAT IF THAT CAN HAPPEN
STATEWIDE THE NEITHER THOSE
SKILLS ARE NOT COULD BE
AVAILABLE OR TWO YOU HAVE SINCE
THE REGIONAL PROGRAMS THROUGH
THIS ONLINE COLLEGE IN AND.
TO US I THINK THE ISSUE OF
CREATING AN ONLINE BECAUSE TO
CREATE REGIONAL PROGRAM THINGS A
LOT CONSIDERING THAT. THAT THE
COLLEGES THEMSELVES ARE SORT OF
REGIONAL AND.
ON. THE THE OTHER THING I THINK
WE WERE JUST HIGHLIGHT AGAIN OF
THAT.
CREATING THE A NEW COLLEGE
COMPARED TO WORKING WITHIN THE
EXISTING SYSTEM MEANS THAT YOU
HAVE TO BUILD UP AN ORGANIZATION
FROM THE GROUND UP THAT MEANS
IT'S GOING TO TAKE A LOT LONGER
TO GET THINGS UP AND RUNNING IN
THE ME THAT IT LIKELY WILL BE
MORE COSTLY.
AND THEN BEFORE.
ANY ACCREDITATION YOU ARE GONNA
HAVE STUDENTS WHO ARE ENTERING
THE PROGRAM.
IN ERROR ARE.
IN A PROGRAM THAT'S NOT
ACCREDITED WHICH MEANS THEY
CAN'T APPLY FOR FEDERAL
FINANCIAL AID AND THEY CAN'T
TRANSFER THE CREDITS TO ANOTHER
SCHOOL.
I'M SO ANDTHEN SWITCHING OVER
DEFEAT SIX JUST OUR ISSUES ARM
FREE TO CONSIDER WE DO THINK
THAT THERE ARE.
ELEMENTS OF THE PROPOSAL OR THE
ELEMENT THAT HAVE BEEN DISCUSSED
OF THINGS THAT WOULD BE PART OF
THE COLLEGE THAT. THAT ARE
PROMISING THAT SEEMS TO BE
ADDRESSING ISSUES THAT WE'VE
HEARD IN THE PAST.
FOR EXAMPLE THE IDEA OF HAVING
MORE PERSONALIZED COMPETENCY
BASED PROGRAM IS SOMETHING THAT
WE'VE HEARD.
THERE BE CONCERNS ABOUT AND
BEING ABLE TO. I USE THAT AS A
WAY TO RECOGNIZE THE PRIOR
LEARNING AND SKILLS THE PEOPLE
WHO COME IN AND OUT TO GET
TRAINING MAKES A LOT OF FANS.
BUT AGAIN FOR US WITH
BEING CLEAR ON WHY THE ONLINE
COLLEGES THIS.
THAT. THERE ARE YOU COULD ALSO
EXPLORE STATEWIDE IMPROVEMENTS
IN YOUR EXISTING FHA THUMB.
FOR EXAMPLE FINDING WAYS TO.
ENCOURAGES COLLEGES TO DO
COMPETENCY BASED EDUCATION ONE
OF THE WAYS THAT YOU CAN DO THAT
IS BY CHANGING THE FISCAL MODEL
WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT YOU'LL
DISCOVER THE NEXT ITEM.
I'M SO DID SO WE DO THINK THAT
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF KEY
QUESTIONS THAT WOULD BE TOGETHER
TO TO.
TO MOVE IN THE DIRECTION AND
BECAUSE THE FIFTH AVE A SOLUTION
THAT WE THINK ADDRESS OF THE.
THAT THE ROOT ISSUES WE
ENCOURAGE WHAT FUTURE IT YOU
MIGHT STILL BE INTERESTED AND IN
PURSUING THIS KIND OF APPROACH
WE ENCOURAGE THOSE SEIZURE TO.
GATHER MORE INFORMATION ABOUT
WHAT THE UNDERLYING PROBLEMS
ARE.
WHAT ARE THE ROOT CAUSES OF
THESE PROBLEMS AND AND REALLY
THINK ABOUT HOW A NEW ONLINE
COLLEGE COULD BE DESIGNED TO
RESPOND TO THOSE ISSUES AND THEN
HOW COULD BE FUNDED HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THOSE
OBJECTIVES?
THANK YOU.
START NOW WITH OUR DISCUSSION
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS.
IT'S A MEDINA.
THANK YOU FOR THE PRESENTATION.
.
I I MIGHT START BY SAYING THAT I
WAS SKEPTICAL.
WHEN I IRST A HERD OF THE PLAN.
I BELIEVE.
I WAS INFORMED OF THE PLAN OF
THE DAY BEFORE THE GOVERNOR PER
A REVEALED HIS BUDGET.
AND THE GOVERNOR'S STAFF CAME TO
GIVE ME A HEADS UP.
THAT.
THE GOVERNOR WAS PROPOSED IN
THIS.
I WAS SKEPTICAL THAT.
BUT AFTER SITTING HERE AND
LISTENING TO THE PRESENTATION I
HAVE TO HONESTLY SAY THAT I HAVE
MUCH MORE SKEPTICAL NOW. THAN I
WAS WHEN I FIRST HEARD.
I I PRIDE MYSELF ON BEING AN
EDUCATOR.
AN EDUCATOR FOR THIRTY FOUR
YEARS IN THE CLASSROOM.
AND I TURNED TO MY COLLEAGUE WHO
SHARED MY EXPERIENCE OF BEING A
CLASSROOM TEACHER.
AND I DO NOT.
.
YOU KNOW.
I DON'T CONSIDER MYSELF AN
EXPERT IN MUCH.
AND A LOT OF THE THINGS THAT I
GET TO VOTE ON HERE IN THE STATE
LEGISLATURE HAVE TO DO WITH MANY
OTHER THINGS THAT I KNOW A LOT
ABOUT.
AND I DO THE BEST I CAN.
TO TRY TO FIND OUT ABOUT THOSE
ISSUES.
KNOW WHETHER THEY BE WATER.
INSURANCE.
HEALTH. AND I DO MY BEST TO GET
MYSELF.
WHERE I FEEL THAT I'M
KNOWLEDGEABLE? IN THAT.
BUT IN EDUCATION HAVING SPENT
THIRTY FOUR YEARS IN THE
CLASSROOM.
THIRTEEN YEARS ON THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES OF A COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
SEVERAL YEARS ANA KATE TWELVE.
BOARD. I DO FEEL I KNOW A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT EDUCATION.
I SHARE WITH THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM.
THE SENSE OF URGENCY.
TO REACH US STUDENTS PERHAPS OR
INDIVIDUALS IN THE WORKPLACE.
WHO HAVE NOT BENEFITED FROM?
?
THE EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM.
THE BEST THAT THEY COULD.
OR DID THE BEST THAT THEY CAN.
OR SHORT. IN A SYSTEM.
THAT IS DESIGNED TO TRY TO HELP
OTHERS.
BUT I SEE IN FRONT OF THOSE.
AND IDEA.
WHO? EVERYTHING THAT I HAVE IN
FRONT OF ME RIGHT NOW DOESN'T
SHOW ME. THAT IT IS BEEN
THOROUGHLY THOUGHT OUT.
AT ALL.
AND I TAKE TO HEART.
WOULD THE L. A. O.. OF BRINGS
HERE THAT THIS IS NOT LOOKING AT
THE ROOT CAUSES.
THE DO YOU KNOW WHY WHY IS IT
THAT THESE TWO AND A HALF
MILLION.
STUDENTS
OR NOT STUDENTS INDIVIDUALS NOW
ADULTS IN THE WORKPLACE HAVEN'T
BEEN ABLE TO BETTER. MAKE USE
OF.
.
THE EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM NOW IN
PLACE.
THE IDEA OF BEGINNING FROM
SCRATCH.
FROM BEGINNING FROM.
.
NOT.
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF HER OF THE
HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN COLLEGES
THAT WE HAVE ALREADY.
.
IS IS BOTHERSOME TO ME.
I SEE. NO EVIDENCE STILL THAT
THIS METHOD WOULD BE THE BEST
METHOD.
TO TO BRING THESE.
TWO HUNDRED FIVE MILLION
INDIVIDUALS UP I DON'T SEE ANY
COLLABORATION YOU'RE WITH
EXISTING PROGRAMS OF.
.
THE REGIONAL.
WORKPLACE.
IMPROVEMENT.
STRUCTURES THAT ARE THERE.
SO I I.
YOU NO LOOK FORWARD TO MORE
QUESTIONS BY MY OWN COLLEAGUES
BUT I DO NOT SEE EVIDENCE.
THAT THIS REALLY.
WOULD DO WHAT WE WANTED TO DO.
I DON'T.
.
AND SO I I WILL I WILL LISTEN NO
LAST MORE QUESTIONS BUT AYE AYE.
HARD PRESSED TO IT IT SEEMS LIKE
TO ME YOU KNOW THIS IS TAKING
SOMETHING THAT IS AN IDEA. AND
JUST PUT IT FORWARD. AND.
.
ASKING THE LEGISLATURE ON FAITH.
TO TO.
APPROVED.
I'M I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO MORE
QUESTIONS AND.
HEARING MORE.
IT'S A LITTLE.
WELCOME IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU
AGAIN.
.
I HAVE A LOT OF QUESTIONS SIR.
I THINK.
.
PROBABLY THERE'S LOTS OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE SKEPTICAL ABOUT THE
PROPOSAL THAT YOU'RE MAKING AND
YOU'VE MADE AT GOOD PRESENTATION
HERE. OF THIS MORNING BUT
THERE'S.
VERY LITTLE MEAT ON THE BONES
RIGHT NOW AND I APPRECIATE
HAVING THE OVERVIEW BUT THAT'S
JUST WHAT IT IS A SIN IT'S AN
OVERVIEW SO I I LOOK FORWARD TO.
RECEIVING MORE DETAIL AND MORE
INFORMATION.
.
PRIOR TO OUR.
HAVING TO VOTE ON WHETHER TO
MOVE THIS FORWARD OR NOT.
COUPLE OF THAT BACK QUESTIONS I
HAVE A AT NIGHT I THINK.
YOU DIDN'T PUT IT EXACTLY THIS
WAY BUT.
AT LEAST SOME OF THE FOCUS A.
ON THIS HAT ADDRESSES ARE ISSUE
OF INCOME OR IS INTENDED TO
ADDRESS OUR ISSUE OF INCOME
INEQUALITY THAT IS GROWING IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO. IF
WE ARE REACHING OUT TO THAT
COHORT THAT TO THAT SADLY VERY
LARGE COHORT OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
FALL INTO THE LOWER INCOME.
CATEGORIES.
HOW ARE WE GOING TO ASSURE FOR
EXAMPLE THAT THOSE FOLKS HAVE
BASIC CA BASELINE? A KEYBOARD
COMPETENCY I'M SO THAT THEY CAN
AVAIL THEMSELVES OF A PROGRAM
LIKE THIS.
HOW WILL THEY AVAIL THEMSELVES
OF EQUIPMENT THAT IS UP TO THE
TO THE CHALLENGE AND A?
?
THE INTERNET CONNECTION WHICH I
PRESUME NEEDS TO BE HIGH SPEED
UP THAT IS NOT AVAILABLE.
A.
AS BROADLY AS WE WOULD LIKE TO
LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR YOU
AT SOME POINT IN THIS PROCESS
TO.
POINT TO THE TYPE OF TECHNOLOGY
THAT YOU ARE LOOKING TO
IMPLEMENT AND DEMONSTRATED FOR
US SO THAT WE UNDERSTAND IT. I
HAVE A.
FAIRLY SIMPLISTIC.
FRANKLY UNDERSTANDING OF ONLINE
LEARNING AND WHAT IT MEANS PART
OF IT'S BASED ON WATCHING MY
SON.
TAKE A PARAMEDIC COURSE.
OUT OF UCLA FOR HIM WAS VERY
EFFECTIVE. BUT THAT LEADS ME TO
ANOTHER QUESTION.
.
IN THAT COURSE AND I AM QUITE
CERTAIN AND. MANY COURSES THAT
ARE TEACHING SKILLS TRAINING.
A LOT OF THE TRAINING IS HANDS
ON YOU SIMPLY CAN'T DO IT AND IN
FRONT OF A MONITOR YOU NEED. AND
HIS CASE HE NEEDS TO BE IN FRONT
OF A. CADAVER FOR SOME OF THE.
SOME OF THE WORK THAT THAT SOME
OF THE LEARNING THAT THEY DO AND
IF YOUR ON TEACHING SKILLS IN
THE IN THE TRADES YOU HAVE TO BE
ABLE TO. PUT YOUR HANDS ON THE
TOOLS AND LEARN HOW TO
MANIPULATE THEM OR.
WHATEVER IT IS YOU'RE YOU'RE
YOU'RE TRAINING FOR SO HOW DO
YOU ACCOMPLISH THAT GOAL THE OUT
THE LAST QUESTION I HAVE AND I
REALLY WOULD LIKE TO INVITE YOU
TO COME BY. MY OFFICE SO WE CAN.
I DIG A LITTLE DEEPER INTO SOME
OF THESE QUESTIONS AND OTHERS.
I'M.
BUT.
IF FATHER AND I I.
DON'T THINK THERE'S SIR OF
A QUESTION THAT TO IT IS WHAT
YOU INTEND IF IF THIS IS
INTENDED TO BE. A BULWARK
AGAINST THE NEXT RECESSION AND
FUTURE RECESSIONS TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE SEEMS A LONG WAY OFF GIVEN
THAT MANY OF THE ECONOMIC CA.
ANALYSES THAT FTA A THAT I'VE
SEEN AND SO.
.
WHY WILL IT TAKE THAT LONG?
AND MAYBE I MISUNDERSTOOD DUH
THE OF THE TIME THE TIMELINE
THAT YOU'RE SUGGESTING. BUT DE A
SEVEN YEAR.
RUN UP SOUNDS LIKE A VERY LONG.
TIME TO ME.
I I THINK SOME OF THE.
UNDERLYING.
ECONOMIC GOALS I ONE OF AYE AYE
ONE UNDERSTAND.
BETTER.
AND I'LL JUST LEAVE IT AT THAT
BUT I.
.
I I THINK THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING WE CAN DO WITH A PROGRAM
LIKE THIS. IS.
.
TEACH SKILLS OUTSIDE THAT ARE
IDENTIFIED AS BEING. IN SHORT
SUPPLY IN THE STATE AND MATCH
UP.
THE APPROPRIATE INDIVIDUALS TO
FILL THOSE JOBS RAISING.
OF THEM IN THE ECONOMY AND
THEIR INCOME CAPACITY.
I IN THE PROCESS.
I DID HAVE ONE OTHER.
.
QUESTION ABOUT.
HOW YOU'LL MEASURE? OF SUCCESS
AND YOU SAID THAT TO.
.
THAT WAS BY MEASURING WHETHER OR
NOT OF PEOPLE HAVE WAGE GAINS.
I I COULD SEE THAT AS A MACRO
MEASUREMENTS BUT NOT AS A MICRO
MEASUREMENT FOR. IT THE
INDIVIDUALS INVOLVED HERE I
DON'T SEE HOW YOU YOU'RE ABLE TO
ONE INDIVIDUALIZED BASIS REALLY.
MEASURE THAT TO ME IT'S THE
ACQUISITION OF.
A OF SKILLS.
.
SO THAT WE KNOW THAT THE
INDIVIDUAL WAS ACTUALLY ACQUIRED
SKILLS THROUGH.
SOME KIND OF TESTING CA A
PROTOCOL WHETHER THAT'S ON THE
JOB OR.
OR OR THROUGH TRADITIONAL
TESTING.
AND IT.
.
OR MAYBE THROUGHOUT THE FACT IS
THAT THOSE THOSE ARE THAT THE
ISSUES AND QUESTIONS THAT.
THAT I HAVE TODAY.
OKAY MISTER O'DONNELL.
THANK YOU HAVE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN.
MISTER BLOOM.
HAPPY PROVIDED AND. FOR ALL OF.
YOU WANT IT KNOW THAT HAVE ANY
OF THEM ADDRESSED HER.
JUST LAYING ABOUT THEIR FOR THE
FUTURE I THINK GOD JUST PUTTING
THE QUESTIONS OUT THERE RIGHT
NOW I THINK WE'RE VERY EARLY IN
THIS FOCUS AREA AND. THAT IS
THROUGH DR. THANK YOU AND I
THINK MISTER CHAIRMAN.
.
TO MY GOOD FARMERS HAD A LOT I
DO BELIEVE WE ARE EARLY IN THIS
PROCESS TO.
I MEAN I I THINK NO ONE HERE IS
QUESTIONING AYE YOUR DEDICATION
CLOSING CERTAINLY.
THAT K. TWELVE ACHIEVEMENT GAP
BUT ALSO BEYOND THE KEY TWELVE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP WHICH CALIFORNIA
HAS PERSISTENTLY HAS AND YOU
KNOW YOUR HISTORY. AYE WITH ME
IN LONG BEACH.
SHOWS YOU'RE VERY DEDICATED. TO
STUDENTS OF ALL AGES IN
CALIFORNIA
SO I APPRECIATE THEM THAT I KNOW
OF YOU SO THAT THAT FOR SURE.
BUT AGAIN ONE OF MY CONCERNS
HERE I'M JUST NOT.
DON'T TOTALLY UNDERSTAND WHERE
WE'RE GOING HERE THAT THAT'S ONE
OF MY CONCERNS.
AND I THINK.
.
WHEN YOU USE THE WORD FAITH AND
I THINK WE ARE. IF WE ARE TO
VOTE IN SUPPORT OF THIS I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF FAITH BECAUSE
AGAIN I I JUST DON'T KNOW WHERE
THIS IS GOING OR WHERE CAN END
UP. I'M WORRIED ABOUT THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES.
I'M COMPETITION BECAME A GOOD
COMPETITION CANNOT BE GOOD I
MEAN IF COMPETITION IS.
I'D I SERVE STUDENTS THE BEST
THAT'S GOOD OF ITS COMPETITION
FOR RESOURCES THAT'S NOT GOOD
THAT'S WHY WONDER WHERE WE GO
DOWN THE ROAD. WHERE WHERE DOES
THIS END UP I MEAN WHO WILL
TEACH THESE CLASSES?
IS THE YOU KNOW YOU SAID NO
PRIVATIZATION I MEAN THERE'S NOT
GOOD SOME PRIVATE OPERATOR IN
TEXAS.
SOMEONE IN A ROOM OPERATING A
COMPUTER.
A BODY WHATEVER THEY CAUGHT
NOWADAYS RIGHT.
TEACHING A CLASS UNTIL WE THAT
CONCERNS ME BECAUSE I WANT SOME
IS CONNECTED TO THE STATE.
AND CONNECTED TO SERVING THE
STUDENTS SO SO YOU MEAN A ANY
CAN YOU COLONIES KNOWER OR NOT
I'M NOT SO CONCERNED ABOUT THAT.
SWITCHED I THINK THESE ARE THESE
ARE THE KIND OF THINGS WE TALK
QUITE. A TALK ABOUT THIS HUNDRED
FIFTEEN COLLEGE SERVING ON. THE
SKILLS GAP.
SO DOES THAT MEAN IT WOULD ONLY
FOCUS ON THE SKILLS GAP OR WOULD
IT TO GO INTO TEACHING GENERAL
EDUCATION CLASSES.
NO IS THAT WHERE THIS
ULTIMATELY.
COULD ADD UP IS THAT BEEN
CONTEMPLATED.
IS THERE SOME WALLED SET UP TO
MAKE SURE THAT SHOULDN'T HAPPEN
SHOULD HAPPEN.
SO THOSE ARE JUST THE KIND OF
THINGS THAT I WORRY ABOUT WHERE
DOES THIS GO. BUSINESS AND THE
AND BECOME THE BIGGEST COLLEGE
AND YOU KNOW TAKE STUDENTS FROM
OTHER COLLEGES WERE JUST PICK
SOMEONE BIG ONLINE SYSTEM WHEN
GUINNESS AND THEN SHARED. HERE I
THINK.
THERE'S A LOT TO BE SAID TO TO
TO EXPERIENCE AN INSTRUCTOR
FIRSTHAND AND IN CONDUCTING
HANDS ON LEARNING.
SO WITH THAT ALL OF THE QUITE
MISTER CHAIR IF YOU WANT TO
RESPOND GREAT IF NOT THAT'S OKAY
TOO.
I'M HAPPY TO RESPOND IF THE
CHAIR.
WISHES.
BUT SO.
.
WHO WILL TEACH?
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FACULTY.
THAT MEET THE MINIMUM
QUALIFICATIONS TO TEACH
THE CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE CULTS
OF.
WE HAVE.
HUNDREDS IF NOT THOUSANDS.
OF FACULTY CREATING ONLINE
CONTENT TODAY.
MANY OF THEM IN THE CAREER
EDUCATION FEEL CREATING
COMPETENCY BASED
CONTACT.
SO WE FEEL THAT WE HAVE.
.
THE CONTENT EXPERTISE ALREADY
IN OUR SYSTEM.
AND WE WANNA GIVE THOSE FACULTY
AND OPPORTUNITY TO SCALE.
WHAT THEY'RE ALREADY DOING?
?
TWO IN TERMS OF COMPETITION.
THE.
THIS PERSONALIZED LEARNING
PLATFORM IS FOCUSED ON MICRO
PRETENSIONS.
JOB SKILLS.
WE ALREADY HAVE THE ONLINE
EDUCATION INITIATIVE
IT IS CREATING OF IS AGGREGATING
ALL OF THE UNDERGRADUATE LEVEL.
ONLINE CONTENT AND AND MAKING IT
AVAILABLE FOR STUDENTS WE WOULD
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THAT.
AND THAT IS SUPPORTED THROUGH A
PROCESS OF.
A PARTNERING WITH THE HUNDRED
FOURTEEN.
SO.
I RECOGNIZE
THAT THIS IS SOMETHING NEW
OF SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE BEEN
CONTEMPLATED BEFORE.
BUT.
I JUST ADDS IF YOU LOOK AT THE
DATA FOR ONLINE COURSES IN THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUTE BECAUSE.
ITIS GROWING MORE RAPIDLY THE
NUMBER OF UNITS STUDENTS ARE
TAKING ONLINE.
IS OUT PACING THE NUMBER OF
UNITS STUDENTS ARE TAKING IN A
BRICK AND MORTAR.
AND WILL SURPASS THAT IN THE
NOT TOO DISTANT.
SO WHETHER OR NOT WE CREATE
SOMETHING HERE
STUDENTS WILL CONTINUE.
TO GRAVITATE TOWARD THOSE
LEARNING ENVIRONMENTS NOT TO
YOUR QUESTION AND AND TO.
MEMBER BLUM'S QUESTION ABOUT
HANDS ON LEARNING ABSOLUTELY.
WE RECOGNIZE.
THAT IN A COMPETENCY BASED MODEL
SOME OF THOSE COMPETENCIES ARE
ARE ARE MEASURED BASED ON. THE
STUDENT'S ABILITY TO MASTER THE
CONTENT ONLINE.
OR IN A PERSONALIZED LEARNING
PLATFORM SOME OF IT HAS TO BE
DEMONSTRATED HANDS ON.
THAT'S WHY WE ARE BUILDING THE
PARTNERSHIPS
NOW.
BETWEEN LABOR. AND YOU KNOW I
WON'T SPEAK FOR THEM THEY CAN
SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES BUT THERE
IS A NEED.
WITH EMPLOYERS.
AND SO WE SAID WE PUT IN FRONT
OF YOUR YOUR.
.
SEATS.
A LIST OF VARIOUS EVENTS WITH
THE DIFFERENT PARTNERS THAT WERE
WORKING WITH TO THINK THROUGH
AND DESIGNED THESE PATHWAYS.
THESE PATHWAYS ARE ALREADY IN
MANY CASES BEING TAUGHT TODAY
JUST ON A SMALLER SCALE.
OF FOR EXAMPLE HERE IN
SACRAMENTO AT CI YOU ONE
THOUSAND IS CREATED.
COUPLE DIFFERENT PROGRAMS THAT
ARE COMPETENCY BASED THAT ALLOW
THEIR MEMBERS TO GAIN CERTAIN
SKILLS THAT ALLOW THEM
PROMOTIONAL OPPORTUNITIES.
SECURELY IN THE IT FIELD.
SO WE WANT TO DO WITH SCALE
THAT.
SO THIS INSTRUCTION IS HAPPENING
THIS IS NOT SOMETHING BRAND NEW
THIS IS JUST THAT'S UP AND THAT
WE HAVE INTENTIONALLY. TRY TO
PULL TOGETHER AND WHY A NEW
COLLEGE.
WE HAVE A HUNDRED FOURTEEN
COLLEGES.
WE GOT TWO HUNDRED FOURTEEN
COLLEGES BECAUSE WE FELT THAT
THERE WAS A NEED
TO BE SERVED.
WHETHER THAT'S COASTLINE COLLEGE
WHICH IS THE COLLEGE WITHOUT
WALLS IN ORANGE COUNTY. OR THE
WORK THAT'S BEING DONE ON WHAT
WILL HOPEFULLY BE OUR NEWEST
COLLEGE IN MADERA.
THERE IS A NEAT AND THAT'S WHY
WE'RE.
WE'RE ORGANIZED ITS WAY.
ALL WE'RE TALKING ABOUT DOING
SERVING ONE MORE ADDITIONAL
NEED.
AND SO.
.
AND THEN FINALLY THERE WAS A
QUESTION ABOUT.
WHY DO WE NEED TO START FROM?
AND I APPRECIATE.
THAT QUESTION AND A COMMENT.
.
ARE HUNDRED FOURTEEN COLLEGES
AND I I YOU KNOW RESPECTFULLY I
KNOW THAT.
A CHAIR MEDINA YOU KNOW EXACTLY
HOW WE'RE COLLEGES OPERATE YOU
HAVE GREAT EXPERIENCE IN OUR
COLLEGE THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE
FACULTY ARE DEDICATED TO THE
MISSION THAT THEY SERVE.
WE WANT THE HUNDRED FIFTEEN
COLLEGE TO BE SOLELY FOCUSED ON
ADULT LEARNERS.
THE INDIVIDUALS WORKING AND
BREATHING AND THE FACULTY
WORKING AT THE ONLINE COLLEGE.
SOLELY FOCUSED ON ADULT LEARNERS
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE THAT IT'S
GOING TO TAKE THAT KIND OF
EFFORT
IN ORDER TO OVERCOME THE
CHALLENGES. THAT EXIST FOR THESE
WORKERS.
SO. HOPEFULLY THAT ANSWERS SOME
OF YOUR QUESTIONS IF I MISSED
ANY BE HAPPY TO COME BACK.
TRY TO GET TO THOSE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER MARTZ
ITCHY.
THANK YOU CHANCE OAKLEY I.
APPRECIATE YOUR PASSION.
AND YOUR.
.
DESIRE TO TRY SOMETHING NEW AND
UP YOU KNOW WHERE AN ESTATE WERE
WERE PROUD OF OUR INNOVATION
ECONOMY AND.
.
YOU KNOW CONCEPTUALLY JUST SEEMS
TO MAKE SENSE THAT THIS IS THE
DIRECTION THAT IT.
WE KNOW ALL OF PUBLIC EDUCATION
IS HEADED.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT.
AND AND WE WE TALKED
IN OUR OFFICE THAT TO YOU ARE
WORKING CLOSELY WITH OUR.
FRIENDS IN LABOR TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEIR CONCERNS ARE
ADDRESSED.
BUT IT IT DOES SEEM LIKE.
SOONER OR LATER WE'RE ALL GOING
TO BE GOING TO TOWARD THIS
DIRECTION AND IT YOU KNOW I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENT
ESPECIALLY ABOUT HOW.
OUR CURRENT ENROLLMENT OUR
CURRENT STUDENTS.
APPEAR TO BE MOVING A TOWARD
THAT DIRECTION AND IN TERMS OF
THEIR ONLINE.
COURSE IN ROMANTIC.
I.
I DO APPRECIATE YOUR LAST FEW
COMMENTS BECAUSE THEY START TO
ADDRESS SOME OF MY.
QUESTIONS FOCUSING ON THE ISSUE
OF WHY WE NEED A WHOLE NEW
ONLINE COMMITTEE COLLEGE. RATHER
THAN JUST EXPANDING EXISTING
ONLINE PROGRAMS YOU MENTIONED
THAT YOU WANTED.
THAT THIS IS TRYING TO MEET A
REAL NEED AND AND THAT THAT NEED
IS TO FOCUS ON. THOSE.
STRANDED WORKERS.
BUT I STILL DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHY.
A NEW.
ONLINE COMMITTEE COLLEGE RATHER
THAN EXPANDING EXISTING ONLINE
PROGRAMS.
IS NECESSARY TO.
IN OF ME THE DE SPECIFIC NEEDS
OF THE STRAND WORKERS.
SO.
.
DID TO SPECIFICALLY TO THAT
QUESTION.
.
AND AND I RECOGNIZE THAT THERE
ARE DIFFERENCES OF OPINION.
BUT AS A FORMER PRESIDENT OF.
A VERY WELL RESPECTED COLLEGE
WHO DID GREAT WORK FOR THE
GREATER LONG BEACH AREA.
.
I RECOGNIZE THAT.
OUR COLLEGES ARE SERVING MANY
MISSIONS.
THERE ARE SOMETIMES OVERWHELMED
BY THE NEED IN THEIR COMMUNITY.
I'M WE ARE ASKING THEM TO
CONTINUOUSLY DO MORE THEN WE
EXPRESSED CONCERN.
ABOUT THE OUTCOMES OF THOSE
STUDENTS.
AND I THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE
THAT THE OUTCOMES OF OUR
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA TO ME
BECAUSE YSTEM ARE NOT WHERE
THEY SHOULD BE. NOT WEAR ANY OF
US WANT TO BE THAT'S NOT A
CRITICISM OF OUR FACULTY OR
COLLEGES OR OUR STAFF.
AT THE CRITICISM OF HOW MUCH
WE'RE ASKING EACH AND EVERY.
OF THOSE HUNDRED FOURTEEN
COLLEGES TO DO.
SO I WANT OUR COLLEGES TO HAVE
THE SPACE AND THE FUNDING AND
THE FOCUS TO SERVE THEIR PRIMARY
MISSIONS IN THEIR COMMUNITIES.
AND TO ADD CAPACITY TO THE
SYSTEM BY ALLOWING FOR THIS
THIS NEW.
ENTITY.
TO SUPPORT THAT CAPACITY
BUILDING.
SO.
I THINK WE'VE HAD MANY.
MANY EXAMPLES THROUGHOUT.
.
OUR HISTORY THE CALIFORNIA
COMMITTEE COLLEGES WHERE WE'VE
SAID WELL LET'S JUST GIVE THE
COMMUNICATIVE IT'S ANOTHER.
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS AND LET
THEM GO TAKE CARE OF THIS
PROBLEM.
I THINK ADULT EDUCATE OUR DULL
BASIC EDUCATION IS A GREAT
EXAMPLE.
WE ALL CARE ABOUT ADULT BASIC
EDUCATION.
WE PUT MONEY TOWARD A BASIC IT'S
GOOD.
I THINK VERY FEW OF US WOULD.
ARGUE THAT ADULT BASIC EDUCATION
IS NOT WORKING WHY.
BECAUSE WE CONTINUE TO PILE ON.
HI I WONDER HUNDRED FOURTEEN
COLLEGES ASKING NOT ONLY TO DEAL
WITH THE PIPELINE STUDENTS THAT
THEY HAVE.
TO TRY AND REACH.
ANOTHER CO HER STUDENT YES THEY
ARE VERY CAPABLE OF DOING THAT
BUT WORK BUT WE WANT TO DO IS
PROVIDE THE CAPACITY REACH
SCALE.
IN A VERY DIFFERENT WAY THAN
WE'RE REACHING TODAY.
THAT IS MY CONCERN.
SCALE WHICH WE NEED TO REACH
IN ORDER TO SERVE.
THE VERY FUNDAMENTAL NEEDS OF
THESE WORKERS.
.
COULD WE INVEST HUNDRED TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN A HUNDRED
FOURTEEN COLLEGES OF COURSE
RICK.
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT THAT
INVESTMENT WOULD PRODUCE THE
RESULTS THAT WE NEED IS A STATE.
AS GREAT AS OUR HUNDRED FOURTEEN
COLLEGES ARE BECAUSE THAT MONEY
WILL BE DISPERSED.
THERE WILL BE NO CENTRAL AREA TO
HOLD ACCOUNTABLE.
AT LEAST WITH THIS.
ENTITY YOU HAVE DIRECT.
OVERSIGHT.
OF ONE COLLEGE THAT IS GEARED
TOWARD ACCOMPLISHING ONE PRIMARY
GOAL.
THAT IS TO UP SKILL WORKERS IN
THE WORKFORCE.
THANK YOU SO MEMORY CHAVEZ.
THANK YOU.
I LIKE TO GO TO THE LA EL.
IN YOUR REPORT.
ON.
I KNOW YOU IT YEAH SKIP TO ONE
THROUGH FIVE BUT I'M GONNA GO
BACK TO.
PAGE TWO.
AND WHEN YOUR COMMENTS A SAYS
ENROLLING IN ONLINE COURSES
OUTSIDE OF HOME DISTRICT IS
DIFFICULT.
STUDENTS MUST APPLY SEPARATELY
FOR ADMISSIONS TO EACH COLLEGE.
AND REGISTER FOR EACH CLASS
SEPARATELY.
THEN ON PAGE FIVE YOU GO DOWN
SAY.
THE MINISTRATION OFF DOES NOT
PROVIDE EVIDENCE THAT WORKING
ADULTS WHO ARE INTERESTED IN
MORE.
EDUCATION.
CANNOT ACCESS IT THROUGH JUSTIN
ONLINE OR IN PERSON.
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
SURE LIKE THOSE ARGUMENTS ARE
GOING AGAINST EACH OTHER THE
DIRECT QUESTION YOU SERVERS.
DO YOU THINK THAT THE
PRESENTATION OF THE TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION.
MEN AND WOMEN AGES TWENTY FIVE
TO THIRTY FOUR ARE STRANDED
WORKERS YOU AGREE WITH HIS
NUMBERS.
RIGHT ARE IRONIES BUT THE
CONCERNS THAT THE TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION NUMBER AT THE GOOD FAITH
FUND DEMOGRAPHIC INFORMATION.
SO DO YOU.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AT THERE'S.
PEOPLE THAT NEED SOME.
SKILLS TO BE. TERM I BELIEVE HIS
WAGE.
HAVE A WAGE GAIN.
YES THAT'S RIGHT.
SO.
MY QUESTION IS ANDY YOU GREED
THAT THERE'S A NEED IS YOUR
ISSUE IS THAT.
NOT THE WHY BUT YOU HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH THE PROCESS AND HOW
EASE ADDRESSING THE PROBLEM IS
LIKE WELL I THINK OUR CONCERN IS
WE DON'T. WIRE THE TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION TO THAT MILLION
WORKERS NOT.
WHAT WHY HAVE THEY NOT BEEN ABLE
TO GET THAT POST SECONDARY AT?
WHAT HAVE BEEN THE BARRIER FOR
THAT I THINK WE DON'T? I DON'T
THINK THAT WE FOR ANYBODY GIVE
US A GOOD REASON FOR WHAT WITH
THAT WITH THE CASE.
IN IN IN GENERAL WHAT WENT ON
BUT ONLINE EDUCATION ISSUES
RIGHT NOW IN IN THE COMMUTE COST
ESTIMATES
STUDENTS WHO ARE OTHER WHITE
HOUSE RD ENROLLED THEY'RE TAKING
A COURSE OR TWO.
TO COMPLEMENT THEIR IN PERSON
COURSES THEY MIGHT HELP THEM
WITH NOT HAVING TO COMMUTE A DAY
MIGHT HELP THEM WITH MAYBE THEY
HAVE ACCESS TO A COURSE THAT
THEY OTHERWISE WOULDN'T BEEN
ABLE TO TAKE BECAUSE THEY HAVE
GOT DOING CONFLICTS WITH
HELPING.
STUDENTS WHO ARE ALREADY
ENROLLED IN THE COLLEGE'S BE
ABLE TO ACCESS OTHER COURSE OF
THE MY HOPE DEMS DUE TO THE
PROFIT THAT'S A GOOD THING
NOTHING VISITING WRONG WITH
THAT.
I THINK ARE OUR CONCERN IS.
WE DON'T KNOW THAT THE REASON
THAT THAT THAT THAT THE TWO
POINT BY MILLION ADULTS ARE NOT
ENROLLED IN THE COLLEGE IT IS
BECAUSE. I
THE COURSES THAT WERE AVAILABLE
ARE NOT ARE ARE NOT.
WILLING TO THEM THAT THEY ARE
THEIR MAIN CHALLENGE IS THAT
THEY DON'T CAN'T GET TO A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE I MEAN IF IF
THAT WAS THE CASE OF ISSUE WITH
ACCESS I HAVE TIME TO DRIVE TO A
COLLEGE AND AN ONLINE PROGRAM.
WE WOULD WE WOULD BE OKAY
THINKING THAT WE MIGHT BE IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION I THINK WE DON'T
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THE REAL
COSTS ARE.
PEOPLE WHO ARE WORKING FULL TIME
AND HAVE FAMILIES.
IT EVEN IF YOU CAN.
OPEN UP THE COMPUTER AND AND
TAKE A COURSE.
IT'S STILL DIFFICULT PICKED A
LOT OF YOUR TIME AND ENERGY TO
TAKE IT TO COURT THAT PEOPLE
MIGHT BE NOT BE ENROLLING
BECAUSE THEIR LIVES ARE JUST.
BUT THEY HAVE A LOT GOING ON AND
THEY DON'T HAVE THE CAPACITY TO
ALSO TAKE THE EXTRA COURSES I
THINK THAT. THAT THAT ANOTHER
ANOTHER. POSSIBLY GOING ON I
THINK OUR CONCERN IS THAT WE
HAVE BEEN TRIED IN ANY CASE TO
TRY TO FIGURE OUT WHAT WHAT ARE
THE MAIN REASONS WHY THESE FOLKS
ARE NOT CURRENTLY. IN THE SYSTEM
AND LET'S FIND OUT WHAT THOSE
PROBLEMS ARE AND THEN LET'S FIX
THOSE PROBLEMS WE ARE WE ARE.
THE PROPOSAL IS HERE IS AN
ONLINE COMMUNITY COLLEGE WE'RE
PRESUMING THAT THIS IS THE
SOLUTION THAT IF THEY HAVE
ACCESS TO THE TH.
TO THIS PROGRAM IN IN THEIR. IN
THEIR HOME THEN THEY'RE GONNA TO
BE ENROLLED IN ANNOUNCED ON THE
PATH THE BARRIER FOR MANY OF
THEM THEY MIGHT NOT EVEN KNOW
WHAT THEY WOULD WANT TO TAKE
WHAT WHAT THEIR COURSE THEY
MIGHT. NEED ADDITIONAL GUIDANCE
FIGURE OUT WHAT ARE ALL OF THE
OF THE VARIETY OF PROGRAMS THAT
I CAN BENEFIT FROM MAYBE THAT'S
THE PROBLEM IF THAT'S THE CASE
THEN MAYBE WE NEED TO FIND A
BETTER WAY TO SORT OF. REACH OUT
TO THOSE FOLKS AND AND PROVIDE
THEM SOME ADVICE WHEN THEY'RE
WHEN THEY'RE ENTERING THE
SYSTEM.
THAT YOU COULD CONCEIVE OF A
NUMBER A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
APPROACHES TO TRY TO SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM.
BUT THE BUT THE WAY THE WAY YOU
APPROACH IT DEPENDS ON WHAT YOU
THINK THE MAIN ROUTE ISSUE.
SO YOUR ISSUE AS IT USED.
YOU RECOGNIZE THERE'S NO MAYBE A
NEED BUT THE SOLUTION TO TO THIS
NEED.
YOU'RE NOT.
CONVINCED YET THAT THIS
SOLUTION IS
MITCHELL NAY LEFT IRAQ OKAY NOW
IN YOUR RESEARCH HAVE YOU.
LOOKED AT.
.
OTHER INSTITUTIONS WERE FULL
TIME WORKERS PEOPLE UNDER TWENTY
FIVE THIRTY FIVE.
HAVE.
ENGAGE IN ANY ACTIVITIES LIKE
THIS YEAR RESEARCH HAVE YOU
SEEN.
WORD.
THEIR SOLUTION IS IS BEING
UNDERTAKEN.
YEAH I THINK WE'VE WE'VE LOOKED
A LITTLE BIT. AND I DON'T KNOW
THAT WE'VE DONE AN EXHAUSTIVE
SEARCH OF EVERYTHING THAT'S
GOING ON ACROSS THE COUNTRY I
THINK THE HARD PART IS WHAT.
COMPARE THE LOT OF THE PROGRAMS
THAT THAT PEOPLE BEEN REFERRING
TO FOR EXAMPLE THERE'S AN
ARIZONA STATE PROGRAM. THERE'S
WESTERN GOVERNORS UNIVERSITY
BOTH PROGRAMS ARE ACTUALLY THOSE
ARE BATTERERS PROGRAMS
SO YEAH IT'S DIFFICULT TO SAY
OKAY THAT'S THE.
SORT LET'S LOOK AT THAT AND
LET'S LET'S USE THAT OF THE
MODEL BECAUSE THAT IS.
IT IF THAT IT'S A TOTALLY
DIFFERENT I'M KIND OF PROGRAM.
GETTING STUDENTS ON THE WAY TO
ABOUT THE DEGREE NOT NECESSARILY
THE THESE KIND OF SHORT TERM
PROGRAMS THAT ARE TIED INDUSTRY
NEED.
WHAT ASK YOU SIR TO LOOK AT?
?
IN THE MILITARY.
BECAUSE THE MILITARY ONES RUNS
ONE PROBABLY THE A WORLDWIDE
ONLINE SYSTEM.
FOR PEOPLE BETWEEN TWENTY FIVE
AND FORTY.
TO GIVE THEM CERTIFICATE SKILLS.
TO AFFORD VANCE MEANT.
AND SO THIS IS NOT A UNIQUE IDEA
ME DISADVANTAGED ACT AIDS.
BECAUSE IN THE MILITARY HAVE
PEOPLE TRAVEL AROUND THE WORLD
WHEN DAVID BEING CALIFORNIA NEXT
DAY THEY COULD BE IN JAPAN. BUT
THE ONLY WAY THEY CAN CONTINUE
TRAVELING IN AND GET THEIR
CERTIFICATES AND SKILLS AS AN
ONLINE PROGRAM.
SO THIS THIS IS HAPPENING.
SO.
IF WE HAVE PEOPLE OUT THERE NEED
I JUST LIKE TO.
PRESENT THAT TO EVERYONE THAT
MAY BE AN OPTION REALLY DID LOOK
AT NOW BACK TO.
.
THE CHANCELLOR YOU KNOW WE YOU
AND I TALKED ABOUT THIS.
FOR ECADES NUMBER DOT DECADES
BUT YEARS. SEEMS LIKE DECADES
AND AND I'VE UP AS YOU AND I'VE
TALKED MY OWN US.
UNICOLOR JUST CONCERNED WITH IT.
.
MY FIRST QUESTION YOU.
PARTNERSHIP.
YOU'RE NOT CAN BE UNDER THIS ON
YOUR OWN WITHOUT PARTNERSHIP.
IS ANY YET ME PARTNERSHER TODAY
OR ANYBODY THAT'S SIGN ON THIS
THING LABOR UNIONS OR YES I
THINK WE HAVE SEVERAL PARTNERS
HERE TODAY AND THAT HE IS
ANYWAY.
PARTNERING HERE STAND UP I KNOW
SOMEBODY THERE.
THEY'RE ALL OUTSIDE.
ABOUT. A.
I DON'T BLAME HIM THE YEAH.
THE.
.
IT I THINK THAT'S CRITICAL IT IS
BEST WHEN YOU LOOK AT
CERTIFICATES WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT.
A BA OF.
BA IN FRENCH LITERATURE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT A SKILLED A.
TO GET A JOB ON THE WAGE ISSUE.
FIVE UP I'M ANXIOUS TO SEE OTHER
PARTNERSHIP DEMAND.
I KNOW YOU HAVE YOUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE WORKING GROUP ON THIS.
BECAUSE I'VE TALKED TO MY PEOPLE
AND THEY'RE ON THE WORKING
GROUP.
HOUSE ADVANCING I KNOW THERE.
WHEN YOU PUT THIS GROUP TOGETHER
SOME PEOPLE SAYING HELL NO WE
WON'T GO IN THAT WE HAD THE
OTHER PEOPLE SAYING THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY WHERE WHERE'S THAT
RIGHT NOW.
SO.
NOT TO GET IN FRONT OF THE NEXT
ITEM BUT WE HAVE SEVERAL WORKING
GROUPS THAT MOST OF WHAT YOU'RE
FOCUSED ON THE FUNDING FORMULA
BUT.
THERE IT'S BEEN A GROUP OF
CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICERS THAT
HAVE COME TOGETHER TO PUT
TOGETHER RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THE
CHANCELLOR FOR THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE.
A LED BY THE PRESIDENT
COASTLINE COLLEGE SHE JUST.
I JUST SAW THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS.
IN THE LAST TWENTY FOUR HOURS.
WE TAKE VERY SERIOUSLY.
THE INPUT IN THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HEAR FROM OUR COLLEGES
ABOUT HOW WE CAN BETTER PARTNER
WITH THEM WERE. NOT ONLY DO WE
NEED PARTNERSHIPS WITH LABOR AND
WITH EMPLOYERS.
WE RECOGNIZE WE NEED
PARTNERSHIPS WITH OUR COLLEGES
SOME COLLEGES.
BUT YOU THOSE IN IN YOUR
DISTRICT.
MEMBER CHVEZ ARE DOING A
GREAT WORK OF SERVING LOCAL
NEEDS.
SO.
WE ARE ABSOLUTELY OPEN TO
HEARING HOW WE CAN BEST SUPPORT.
THOSE COLLEGES IF YOU CONSIDER
THE TESTIMONY AT THE SENATE
HEARING.
THERE WERE TWO COLLEGE
PRESIDENTS THERE WHO MADE A VERY
COMPELLING CASE IS WHY THIS
WOULD SUPPORT THEIR COLLEGES IN
GROWING THEIR CAPACITY.
SO WE ABSOLUTELY RECOGNIZE THE
PARTNERSHIPS ARE CRITICAL.
WE ARE DEVELOPINGTHOSE
PARTNERSHIPS AS WE SPEAK AND I
THINK YOU'LL HEAR FROM MANY OF
OUR PARTNERS DURING PUBLIC
TESTIMONY.
SO THIS ISN'T A ESTO PIE.
INTERNAL.
GIVEN THE DONE JUST BY YOU AND
YOUR EXECUTIVE STAFF THIS
ACTUALLY READS
ACROSS THE STATE NOT JUST WITH
YOUR COLLEGES BUT ALSO. TRADE
INDUSTRIES AND BUSINESSES AND
EVERYBODY ELSE FOR ABSOLUTELY
THIS THIS IDEA ACTUALLY DIDN'T
COME FROM MY STAFF.
I KNOW SOME OF THEM UP COME
KICKING AND SCREAMING TO THIS
IDEA BUT.
BUT NO SERIOUSLY.
THIS IDEA CAME FROM OUR LABOR
PARTNERS.
WHO WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH WITH
MANY YEARS HO ARE FRUSTRATED
THAT THEY SEE THE DIRECTION THAT
THE ECONOMY IS TAKING THEIR
WORKERS?
AND HAVE BEEN DEVELOPING THEIR
OWN LOCAL PROGRAMS.
COMPETENCY BASED.
SO.
WE'VE TRIED TO PROVIDE A
SCALABLE SOLUTION
TOO MANY OF THE CHALLENGES THAT
THEY'VE BEEN BRINGING TO US OVER
THE YEARS AND I THINK YOU HERE
FOR SOME OF THAT.
IN THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY WE
COULDN'T TELL OR HIT THE SWEET
SPOT BECAUSE IN THE DIET STARTS.
TALKING AMONG THEMSELVES
MISSTATED IN AREAS OF CONCERN
VIA THIS MEET UP SHEET YOU HAVE
RIGHT HERE THAT THESE ARE
HEARINGS GOING AROUND THE STATE
THAT THE. YES THOSE ARE.
OPPORTUNITIES.
THAT ARE SPONSORED YOU SEE THE
HOST ALL SORTS OF VARIETY
OPPOSED THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE FUTURE
OF WORK
AND IF THIS THIS TOPIC OF THE
FUTURE OF WORK IS SOMETHING
THAT'S CRITICAL TO MANY OF OUR
PARTNERS.
AND US SO WE HAVE THESE
OPPORTUNITIES TO BRING TOGETHER.
FOLKS FROM ALL SORTS OF SPECTRUM
OF FOR EMPLOYERS TO A EDUCATORS
TO.
.
RESEARCHERS TO TALK ABOUT HOW
WE DEVELOP.
THE PATHWAYS FOR.
TO RESPOND TO THE CONCERNS THAT
EVERYBODY HAS BUT THE FUTURE OF
WORK.
OKAY APRIL SECOND SAN DIEGO'S
MONDAY WILL BE UP HERE.
CAUSING OTHER PROBLEMS BUT THE I
WOULD LIKE. TO MAKE SURE MY
CHIEF OF STAFF YOU ARE WELCOME
TO US AND THE.
YOUR ENTIRE DISTRICT STAFF.
BLASTING OUT JUST MAKE A COMMENT
IS.
.
CHANGE IS ALWAYS TOUGH.
AND NOW.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE AT THE WHOLE
ISSUE OF EQUITY.
PARTICULAR FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE
OF COLOR.
THE.
.
THE ONLY WAY WE CAN TRULY DEAL
WITH EQUITY.
IS TO EDUCATION.
YESTERDAY ON THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR
I MADE A COMMENT THAT.
MY FATHER WHO HAD A THIRD GRADE
EDUCATION WHOSE WORK IN THE
FIELD IN WORLD WAR TWO STARTED.
WHEN OFTEN THE COURT CAME BACK
WAS WORKING AT U. S. STILL.
AND BECAUSE OF. EL CAMINO JUNIOR
COLLEGE.
AT NIGHT.
HE WAS ABLE TO GET SOME SKILLS
NINETY DEGREE.
SKILLS TO WORK IN THE AEROSPACE
INDUSTRY AND ALLOW US TO MOVE
FROM THE BODY .
TO TORRANCE CALIFORNIA WE HAD
SIDEWALKS
SO THE.
.
THIS IS NOT THE NEW OF HOW WE'RE
TRYING TO MEET DID THE EQUITY
ISSUE OF JOBS.
FOR PEOPLE SO.
.
AS I STATED MY BEGINNING
COMMENTS.
IT'S GREAT TO HAVE THE FREEDOM
TO GO TO COLLEGE BUT WHEN YOU'RE
WORKING TO PUT FOOD ON THE TABLE
YOU OFTEN CAN'T DO THIS. THIS IS
NOT ANYTHING NEW.
.
DF MY FATHER HAD TO GO TO EL
CAMINO JUNIOR COLLEGES THEY
DIDN'T HAVE COMPUTERS THAT HE
COULD DO IT IN HIS HOUSE.
BUT AS I MENTIONED EARLIER THE
MILITARY WE DO THIS ALL THE TIME
WHEN YOU'RE ON SHIPS WHEN YOU'RE
DEPLOYED OVERSEAS.
STILL ABOUT CONTINUING YOUR
EDUCATION FOR ADVANCEMENTS WAGE
EARNERS YOU DON'T GET A
CERTIFICATE YOU DON'T GET
PROMOTED YOU DON'T GET PROMOTED
YOU GET KICKED OUT.
SO IT'S A NUMBER OUT SYSTEM
SO THIS IS.
A VERY GOOD STEP IN THE
DIRECTION JUST CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH EVERYBODY AND HAVE PEOPLE
PART OF IT I THINK YOU DOING
THAT WITH THIS.
THESE MEETUPS AROUND THE STATE
AND.
I'M SUPPORTIVE YOU GOING FORWARD
IN AN INTRIGUED BUT WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO GET OUT OF THIS SO.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
SIR.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIMON
GREAT THANK YOU THANK YOU CHAIR
AND THINK YOU. CAN'T TURN OTHERS
FOR BEING HERE I DO HAVE AT
LEAST FIVE QUESTIONS I WANT TO
WARN THE CHAIR THAT I HAVE
COUPLE OF GUN TO ASK AND I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN SHARED AROUND SUCCESS.
I THINK THAT TO AYE WE HEARD
FOR MY COLLEAGUES AND I MONICA
AS WELL THAT.
HOW WE DEFINE SUCCESS IS
IMPORTANT AND I KNOW YOU'VE
SHARED ON SOME METRICS?
OF HOW THAT IS DEFINED ONE OF
THEM BEING WAGE INCREASES ON AT
BASS THAT'S CORONATION ALL BREAK
IT'S NOT EXACTLY YOU CAN'T
DIRECTLY SAY THAT THAT'S THE
CLASS BUT YOU CAN CORRELATE IT
TO IT.
.
BUT HOW WILL YOU YOU KNOW WHAT
THE DEFINITION OF SUCCESS FOR AN
ONLINE PROGRAM IS IMPORTANT AS
IT IS. HOW WE MEASURE SUCCESS
AND HOW WE VIOLATE THAT CAN YOU
PLEASE SPEAK TO HOW WE EVALUATE
CIGARETTES NOT JUST WITH THE
METRICS OF SUCCESS ARE?
SURE SO MUCH THE WAY WE MEASURE.
SUCCESS TODAY IN THE HUNDRED
FOURTEEN COLLEGES TO.
AVAILABILITY OF DATA ON A HOUSE
STUDENTS ARE PROGRESSING
SO CALIFORNIA TO ME COLLEGES
HAVE SEVERAL METRICS THAT WE
USE.
TYPICALLY CONTAINED IN OUR
SCORECARD.
SO WHILE THE.
THIS PERSONALIZED VERY PLATFORM
IS A LITTLE DIFFERENT BECAUSE
WE'RE NOT.
MARCHING TOWARD A ESOS HIS
DEGREE OR A TYPICAL
UNDERGRADUATE EDUCATION.
STUDENTS STILL HAVE TO
DEMONSTRATE THAT THEY ARE
MASTERING THE CONTENT.
AND SO.
JUST AS WE DO NOW.
IN A TYPICAL ENVIRONMENT THAT'S
DONE THROUGH A GRADING SYSTEM
THAT'S DONE THROUGH PROGRESSION
FROM ONE CLASS TO ANOTHER
PERSISTENCE.
AND THEN COMPLETION OF AN
EDUCATIONAL GOAL.
THOSE METRICS WOULD APPLY. TO
THIS UP PLATFORM AS WELL.
.
THE OTHER METRIC THAT WE'VE
RECENTLY CREATED WHICH IS IN THE
VISION FOR SUCCESS IS THIS ISSUE
OF PLACEMENT IN THE JOB.
AND GAINING A MEANINGFUL WAGE
WE DO FEEL THAT WE HAVE THE
ACCESS TO THE DATA THAT WE NEED.
IN ORDER TO PRODUCE.
QUALITY INFORMATION ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT AN INDIVIDUAL.
.
A BENEFITTED.
THROUGH WAGE GAME.
AND I THINK THAT'S WHY IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US TO BUILD THESE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE EMPLOYERS
AND.
AND THE LABOR COMMUNITY.
SO.
.
TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION IT
WOULD BE VERY MUCH
SIMILAR APPLICABLE MEASURES THAT
WE USE FOR ANY OF ON AND
FOURTEEN COLLEGES. AS WELL AS
ADDITIONAL ELEMENT. ARE
ENCOMPASSES BASE SYSTEM BY THE
WAY. YOU ONLY PROGRESS IF YOU
MASTER THE CONTENT.
.
SO THIS IS SELF PACED.
IF A STUDENT MASTERS THE
CONTENT THEN THEY MOVE FORWARD
IF THEY DON'T THEN THEY
CONTINUE.
TO.
ACCESS TO CONTENT WITH SOME
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT UNTIL THEY
MASTER AT SO. PART OF IT IS
DEMONSTRATING THAT COMPETENCY
WHICH IS IN A COMPLICATED SYSTEM
IT IS VERY STRAIGHTFORWARD
EITHER THEY MASTER THE CONTENT
OR THEY DON'T AND IF THEY DO
THEY MOVE FORWARD.
AND SO THAT'S HOW YOU. WHAT I'M
HEARING IS HOW YOU AND MEASURE
OR DO THERE ARE TALK ABOUT
INDIVIDUAL STUDENT SUCCESS WHO
HOW WILL THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
KNOW IF YOU'VE BEEN SUCCESSFUL?
WITH THE ENTIRE PROGRAM AND THE
ENTIRE INITIATIVE.
WELL FIRST OF ALL LET ME SAY
THAT.
.
WE WELCOME.
ANY ADDITIONAL THOUGHTS OR
IDEAS THAT THIS BODY WOULD HAVE
WE WANT TO BE RESPONSIVE TO THE
CONCERNS THAT YOU ALL HAVE A IN
TERMS OF HOW WE MEASURE SUCCESS.
AS A NEW INSTITUTION.
SO.
HOW WOULD WE MEASURE SUCCESS SO
CERTAINLY IN THE NEAR TERM IT
WOULD BE?
?
A.
MAKING SURE THAT THERE'S DEMAND
SO OUR STUDENTS ENROLLING.
OUR PARTNERSHIPS BEING BUILT.
DO WE HAVE EMPLOYER AND LABOR.
PARTNERS WORKING ON THIS.
.
HAVE WE ACCOMPLISH GETTING THE
INSTITUTION OF CRIED ACCREDITED.
AND OUR STUDENTS PROGRESSING
NOT JUST TO WAGE GAME BUT ARE
THEY PROGRESSING.
IN TERMS OF THEIR EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES
DO WE SEE OVER TIME. THAT THESE
INDIVIDUALS ARE GAINING HIGHER
LEVEL CREDENTIALS.
THOSE ARE WAYS THAT WE WOULD
EXPECT TO HOLD THIS NEW
INSTITUTION ACCOUNTABLE.
ARE THEY CREATING VALUE FOR
CALIFORNIANS
A AND ALSO. A ARE WE ENSURING
THAT THE PARTNERSHIPS WITH OUR
COLLEGES EXIST SO THAT WE DON'T.
UNDERMINE ENROLLMENT OVER OTHER
COLLEGES SO THEY WOULD HAVE TO
BE CLEAR CRITERIA.
IN TERMS OF HOW WE HOLD THE
COLLEGE ACCOUNTABLE TO ENSURE
THAT THEY ARE WORKING WITH THEIR
PARTNER COLLEGES TO BUILD
CAPACITY NOT TO CANNIBALIZE.
I YOU DO YOU DESCRIBED THAT THIS
CONVERSATION IN PAR IS ABOUT THE
FUTURE OF
I HAD THE WORK FORCE.
AND OF THE LABOR AND AND IN MY
MIND I'D THERE IS A STRONG
INTERSECTION BETWEEN WHAT THIS
MEANS FOR THE FUTURE OF
EDUCATION. AND BECAUSE I ALSO
THINK WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
FUTURE OF EDUCATION I LOOK AND
AT MY OWN EXPERIENCE IN THE
RESEARCH IN THE LITERATURE OUT
THERE THAT REMINDS US THAT NO
MATTER WHAT INITIATIVES AND
PROJECTS WE'VE. TRIED AND WE
STILL CONTINUE TO SEE FRESH
NARRATION LOW INCOME STUDENTS
I'M WHO STRUGGLE NO MATTER WHAT
THE MODEL IS. AND AND SO FROM
THAT PLACE.
I ASKED MYSELF
WHY NOT A PILOT.
WHY DOES THIS HAVE TO BE THE
PROGRAM IT IS AND WHY NOT PILOT
IT? I'M IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT
WE MAY WANT TO MAKE THE
APPROPRIATE OR NEEDED
INVESTMENTS IN THE FUTURE BUT TO
GIVE US THE TIME TO UNDERSTAND
LIKE IS THIS REALLY GOING TO
WORK.
SO I I THINK THAT'S A FAIR
QUESTION.
AND IN MANY WAYS THE WAY THIS
IS BEING DESIGNED CURRENTLY IS
IN MANY WAYS A PILOT WE'VE BEEN
ASKED.
TO DEVELOP AT LEAST THREE
PATHWAYS.
TO ENROLL THE FIRST COHORT
STUDENT.
STUDENTS BY THE END OF TWENTY
NINETEEN.
SO I'M I WOULD BE VERY
COMFORTABLE COMING BACK TO THIS
BODY.
AT A FUTURE TIME.
ENSURING THAT WE HAVE MET THOSE
GOALS IN ORDER TO RECEIVE
CONTINUED INVESTMENT IF THAT'S
THE PLEASURE OF THIS BODY.
SO.
.
WHETHER WE DO IT.
FORMALLY AWARE THAT WE DO IT.
INFORMALLY WHEN WE COME BACK TO
YOU.
AND YOU QUESTION WHETHER OR NOT
THERE NEEDS TO BE CONTINUED
INVESTMENT I THINK.
WE ARE VERY OPEN TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THOSE INITIAL
COHORTS
AND WE BE HAPPY TO FIGURE OUT
HOW THAT BEST DONE.
AT YOU WHEN THINKING ABOUT
HIGHER ED AND AND.
ALL OF THE THINGS THAT HELP
STUDENTS BE SUCCESSFUL SO ONE OF
YOUR METRICS BOTH I'M FOR
INDIVIDUAL STUDENTS SUCCESS BUT
ALSO FOR INSTITUTIONAL SUCCESS
IS TO IS TO LOOK AT WHETHER THE
STUDENTS WERE SUCCESSFUL OR NOT.
AND WE ARE ABLE TO IDENTIFY A
MULTITUDE OF SERVICES INCLUDING
TUTORING ADVISING OTHER SERVICES
THAT HELP. THAT STUDENT BE
SUCCESS.
HOW IS THIS PROGRAM THIS IDEA OF
GOING TO INCLUDE OTHER ELEMENTS
THAT WE KNOW?
STUDENTS NO MATTER WHETHER
THEY'RE NONTRADITIONAL ADULT
LEARNERS ARE EVEN KEEP YOUR
TWELVE STUDENTS MEET IN ORDER TO
BE SUCCESSFUL.
WELL WE ARE CLEARLY ACKNOWLEDGE
AND AGREE WITH YOU THAT.
.
THIS IN EVERY GROUP IS TO NICK
COUNTER COLLEGES NEEDS
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
PARTICULARLY.
INDIVIDUALS IN THIS.
LEARNING ENVIRONMENT
ADULT LEARNERS
WILL NEED SUPPORT THEY WILL NEED
AND THIS IS WHY AGAIN IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT AS WE DEVELOP
THESE PATHWAYS AND IF YOU LOOK
AT THE PRINCIPLES THAT WE'VE PUT
FORWARD TO DEVELOP THE PATHWAYS.
THEY REQUIRE US
TO WORK WITH OUR PARTNERS WITH
THEIR LABOR EMPLOYERS TO CREATE
THE MENTORSHIP THE COACHING.
THE INTRUSIVE.
.
SUPPORT SYSTEM THAT WE WILL
NEED TO ENSURE THAT THESE
INDIVIDUALS SUCCEED WE'VE SEEN
MODELS OF THAT.
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY.
IN PUBLIC.
ONLINE PLATFORMS.
.
WE'RE LEARNING A LOT ABOUT WHAT
WE'RE DOING NOW WITH THE CURRENT
ONLINE EDUCATION INITIATIVE AND
HOW WE'RE EMBEDDING SUPPORT
SERVICES IN THAT ENVIRONMENT.
SO WE FEEL CONFIDENT THAT WE CAN
DO THAT IN PARTICULAR ADD ONE
MORE COMPONENT WHICH IS THAT
COACHING AND MENTORING
COMPONENT.
THAT WILL BE PROVIDED BY EITHER
THE LABOR PARTNER OR THE
EMPLOYER PARTNER
BECAUSE WE RECOGNIZE THAT THESE
INDIVIDUALS.
FACE MANY MANY CHALLENGES.
INCLUDING EQUIPMENT ACCESS TO
BROADBAND.
INTERNET SO IN AREAS WHERE
THAT'S NOT AVAILABLE WE WOULD BE
WORKING WITH THE EMPLOYER FOR
THE LABOR PARTY TO ENSURE THAT
THERE IS A SPACE.
WHERE THESE INDIVIDUALS CAN GO
TO GAIN ACCESS
TO BROADBAND EACH AND JUST TO BE
CLEAR DOES THAT THEN MEAN THAT
THERE IS A ROLE FOR THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TO PLAY IN
THIS BECAUSE? I MEAN THEY CAN'T
ALL TRAVEL TO.
YES RIGHT YEAH.
ABSOLUTELY.
HER PUTTING FOURTEEN COLLEGES
SO WHETHER OR NOT. THEY PROVIDE
SPACE PROVIDE.
PART TIME INSTRUCTORS FULL TIME
INSTRUCTORS
THAT ARE SPECIFIC TO THE CONTENT
THAT WE'RE DELIVERING.
I WE WOULD ABSOLUTELY EXPECT A
PARTNER WITH THEM.
BUT FIRST AND FOREMOST YOU KNOW
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE UP FRONT.
THAT WE HAVE THE SUPPORT WE NEED
FROM OUR LABOR PARTNERS EMPLOYER
PARTNERS TO ENSURE IT IS THESE
INDIVIDUALS AND ROLL.
THAT THEY ALREADY HAVE THE
SUPPORT NECESSARY AND AND THAT'S
WHAT. YOU KNOW QUITE FRANKLY MY
CONVERSATIONS ARE CONVERSATIONS
WITH OUR LABOR PARTNERS THEY
EXPECT THAT OF US.
AND IF REQUIRED THAT OF US IF
THEY DO PARTNER WITH.
THE OTHER THING IS IT IS JUST
FOR CLARITY PURPOSES AND. IT
THERE IS. FEES ASSOCIATED WITH
THIS DO WE EXPECT THAT THESE
FEES ARE GOING TO BE ALIGNED OR
IS THIS NEW BOARD AND NEW
COLLEGE GOING TO ADAPT A
DIFFERENT MODEL. AND THAT'S
DIFFERENT THAN THE FEE STRUCTURE
THAT WE SEE IN PLACE FOR THE
HUNDRED IMPORTANT COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. SO FIRST OF ALL.
THE FEE STRUCTURE WOULD BE
CONSISTENT.
WITH.
THE COST OF EDUCATION IN THE
CALIFORNIA TOO BECAUSE I THINK
FINANCE.
LAID THAT OUT.
BECAUSE IT'S A COMPETENCY BASED
MODEL WE WILL PROBABLY NEED LOOK
AT ADAPTING.
A FEE STRUCTURE THAT'S
CONSISTENT WITH THE WAY THE
STUDENTS COME IN AND OUT.
IN THIS MODEL STUDENTS CAN COME
IN AND OUT WHENEVER THEY WANT
BASICALLY THERE IS NO
TRADITIONAL ACADEMIC CALENDAR.
IT'S NOT A PER UNIT BASIS RIGHT
NOW WE CHARGE PER UNIT.
SO WE WOULD NEED TO ADOPT AND
ADAPT FEE STRUCTURE THAT'S
CONSISTENT WITH THE FORTY SIX
DOLLARS A UNIT FOR THIS MODEL SO
WE WOULD BE WORKING. WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AS WELL
IT'S YOU KNOW CURRENTLY THE
LEGISLATURE SETS.
OTHER FEATS FOR MUSICOLOGISTS SO
WE WOULD NEED TO FIND SOMETHING
THAT CONFORMS AND COMPORTS TO
THE FEE STRUCTURE THAT YOU'VE
ALREADY ADOPTED.
AND AS YOU THINK OF BOTH THE
SHORT TERM AND THE LONG TERM.
OF SOMETHING LIKE THIS IN IN
THE LONG TERM HOW DO YOU DECIDE
IF YOU EXPAND HOW DO YOU DECIDE
IF THIS GROWS BIGGER AND WE'RE
HAVING A CONVERSATION NOW. YOU
KNOW INITIALLY AND IT SOUNDS
LIKE IT'S LIMITED PATHWAYS.
VERY FOCUS BUT
HOW DOES THAT DECISION IN THE
LONG TERM AND FUTURE WORK.
WELL I THINK.
FIRST OF ALL.
SIMILAR TO THE CONVERSATION TO
HAPPEN NOW AT OUR COLLEGES.
.
THERE.
THE CURRICULUM DISCUSSIONS ARE
LED BY THE FACULTY OF THAT
COLLEGE SO IF THERE IS A.
A DEMAND IN THAT NEEDS TO BE
SERVED WE WOULD EXPECT THAT THE
CURRICULUM PROCESS WHICH TRIED
TO ADDRESS THAT DEMAND.
.
IF THERE ARE ANY.
NEW ASPECTS OF THE BECAUSE IT
WOULD HAVE TO BE BROUGHT FORWARD
TO THE BOARD OF GOVERNORS.
.
IF THERE'S ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT
THAT WE WOULD HAVE TO COME TO
THE LEGISLATURE TO ASK FOR THAT.
BUT.
IN THE END WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
CURRENT INVESTMENT FIRST THOUGH
IF THERE IS A DESIRE AND A
DEMAND TO EXPAND AND INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF ONLINE OFFERINGS.
IN A TRADITIONAL UNDERGRADUATE
FRAMEWORK THAT WE WOULD BE
RELYING ON THE ONLINE EDUCATION
INITIATIVE TO REACH THAT THE
MAN.
SO I WE THINK THE TWO CAN WORK
IN CONCERT WITH A WE ALREADY
HAVE ONE MECHANISM FOR
UNDERGRADUATE EDUCATION ONLINE
WE WANNA CONTINUE TO GROW THAT.
IN THIS GIVES IS JUST ONE MORE
TOOL BUT WE WOULD HAVE THE SAME
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS IN THE
SAME PROCESS FOR REQUESTING
EXPANSION AS WE DO NOW.
THANK YOU AND I MEAN JUST IN
CLOSING AS A COMMENT I THINK
THAT THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
CONVERSATIONS I'M IF YOU KNOW
INTERNALLY AMONGST MEMBERS. AND
WE'VE WE YOU KNOW WE'VE HAD
CONVERSATIONS AS WELL AND I
THINK WELL I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE AND YOU KNOW THE
ESSENCE OF THIS THIS IS ABOUT
GETTING NONTRADITIONAL STUDENTS.
ENROLLED AND CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
COLLEGE RIGHT AYE I GET THAT I
APPRECIATE THAT AND THEIR.
I ALSO THINK THAT.
SOME OF MY CONCERNS AND
HESITATION COME FROM A PLACE OF
ALSO WATCHING MULTIPLE MODELS IN
EDUCATION AND TRIED AND WE
CONTINUE TO SEE FIRSTHAND
ORATION. STUDENTS WHO HAVE A
NEED TO WORK IN A FULL TIME
STRUGGLE IN ALL OF THESE MODELS
SO I RAISE THESE QUESTIONS AND
I'M YOU KNOW AND THEY'RE PARTLY
QUESTIONS SLASH CONCERNS OF
RIGHT TERMS OF WHAT I'M
THINKING.
SIMPLY AS A WAY TO ENSURE THAT
THIS MODEL WHILE GREAT INTENT
DOESN'T LEAVE BEHIND THE STUDENT
THAT EVERY OTHER MODEL HAS LEFT
BEHIND IN CALIFORNIA AMEND
ACTUALLY OUR COUNTRY IT'S NOT
IT'S NOT JUST THERE SO I WANT TO
BE CLEAR THAT. AND THAT'S REALLY
WHERE THE CONCERN IS AND NOT A
CONCERN OF WHETHER OR NOT WE
NEED TO BE FLEXIBLE OR ADAPT TO
YOU KNOW NEW LEARNING STYLES.
THAT I CAN FOLLOW BUT AND IT IS
A CONCERN OF.
HOW DO WE KNOW IT'S GOING TO
WORK FOR THE STUDENTS THAT? YOU
KNOW.
HAVE A HISTORY OF IT IS A FAIR
NOT EARNING WELL SO YEAH BECAUSE
THE MODEL DOESN'T WORK SO THAT I
THINK I THINK YOU.
COULD AMERICAN AYE NETS YET
CHRIS FERGUSON WITH FINANCE
I THINK YOUR POINT OF WOULD YOU
KNOW REITERATE THE RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT UNIT SPECIFICALLY
WILL BE LOOKING AT. ITEMS SUCH
AS ARE THEIR DISPARITIES IN THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP IN THIS COLLEGE
AND WILL BE DEVELOPING COUNTRIES
CONSTANTLY. AT NEW STRATEGIES TO
ENSURE IT THAT IS OCCURRING THAT
WE ADDRESS IT INSTANTLY AND THAT
THE COLLEGE TAKES THAT INTO
ACCOUNT FROM THE START AND IS
REVIEWING IT. CONSTANTLY GREAT
THANK YOU AND I DO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT. THERE IS
RESEARCH NOW THAT FIRST AND LOW
INCOME STUDENTS ARE NOT DOING
WELL ON ONLINE YOU KNOW I MEAN
IT WORKS FOR SOME AND IT DOESN'T
WORK FOR OTHERS SO. THERE IS
ALREADY STAFF THERE THAT TEST
YOU KNOW THAT TELLS US AND YOU
KNOW WE SHOULD BE RAISING THESE
QUESTIONS SO.
THANK YOU THOUGH.
MR MEDINA.
THANK YOU.
AS AND THANK YOU MS LOW MOAN AS
I AM LISTENING HERE.
TO THE.
DISCUSSION.
IT SEEMS LIKE TO ME THE CONCERNS
ARE.
AND THREE THREE DIFFERENT
DIRECTIONS.
FIRST ONE I I WOULD SAY IS.
.
ONE THAT WE JUST HAD A
DISCUSSION ON. THE.
PETTY GOLLY GEE.
OF OR THE WAY WE REACH STUDENTS
THE WAY WE TEACH.
AND.
AND AS A MISTER CHAVEZ WAS
SPEAKING ABOUT THE MILITARY. AN
ONLINE AYE AYE REMEMBERING MY
HIGH SCHOOL EXPERIENCE AND ARMY
ROTC.
AND I LEARNED TO TAKE APART AND
PUT TOGETHER THE M. ONE RIFLE
THAT'S HOW OLD. FOR LONG AGO.
I WAS IN HIGH SCHOOL THAT WAS
THE M. ONE RIFLE.
BUT IF I HAD TO LEARN HOW TO
TAKE APART AND PUT TOGETHER THE
M. ONE RIFLE I DON'T THINK I
COULD HAVE LEARNED HOW TO HAVE
DONE THAT. ONLINE.
AND AND.
.
AND I DON'T BELIEVE THAT THE
MILITARY TEACHES THOSE KIND OF
THINGS ONLINE.
AND AND THOSE SO THAT GOES TO
THE QUESTION OF HOW. YOU LEARN.
AND HOW INDIVIDUALS LEARN AND
THE NEED FOR HANDS ON.
SO THAT'S THAT'S THE FIRST
CATEGORY. YOU KNOW OUR OURS ARE
LEARNERS REALLY GOING TO BE ABLE
TO USE THEIR PHONES.
TO A ACCESS EDUCATION IS THIS.
A.
I'M NOT.
IS THIS LITTLE DEVICE ENOUGH WAY
TO LEARN PERHAPS COMPLICATED
INFORMATION.
AND THAT THAT GOES ALSO TO.
ACCESS.
SO THAT THAT'S I THINK THAT'S
THE FIRST QUESTION THAT IT'S IN
MY MIND. THE SECOND IS AS WE'VE
MENTIONED GOVERNMENTS.
ACCREDITATION.
.
HOW LONG DOES IT TAKE FOR THIS
ENTITY TO GET ACCREDITED?
?
WHO DOES IT COMPETE WITH?
AND I THINK THE THIRD IS FINANCE
WHERE WHERE DOES THIS. COME MAN
WITH THE. WITH PROP NINETY EIGHT
FUNDING
IS THIS TAKING MONEY FROM PROP
NINETY EIGHT IS IS TAKING MONEY
FROM A.
FOR MOTHER FOR FROM OTHER
COLLEGES FINANCE WANTS TO
RESPOND.
TO THE FUNDING FOR ABOUT NINETY
EIGHT ON THAT THE FUNDING ASPECT
THE PROPOSED HUNDRED AND TWENTY
MILLION. AYE IT'S WITHIN THE
SPORT THAT IT'S ABOUT PROVIDED
FOR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES BUT IT'S NOT DIRECTLY
TAKEN OUT OF ANOTHER ALLOCATION
THAT'S EXISTING. OR THAT IT'S.
NOW PROPOSED FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS
SPECIFICALLY SO WITH STRUCTURED
BOTH THE LANGUAGE AS WELL AS THE
FUNDING. SHE SAY THAT NOW THAT
WE'VE SEEING SOME.
AVAILABLE FUNDING WITHIN THAT AT
SPLIT THE WE WERE USING IT FOR
THIS PURPOSE AND WE'VE SAID VERY
CLEARLY IN THE LANGUAGE THAT THE
INTENT MOVING FORWARD. IS THAT
IF THERE'S ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FOR THIS COLLEGE SAY VIA FTP
ELSE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDERATE SEPARATE FROM
FUNDING FOR ALL OF THE OTHER
COLLEGES TO ENSURE THAT WERE NOT
IMPACTING. ENROLLMENT OR GROWTH
WITHIN THE TRADITIONAL HUNDRED
FOURTEEN COLLEGES.
A. TO THE TO THE QUESTION OF
GOVERNANCE.
.
CREDIT TATIAN.
SO.
ACCREDITATION  WE ARE IN
CONVERSATIONS NOW WITH.
OUR CREDITORS.
ACC JC AS WELL AS OTHER
CREDITORS TO WHAT'S.
ANSWERING THESE QUICK ASKING
AND ANSWERING THESE QUESTIONS OF
THEIR CERTAINLY. THE
ACCREDITATION THAT ARE HUNDRED
FOR EIGHTEEN COLLEGES
TRADITIONALLY PURSUE WHICH WE
WOULD PURSUE. WEARING
CONVERSATION THEY SEE SEE JC
ABOUT HOW QUICKLY WE CAN MOVE TO
THAN WHAT THEY WOULD REQUIRE AS
WELL AS WE'RE LOOKING. AT AT THE
OPTIONS OFFERED THROUGH WHAT'S.
FOUR PREDATION OF.
.
CERTIFICATE COURSE.
WHICH IS DIFFERENT THAN
TRADITIONAL UNDERGRADUATE.
DEGREE COURSES
SO WE ARE EXPLORING BOTH WITH
WATCHED AND WITH A C. JC.  WE
THINK WE CAN MOVE THROUGH THAT
PROCESS RELATIVELY QUICKLY.
AND WE FULLY EXPECT TO BE FULLY
A FULLY ACCREDITED AND MAKE SURE
THAT OUR STUDENTS HAVE AVAILABLE
TO THEM ALL THE BENEFITS NOT
ONLY OF CALIFORNIA. BUT OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AS WELL.
TO THE FIRST QUESTION OF
PEDAGOGY. IS THIS THE BEST WAY
TO LEARN.
SO.
MEMBER MEDINA AYE AYE I
APPRECIATE THAT AND AND I I
THINK WE WOULD ALL AGREE THAT.
THE IPHONE.
.
CANNOT AND SHOULD NOT BE A
REPLACEMENT.
FOR.
EDUCATION.
BROUGHT TO US BY OUR
FULLY COMMITTED.
CLASSROOM INSTRUCTORS.
.
THAT THE CHALLENGE IS.
INTEREST WELL LET ME SAY THAT I
DON'T BELIEVE THE IPHONE WOULD
BE THE PLACE TO LEARN.
A COMPLICATED SUBJECT GROWTH
SUBJECT THAT REQUIRES EXTENSIVE.
INSTRUCTION.
BUT CAN BE A PLACE TO LEARN SOFT
SKILLS.
IT CAN BE A PLACE
TO MASTERS SOME RUDIMENTARY
FUNDAMENTAL ISSUES AROUND THE
USE.
AN ACCESS TO THE INTERNET THE
USE OF A BROWSER.
WHICH MANY OF THESE WORKERS
LACK EVEN THOSE FUNDAMENTAL
SKILLS.
SO.
WE'RE LOOKING AT THIS IN TERMS
OF ALL THE TOOLS AVAILABLE.
THAT AN INDIVIDUAL COULD HAVE
AND TAILORING. THE INSTRUCTION
TO THE TOOLS THAT WOULD BE
NECESSARY.
FOR HIGHER LEVEL INSTRUCTION WE
WOULD ABSOLUTELY NEED THE
INDIVIDUAL TO BE CONNECTED
DIRECTLY.
IN AND A ROBUST PLATFORM TO A
FACULTY MEMBER.
AND HAVE ACCESS TO BROADBAND.
TO ACCOMPLISH THAT.
BUT THERE ARE SOME FUNDAMENTAL
SKILLS THAT INDIVIDUAL COULD
LEARN. AND COULD MASTER ON THE
IPHONE SO.
BUT THAT IS THE JOB OF OUR
CONTENT EXPERTS ARE FACULTY.
DEVELOP MODULES THAT ARE
APPROPRIATE.
FOR THE DEVICE
THAT THEY WOULD BE.
DEPLOY.
THANK YOU.
I CHVEZ THIS WHO REALLY QUICK
QUESTION TO THE LA OUT.
ARE YOU AWARE OF ANY STUDIES.
AS FAR AS ONLINE LEARNING.
.
OLDER PEOPLE BECAUSE WE'RE
TALKING PEOPLE RIGHT HERE TWENTY
FIVE TO THIRTY FOUR WERE NOT AS
SOME OF THE MEMBERS OF THE DICE
REFERRING SAN ONLINE.
ISN'T BEST FOR YOUNG PEOPLE I
SEEN THOSE STUDIES SPECIAL
ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS
WE'RE TALKING TWENTY FIVE TO
THIRTY FIVE FOUR YEAR OLD ARE
YOU ARE MANY SIZES SHOW.
THERE'S NO ADVANTAGE OR
DISADVANTAGE ONLINE LET ME.
I THINK THAT THERE ARE A VARIETY
OF STUDIES THAT TRY TO MEASURE.
.
PERFORMANCE IN THE CLASSROOM
VERSUS ONLINE INCOME LOOK AT
THOSE GAPS I THINK WITH
VIRTUALLY ALL GROUPS THERE'S A
LITTLE BIT LOWER. PERFORMANCE.
ONLINE THAN THAN IN PERSON
THOUGH THAT GAP HAS BEEN CLOSING
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS.
AND A BUT ONE OF THE IT'S ALL OF
THAT IS THE CAT SO HOW BIG THAT
GAP AND FOR DIFFERENT
DEMOGRAPHIC GROUPS ACTUALLY FOR
OLDER. FOR OLDER ADULTS.
THEY TENDED.
YOU BETTER TO HAVE A LOWER DROP
OFF IN PERFORMANCE AND FROM THAT
WITH SOME OF THE STUDIES SHOW. I
THINK THAT THERE WITH AN A IN
THE THIRTIES I THOUGHT THAT WAS
A SPECIFIC REASON. FOR OUR THAT
THEY COULD BECKETT SPECIFICALLY
TIE BUT ONE THOUGHT IS THAT
OLDER ADULTS WHO CAMINO EXACTLY
WHAT THEY YOU KNOW THEY HAVE THE
DISCIPLINE THEY KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE. WHAT THEY'RE HERE TO DO
AND SO THEY CAN BE MORE FOCUSED
THAN I AM INTO COMBAT COURSE SO
THERE IS?
THUMB.
CITY THE SHOW THAT I THINK IN
IN IN GENERAL.
OLDER ADULT THEMES HAVE THEM
BETTER ON SOME OF THE LAWMAKERS
I REFER TO THE ROUGH YOUR STUDY.
BECAUSE IT SHOWS ADULTS DO
BETTER ON ONLINE SO MAYBE FOR
ENGLISH LANGUAGE OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE BUT FOR THE GROUP THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT BETWEEN TWENTY
FIVE AND THIRTY FOR THE STUDIES
SHOW. THAT ARE ONLINE LEARNING
CAN OFTEN BE ENHANCE FOR OLDER
ADULTS.
IN ADDITION WE THE ISSUE ABOUT A
LEARNING DETAIL COMPLICATED
THINGS.
I LEARNED HOW DO WE.
PLAN IN RELEASE.
THE.
NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
ONLINE.
AND THE DETAILS ON THAT IS VERY
SPECIFIC IN ITS NOT SOMETHING
YOU WANNA.
NOT PASS SO.
YOU CAN LEARN VERY COMPLEX
THINGS IF YOU WANT TO.
FOCUS ON AND GET IT SO.
CLIP WE NOT HAVE A HIGHER
EDUCATION IS AVAILABLE TO OUR
LEADERS RIGHT NOW THAT'S WHAT. I
FEEL A LOT OF THINGS THERE THANK
YOU.
AND NOW WE HAVE A LOT OF THE.
PUBLIC COMMENT AS WELL AND I
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION.
GREAT QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS AND
CONCERNS FROM FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THAT BOTH HIGHER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ON THE BUDGET. CAN
SUBCOMMITTEE WILL BE ADDRESSING
THIS I I HAVE A FEW THINGS ON
THE WAY OUT THERE AND FRANKLY
MOST OF THESE HAVE BEEN HIT. I I
DO THINK YOU YOU OVER OVERALL
TALK ABOUT THE ISSUE THAT WE
ALL.
WE ALL CARE ABOUT IS HOW DO WE
MAKE SURE THAT MORE PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA. GET ADDITIONAL
EDUCATION OPPORTUNITIES BEYOND
HIGH SCHOOL.
THE FOCUS ON THE JOBS OF TODAY
AND TOMORROW BECAUSE THIS
ECONOMY REWARDS PEOPLE WITH MORE
EDUCATION BUT CONVERSELY AND
MORE IMPORTANTLY IT PUNISHES
THOSE. WITHOUT EDUCATION BEYOND
HIGH SCHOOL.
AND THEN I I AGREE THAT ARE
PROBABLY PEOPLE WHO ARE
STRANDED.
AND YOU KNOW YOU LOOK AT THAT
THE YOUR YOUR MAP HERE AS KNOW
SOME POPULATION BASES SAN DIEGO
ALL A. RIVERSIDE SACRAMENTO THE
BAY AREA THEY HAVE A LOT OF
COLLEGE OPPORTUNITIES BUT ONE
THING THAT'S GREAT ABOUT THE
COMMITTEE CALLED SYSTEMS HUNDRED
FOURTEEN COLLEGES.
IS WHETHER YOU'RE UKIAH READING
SONORA.
A BAKERSFIELD WE DO HAVE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THERE TOO SO
IT'S NOT LIKE THEY'RE STRANDED
WITHOUT THAT'S WHY WE HAVE ONE
FOURTEEN ONE.
ONE FOURTEEN ACROSS THE STATE
AND DAMN I THINK YOU KNOW WE
RAISED A GOOD QUESTION IS WHY
ISN'T IT WORKING FOR THE
STUDENTS WHO ARE.
STRANDED DON.
TO GO IN AND GET MORE EDUCATION.
OPTIM THAT MORE HIGHER EDUCATION
OPPORTUNITIES TO TO ADVANCE.
THEIR CAREERS AND SO FORTH.
YOU KNOW CURRENTLY IN AN AND I
DO THINK THAT YOU RAISE A
QUESTION THAT I AM CONCERNED
ABOUT IS FOR THE POOR FOR PROFIT
COLLEGES AND ONE THING THAT BEEN
SAYING FOR FEARS IS.
IS.
THERE ARE DEPLORABLE IN MANY
WAYS.
SAY STRAIGHT UP.
BUT WOULD THEY ARE BRILLIANT AT
IS PROVIDING ACCESS SEAMLESSLY
YEAH CAN ENROLL IN THE MALL.
YOU CAN YOU CAN START ANY
MONDAY.
YOU CAN GO TO SCHOOL SCHOOL ON
FRIDAY NIGHTS WEEKENDS SUNDAYS.
AND OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES
PRETTY MUCH YOU HAVE TO START
TWICE YEAR I GUESS YOU DO THE
SUMMERS OF THREE TIMES A YEAR.
.
YOU.
UNIT UP THE COURSE OFFERINGS
YOU KNOW THAT THE STEREOTYPE IS
TRUE YOU GOTTA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
THE MONDAY THROUGH THURSDAY
FROM.
FRIEND TEND TO FOR VERY CROWDED
SOMETIMES EVENINGS BUT.
THE THE EVENINGS IN THE NIGHTS
THAT ARE PROBABLY VERY BUSY AT
THESE FOR PROFIT COLLEGES ARE
PART.
VERY QUIET THAT ON OUR.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE I THINK WE'D
DO SOMETHING DRAMATIC AND MATURE
IF INSTANT ADMINISTRATORS
FACULTY WHAT HAVE YOU BUT WE'RE
NOT SERVING. THE STUDENT NEEDS I
THINK WE SHOULD HAVE SOME
COMMUNICATIVE PROGRAM TO START.
ON A MORE FREQUENT BASIS
ESPECIALLY WHEN A DEAL WITH
THESE.
STRANDED.
ADULTS AS FAR AS HIGHER
EDUCATION NEEDS OUT SO I GET
THAT.
I DO THINK THAT.
YOU KNOW.
YOU HAVE YOUR OPINIONS BUT THAT
THE FACTS ARE THE FACTS AND
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT THAT AS
MYSTERY MAN SAID THAT THAT.
THERE ARE SOME CONCERNS AS FAR
AS THE POPULATION WERE TRYING TO
REACH.
STORK TRANSIT BEING SUCCESSFUL
THE SERVICES THEY NEED AN EVEN
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE YEARS AGO
WE WENT TO THAT.
RIPPLE BUT THE CULTURE FELIZ P.
YES THAT'S A RIGHT YEAH YEAH
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT. PEOPLE
GOING TO COLLEGE IS GIVEN THE
CLASS DOESN'T ALWAYS WORK THEY
NEED ADDITIONAL SERVICE IS.
COUNSELING UNDERSTANDING OF THE
MAYES ARE GOING THROUGH AND SO.
YOU KNOW GOING THROUGH YOUR
SMARTPHONE YOU TO THE UNIVERSITY
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S GONNA
PLAY OUT WELL.
FOR THESE FOLKS.
.
YOU KNOW THEY THAT AS THIS THAT
STAFF AGENDA AND ANALYSIS TALKS
ABOUT.
THERE ARE A LOT PEOPLE THAT
HAVE.
IT INTERNET CONNECTIVITY BUT
ALL HAVE OTHER AS A PHONE TO
PHONE DOESN'T ALWAYS WORK I KNOW
MY LITTLE KIDS THEY DO THERE
MOBYMAX IN KHAN ACADEMY AND GOT
EMAIL FROM OUR TEACHER YOU'RE
DISSING.
LA VICTORIA'S NOT NOT DOING HER.
THINGS WENT TERRACE WHAT HAPPENS
LIKE NO NO NO I SHOULD WE HAVE
AN OLD IPHONE SHE TOOK IT FOR A
FEW DAYS SHE WENT DINNER. THING
BUT IT WASN'T CONNECTING
PROPERLY DID DID AND SHE WASN'T
ABLE TO PRESS THE SAME BUTTONS
AS WE DO WITH THE COMPUTER
INTERFACE AND SO. JUST SIMPLE.
ON LOGISTICS.
WHO LIKE THAT ON?
BUT I DO HAVE TO QUESTION THE
ONE I WANT TO GIVE YOU THE
CHANCE TO TO TO ANSWER THE.
AND THAT.
IT WON'T WORK WHERE WE'VE HEARD
FROM A LOT OF PEOPLE ACROSS THE
STATE.
SOME YOU CAN BE CALLED DISTRICTS
THAT ARE. ARE VERY CONCERNED SO.
.
WHY ARE THEY SO CONCERNS
AND WHY ARE THEY POTENTIALLY
WRONG?
AND AND WHY DO THEY BELIEVE THAT
THIS WILL WILL HARM THEM PRISON
BARS THEY'RE TEETERING DISTRICTS
AS FAR AS AND ROMANTICS.
DECLINING POPULATION BASE
THEY SOME OF THEM FEW THAT. YOU
I'VE HEARD THIS AT THIS COULD BE
THE. DEATH KNELL
SOME OF THEM.
THAT THERE THEIR ENROLLMENT IN
THERE JUST STAYING AFLOAT AND
WHY ARE THEY WRONG.
SO FIRST OF ALL LET ME SAY THAT.
.
I I ABSOLUTELY RESPECT.
THE OPINIONS AND THE CONCERNS
THAT HAVE BEEN EXPRESSED FROM MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE SYSTEM.
.
I BELIEVE THAT THIS ANXIETY THIS
CONCERN COMES FROM A PLACE OF.
OF NOT BEING.
SURE THAT.
THE THE WAY THAT THEY'RE
CURRENTLY FUNDED WILL CONTINUE
TO SUPPORT THEIR OPERATION.
SO. IN MY MIND.
AND CERTAINLY CONCERNS I'VE
HEARD FROM THEM ARE THAT IF WE
IMPLEMENT THIS NEW.
PLATFORM THIS NEW ORGANIZATION
THIS NEW COLLEGE.
THAT THEY FEAR THAT IT WILL.
ULTIMATELY.
ROB THEM OF THEIR ROMANCE.
SO.
PROBLEM WITH THAT TO.
CONCERN ISN'T
DAMAGE INDIVIDUALS EXPRESSING A
CONCERN THE PROBLEM IS.
THE SYSTEM THAT WE'VE CREATE.
THAT RELY SO HEAVILY ON
ENROLLMENT.
INSTEAD OF RELYING AND PROVIDING
THE RESOURCES NECESSARY FOR THE
COLLEGES TO DO THE MISSION THAT
THERE.
I HAVE TO DO.
SO I THINK PART OF THE CHALLENGE
IS THE CURRENT CONTEXT THAT WERE
IN.
AS LONG AS WE CONTINUE TO ONLY
RELY ON ENROLLMENT FOR GROWTH IN
REVENUES.
THEN COLLEGES ARE EXPRESSING AND
NATURAL ANXIETY.
WHICH IS.
WILL THIS NEW INSTITUTION TAKE
STUDENTS AWAY FROM MY COLLEGE.
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT THEIR
ANXIETY CENTERS ON WHETHER OR
NOT.
WE SHOULD.
REACHES POPULATION I BELIEVE
THEIR CONCERN COMES FROM THIS
NOTION SO. I'M NOT SAYING THAT
THEIR CONCERNS ARE WRONG I'M
SAYING THAT WE AS A SYSTEM. OR
CREATING THIS CONCERN THAT IT'S
COMING FROM THE WRONG PLACE YEAH
IRIS AS MISTER CHAVEZ SAYS
CHANGE IS HARD. DELAYS THAT OLD
SAYING THAT.
ABOUT CHANGE IN A HALF THE
PEOPLE.
OUR.
CAUTIOUSLY LIKE YOU.
I'M OPTIMISTIC ABOUT THE SUCCESS
AND PEOPLE DON'T LIKE IT CHANGE
OUR ONE CERTAIN ONE HUNDRED
PERCENT CERTAIN AS FAR AS THE.
NEGATIVE IMPACTS OF THOSE THESE
THINK THINGS TOGETHER. AND YOU
KNOW.
MAKE MAKE THE ISSUE DAUNTING.
THE OTHER QUESTION THAT THAT.
I'LL THAT YOU PROBABLY ANSWERED.
AND THESE ARE.
QUESTION
SO BUT DOES IT MEAN THAT MIGHT
GET AYE CONCERNS ARE ARE ARE
THAT BUT I'LL I'LL I'LL GIVE YOU
A CHANCE TO TO ADDRESS THIS IS.
WHY CAN'T THE EXISTING COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM?
AND THE HUNDRED FOURTEEN
COLLEGES.
.
WHY CAN'T THEY DO THIS WHY CAN'T
WE EXPAND THERE ARE RESOURCES
FOR THOSE ONLINE PROGRAMS?
BECAUSE THEY THEY ALREADY HAVE.
THE.
THAT ACCREDITATION ISSUES WHERE
THE FINANCIAL AID REVEALED TO
GET THERE FROM THE GATE THE RD
HAVE THE SUPPORT SERVICES.
THAT THE FAMILY MEMBERS IN THAT.
THEN THAT. STUDENT POPULATION
KNOWS ABOUT THAT THE HISTORY IN
THE COMMUNION WHAT THIS PLACE IS
THEY HAVE A BRAND NAME.
.
AND THEN THEY COULD HAVE.
HYBRID TYPE CLASSES WHERE YOU
CAN GO IN PERSON ACTUALLY SEEING
SOMEBODY AND RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
STUDENTS ARE ACTUALLY HAVE THAT.
DO MUCH BETTER THAN PURE ONLINE
SO WHY CAN'T WE USE THE
EXISTING.
CAN BE CALLED SYSTEM AND
AUGMENT THAT TO MAKEUP AND A
STRONGER ONLINE PRESENCE.
COURSE THAT IS A FAIR QUESTION.
IT'S A QUESTION BEING RAISED
WITHIN OUR OUR SYSTEM.
A FIRST OF ALL LET ME.
TING YOU TO TRY TO BE CLEAR.
.
WE'RE PROPOSING ITS A COMPETENCY
BASED EDUCATION MODEL A
PERSONALIZED LEARNING PLATFORM.
WHICH IS DIFFERENT VERY
DIFFERENT THAN OUR TRADITIONAL.
SEEK TIME FOR CREDIT.
STRUCTURE THAT WE'RE PROVIDING
WHETHER ONLINE OR IN THE BRICK
AND MORTAR CLASSROOM.
SO ONE.
.
REALLY CREATING A VERY.
COMPLETELY NEW DELIVERY MODEL
IT'S PART OF WHY WE FEEL A NEW
ONLINE. ORGANIZATION COLLEGE
WHATEVER YOU WANNA CALL IT IS
APPROPRIATE.
BECAUSE IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO.
A UP AND THE ACADEMIC CALENDAR
FOR ONE OF OUR TRADITIONAL
COLLEGES.
AND THE SCALE AT WHICH WE'RE
TRYING TO ACHIEVE IN THE URGENCY
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO.
TO ME.
.
BUT WE FEEL.
WOULD BE EASIER TO ACCOMPLISH IF
WE DEDICATED A GROUP OF FACULTY.
SOLE PURPOSE WAS TO DEVELOP THE
CONTENT FOR THIS PLATFORM AND TO
FOCUS ON THE NEEDS OF ADULTS OR.
.
CERTAINLY THERE ARE COLLEGES AND
I BELIEVE.
IN IN THE SENATE HEARING ABOUT
SAN ANTONIO COLLEGE PRESIDENT
BILL SCRUGGS DID A GREAT JOB OF
EX.
EXPLAINING HOW HE HAS
IT'S COLLEGE OF THE PROGRAM.
THAT DEALS WITH SOME OF THESE
NEEDS.
BUT THE NEEDS THAT.
HE IS SERVING ARE RELATIVELY
SMALL AND CONFINED TO HIS
DISTRICT BOUNDARIES.
SO IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO
SATISFY THOSE NEEDS AT SCALE. IF
WE GO COLLEGE BY COLLEGE WITHIN
REACH IN BECAUSE AT THE END OF
THE DAY. THAT COLLEGE HAS TO
PRODUCE ITS ENROLLMENT FOR ITS
OWN BUDGET.
AND SO WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
IS ELIMINATE SOME OF THAT
COMPETITION.
BUT ALSO.
AGAIN.
.
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT.
TWO ASK A COLLEGE.
QUICKLY ADOPT AND ADAPT A BRAND
NEW.
SCHEDULING MODEL OF BRAND NEW
ACADEMIC CALENDAR A BRAND NEW
WAY OF DELIVERING CONTENT.
A IN A VERY SHORT PERIOD OF
TIME.
WHAT WE HOPE IS THAT THIS ONLINE
COLLEGE WILL PROVIDE THAT
EXAMPLE THAT LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT THAT EXPERIMENTATION
THAT WILL THEN ALLOW ALL HUNDRED
FOURTEEN COLLEGES TO MORE
QUICKLY ADAPT?
MODELS THAT MIRROR.
WHAT'S BEING OFFERED AND ALLOW
THEM TO BUILD THEIR OWN CAPACITY
SO.
THAT'S WHY.
WE FEEL THAT ADDING ONE MORE
MISSION.
TO THE COLLEGES.
DOESN'T ALLOW THEM.
THE OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY REACH.
.
THE PROBLEM IN A WAY THAT.
WE FEEL IS NECESSARY IN THE
SCALE THAT WE THINK WE NEED.
OKAY THANK YOU.
OUT WITH THAT WE WILL NOW
PROCEED TO PUBLIC COMMENTS.
PLEASE LINE UP IN THE MIDDLE.
OKAY WAY WHILE WE'RE LIGHTING AT
ANOTHER'S LA PEOPLE OUTSIDE AS
WELL I BELIEVE WHEN A SPEAKS A
PLEASE TRY TO KEEP YOUR COMMENTS
TO. ONE MINUTES OR LESS.
SIXTY SECONDS
OR LET'S.
THANK YOU.
PLEASE BE A.
HI I'M ROXANNE.
I LIVED STUDENT OF THE
CHANCELLOR WAS TALKING ABOUT I
JUST WANTED TO SAY THAT.
THIS REALLY COULD HELP A LOT OF
STUDENTS.
NOT ONLY.
WHO WOULD HAVE A PROBLEM WITH ON
LINE COLLEGE BUT?
WHICH TRADITIONAL COLLEGE BUT
WITH.
MENTAL DISORDERS I MYSELF
SUFFER FROM ANXIETY AND
DEPRESSION AND THIS RIGHT HERE
IS A REALLY. REALLY BIG THING
FOR ME.
GOING TO COLLEGE.
I HAD A BREAKDOWN. IN FRONT OF
YOU THEIR COLLEGE AND I COULDN'T
EVEN WALK THROUGH THE DOORS I
SAT THERE FOR TWO. HOURS BAWLING
MY EYES OUT BECAUSE IT WAS SO
HARD FOR ME TO.
DO IT.
BECAUSE I HAVE A FEAR OF GROUPS
AND PEOPLE LAW AND MY ANXIETY
GETS THROUGH THE ROOF SO THIS.
COULD REALLY HELP.
.
EVERYBODY AS WELL AS FINANCES
BECAUSE I AM OF AS A FULL TIME
JOB.
SO WITH THAT IT'S HARD TO.
GET EVERYTHING TOGETHER AND IT'S
REALLY OVERWHELMING.
HAVING TO GO TO COLLEGE HAVING
TO GO TO WORK HAVING TO FOCUS ON
MY MENTAL HEALTH.
AS WELL AS EVERYBODY ELSE'S
HEALTH AROUND.
.
IT'S REALLY AT THAT.
COULD DO A LOT AND IT COULD HELP
A LOT OF OTHERS WHO ALSO HAVE
THE SAME PROBLEM THAT I DEAL. AT
SO THANK YOU FOR HEARING ME OUT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS THOMAS
GREEN AYE SERVICE THE PRESIDENT
OF AMERICAN RIVER COLLEGE HERE
IN SACRAMENTO.
AND AND SIMILAR TO MOST OTHER
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN OUR SYSTEM
A OUR SEE HIS HISTORICALLY
APPROACHED ONLINE EDUCATION AS A
WAY TO SERVE OUR COLLEGE IN
REGIONAL STUDENTS ARE LOOKING TO
AUGMENT THEIR IN PERSON COURSES
AND PROGRAMS.
AND THE ONLINE COLLEGE
REPRESENTS A VERY DIFFERENT
MODEL SO HIS PROPOSED YOU HEARD
MANY THINGS SO I'M ADVANCEMENT.
ADVANCE CREDIT A CREDIT FOR
PRIOR LEARNING MEETING COMPLEX
HE'S ONLINE FLEXIBLE SHORT TERM
FORMAT THAT INTEGRATES WORK
BASED LEARNING.
THESE IN THE OTHER PROPOSED
DESIGN AND DELIVERY ELEMENTS OF
THE ONLINE COLLEGE ARE CRITICAL
TO FURTHERING OUR COLLECTIVE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT EFFORTS
YET A RC AS WELL AS THE OTHER
HUNDRED THIRTEEN COLLEGES. HAVE
BEEN UNABLE TO IMPLEMENT THESE
AT SCALE TO DO EXISTING BARRIERS
AND LAWS REGULATIONS AND OTHER
SYSTEM AN INSTITUTIONAL
CONSTRAINTS.
SO THE STATUTORY BASIS FOR THE
ONLINE COLLEGE REMOVES MANY
THESE CONSTRAINTS. EXCUSE ME AND
IN DOING SO CREATE OPPORTUNITY
TO PROTOTYPE.
THESE DESIGN AND DELIVERY
ELEMENTS THAT CAN BE REFINED AND
EXPANDED ACROSS OUR ENTIRE
SYSTEM AND IN DOING SO
STRENGTHEN OUR ENTIRE ONLINE
ECOSYSTEM.
SO I AM CONCERNED ABOUT THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT
REFERS OFFERING TO YOUR
ASSOCIATE DEGREES AND TRANSFER
PREPARATION.
HOWEVER I FEEL AND.
THAT THAT IN MY OPINION THAT
THAT FLEXIBLE AFFORDABLE FULLY
ONLINE OPTION FOR WORKING ADULTS
TO OBTAIN SHORT TERM SUB
ASSOCIATE DEGREE CREDENTIALS
WILL NOT DUPLICATE EFFORTS OF
OTHER COLLEGES INCLUDING AIR
SEA.
IN FACT MAY COMPLEMENT THEM. AND
IT WILL NOT COMPETE WITH OUR
ONLINE AT INITIATIVE.
IT'S PRIMARILY FOCUSED ON
UNDERGRADUATE EDUCATION AND
TRANSFER PREPARATION THANK YOU.
I THINK I LIKE YOU. PATH
MCCALLUM WITH THE LARGE DISTRICT
COALITION I LIKED FIRST TALK
ABOUT THE FUNDING FORMULA.
OF THE CALIFORNIA COMEY COLLEGES
ARE THE LARGEST TIRES ADD SYSTEM
IN THE WORLD LET'S THAT WAIT FOR
THAT IS THAT NEXT GUY SO ON THE
ONLINE ACCOUNT SO YOU TAKEN BUT
I THINK YOU TAKEN BOTH.
SO IN REGARDS TO THE ONLINE
PROPOSAL.
.
OUR CLIENTS AGREE WITH THE
GOVERNOR AND THE CHANCELLOR THAT
WE NEED TO STEP UP ON COPS HE
BASED EDUCATION AND TRY TO
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO BETTER
APPROACH. THOSE KIND OF STUDENTS
IN EDUCATION.
THE BARRIERS IN PLACE ARE BOTH
FUNDING AND STATUTORY.
IF WE CAN FOR EXAMPLE IN
FUNDING.
SO PUT SOME TARGETED FUNDING FOR
COMP SEE BASIS BEING SUGGESTED
IN THIS PROPOSED BUDGET. CHANGE
SOME REGULATIONS PRESIDENT GREEN
JUST TALKED ABOUT THEN I THINK
YOU CAN SEE COMMITTEE COLLEGES.
EITHER DIRECTLY IN THE COMMITTEE
COLLEGES STEP UP AND DO THIS
MORE. OR THROUGH THE ONLINE
INITIATIVE AND IF YOU CHOOSE TO
DO THE.
UNDER FIFTEEN COLLEGE SO
THEY'RE DIFFERENT WAYS TO DO
THIS.
MIGHT CLIENTS ARE READY TO STEP
UP AND GROW IN THIS AREA ONE
CHANGE ON THIS THAT WOULD BE
DRAMATIC IS HOW WE FUND ONLINE
EDUCATION. SO WE KNOW THAT THERE
IS A SIXTEEN PERCENT DROP IN
COMMITTEE COLLEGES WHEN YOU GO
ONLINE IF YOU HYBRID. THAT AND
YOU HAD DIRECT TUTORS YOUR
RESULTS GO UP.
SO WHAT THE WAY WE FIND ONLINE
IS ON UP OF PEOPLE COUNT THAT'S
ABOUT AN EIGHT PERCENT DROP. IF
WE COULD CHANGE THAT TO A CENSUS
DATE WOULD BE MORE LIKELY TO BE
ABLE THEY ADD THOSE TUTORS AND
HYBRID EDUCATION.
AND ONLINE EDUCATION.
SO IT'S A BIG ISSUE. AND THE
COMMITTEE COLLEGES ARE READY TO
STEP UP I WAS WITH THE I THINK
YOU.
I I'M GREGORY VAN ACKER I'M
ACTUALLY HERE FOR SOMETHING ELSE
ON HERE FOR CAL RTA. PERSONALLY
ALSO HAPPEN TO SEE THIS HAPPEN
TO SEE THIS COMMITTEE MEETING.
AND SO I CAME IN AND.
I'M NOW CURRENTLY I WAS UP FOR
TWENTY YEARS ALMOST TWENTY YEARS
I WAS A. COMPUTER INSTRUCTOR AT
VALLEY I TAUGHT ACTUALLY AND
HE'S TO
TO DO THAT TAUGHT IT A.
MICROSOFT CERTIFICATION PROGRAM
AND I DID CERTIFICATIONS IN.
HIGH SCHOOL.
MIKE SUPPORT IN MICROSOFT EXCEL.
AND I AM NOW AND AS A PART TIME
STRUCTURE I'M TEACHING AT
SACRAMENTO CITY COLLEGE AND WHAT
I SEE IN. WHAT I'VE SEEN SO FAR
SECOND CITY COLLISION ACCIDENT
CLASSES BECAUSE SOME THIS RIVER?
IS THAT THE HYBRID MODEL REALLY
WORKED WELL FOR MY OLDER
STUDENTS
IS THAT. THE VAST MAJORITY OF
STUDENTS THAN I HAD EVEN THE
TWENTY FOUR TO THIRTY FIVE YEAR
OLDS. THEY HAVE THE OPTION TO DO
AN ONLINE CLASS BUT THEY CHOSE
TO BE IN CLASS MY CLASS WHICH
WAS MORE OF A HYBRID CLASS PART
OF THE INSTRUCTION WAS ONLINE.
LOT OF IT WAS IN CLASS IN MY
EXPERIENCE WAS THAT THE OLDER
STUDENTS. REALLY NEEDED AN
INSTRUCTOR.
AND MY EXPERIENCE IN THE
CERTIFICATION CLASSES.
WAS THAT THE HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS THAT I HAD SEVERELY
NEEDED COACHING TO BE ABLE TO
GET THROUGH A CERTIFICATION
TESTS.
AND I DON'T REALLY SEE HOW.
CERTIFICATION TEST FOR MICROSOFT
OFFICE COULD BE PASSED.
BY PEOPLE JUST DOING ONLINE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN PARTY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MARIO
GUERRERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
CFA IS OPPOSED TO THE GOVERNOR'S
ONLINE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
PROPOSAL AS WRITTEN.
WE DO WANT TO MAKE CLEAR THAT
CFA DOES NOT OPPONENT OPPOSE
ONLINE EDUCATION AND THE MANY OF
OUR MEMBERS HAVE TAUGHT OR
TEACHINGS OF SUCH COURSES AT THE
CSU. WE BELIEVE THAT IF YOU
PROPOSAL MOVES FORWARD IT MUST
FOLLOW AT LEAST FOUR PRINCIPLES
USE EXISTING ADMINISTRATIVE
STRUCTURES THAT MEANS NOT IN
CREATING A NEW COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT. TO NOT DUPLICATING
CITY PROGRAMS OR CLASSES THREE
NOT CONJURING ACT CONTRACTING
OUT WORK INCLUDING CURRICULUM
DEVELOPMENT COURSE DESIGN AND
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY SUPPORT
FOR PROTECTING THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING.
RIGHTS OF PEOPLE WHO WORK IN
THESE PROGRAMS.
WE BELIEVE THAT WE MUST PROTECT
OUR STUDENTS FROM EXPLOITATION.
.
BUY ONLINE.
PROF BY ONLINE FOR PROFIT
COLLEGES BUT WE MUST NOT ALLOW
HOURS OUR PUBLIC SYSTEM BE TO
BECOME MORE LIKE THEM OFFERING
LOW QUALITY CLASSES AND
CONTRACTING OUT WORK IN A
QUESTIONABLE EFFORT TO SAVE A
FEW BUCKS.
HIGH QUALITY EDUCATION IS NOT
CHEAP
A TAKING SOME ONLINE COURSES AS
PART OF A BRICK AND MORTAR
DEGREE PROGRAM IS ONE THING
ENTIRE ONLINE.
DEGREES IS ANOTHER.
AT THE END OF THE DAY WE BELIEVE
THAT THE.
A PROPOSED FUNDING WOULD BE
BETTER SPENT SUPPORTING ONLINE
EDUCATIONAL OFFERINGS IN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TODAY WE
BELIEVE THAT IF THE GOVERNOR
REALLY WANTS TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IN HIGHER EDUCATION
AND ACCESS ONE THING YOU COULD
DO IS FULLY FUND THE SEGMENTS.
TO ENSURE THAT EACH QUALIFIED
STUDENT HAS A SEAT AND IS NOT
TURNED AWAY DUE TO FUNDING THINK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING JENNIFER BAKER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION.
WE DO HAVE A NUMBER OF SERIOUS
CONCERNS BUT THAT THE MOST
PROMINENT CONCERN IS.
THE LACK OF CONSTITUTIONALITY
IN THE SET UP OF THE STRUCTURE
OF THE BOARD WE BELIEVE IT'S AN
CONSTITUTIONAL CONFLICT. TO THE
TENETS OF PROP NINETY EIGHT IT
WOULD NOT BE SUSTAINABLE.
PARTICULARLY BECAUSE ONCE THAT
THE COLLEGES ESTABLISH IT'S RUN
BY A PRIVATE BOARD GRANTED THIS
IS THE BOARD OF GOVERNORS BUT IN
CONTEXT OF PROP NINETY EIGHT
IT'S NOT A LOCAL ELECT
EDUCATIONAL AGENCY WHICH MEANS
PROP NINETY EIGHT DOLLARS CANNOT
FLOW IN BE MANAGED. THROUGH THAT
INSTITUTION AND THEREFORE IT'S
AN CONSTITUTIONAL CONFLICT IN
CANNOT BE RECTIFIED IN LESS THIS
WERE TO ACTUALLY RUN THROUGH A
LOCAL COMMUNICABLE AGE THAT'S
DIRECTLY ACCOUNTABLE TO VOTERS.
DIRECTLY ACCOUNTABLE TO VOTERS
WE DO HAVE A NUMBER OF OTHER
CONCERNS.
IT THIS IS SOMEWHAT AKIN TO
WHAT K. TWELVE HAS EXPERIENCE
WITH. CHARTER SCHOOLS THERE WERE
A NUMBER OF UNANTICIPATED
IMPACTS THAT CHARTER SCHOOLS HAD
ON THE EDUCATIONAL ESTABLISHMENT
WE THINK THAT THIS COULD OPEN UP
A SERIES OF FUN INTENDED.
IMPACTS ON THE COMMUNICABLE ITS
SYSTEM AND WOULD WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT ALL OF YOUR QUESTIONS
AND CONCERNS ARE ANSWERED PRIOR
TO MOVING FORWARD. SUCH AS
CONSIDERING THE FACT THAT THESE
INSTITUTION COULD POTENTIALLY
SERVE STUDENTS OTHER THAN THE
TARGETED DEMOGRAPHIC HOW WOULD
THIS IMPACT HE TWELVE DUAL
ENROLLMENT STUDENTS HOW DO YOU
ENSURE THAT WE'RE GONNA HAVE.
EQUITABLE STUDENT SUCCESS FOR
ALL STUDENTS THAT WANT TO
PARTICIPATE WHETHER OR NOT THEY
BELONG TO THE TARGET TARGET
DEMOGRAPHIC ADDITIONALLY SINCE
THIS INSTITUTION WOULD HAVE THE
ABILITY TO SET FEES THAT WOULD
BE DIFFERENTIATED THEN THE FEES
THAT THE LEGISLATURE
STRUCTURING.
HOW DO WE KNOW AT THE END OF THE
DAY IN THE LONG RUN THAT THE FEE
STRUCTURE WOULD BE SIMILAR TO
THE FEE STRUCTURE THAT WE'VE
SEEN FOR PROFIT INSTITUTIONS?
UTILIZING BECAUSE IT HAS TO BE
CONSISTENT WITH THE COSTS OF
EDUCATION THE LEGISLATURE HAS
WORKED DILIGENTLY TO ENSURE THAT
STUDENT FEES ARE KEPT TO A
MINIMUM. THIS WOULD DEVIATE FROM
THAT SO WE WOULD ASK THOSE
QUESTIONS BE ANSWERED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ERICA BECAME SOLANO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE MODESTO JUNIOR
COLLEGE I'M CTE FACULTY AND
DISTANCE EDUCATION COORDINATOR.
AYE FEES THIS TARGET POPULATION
EVERY SINGLE DAY THEY DON'T WANT
TO BE ONLINE THEY WANT THE
EXPERIENCE THAT WE OFFER AS
FACULTY IN THE CLASSROOM. I DO
TEACH ONLINE AND HYBRID AS WELL
I EXPERIENCED A SUCCESS RATES I
UNDERSTAND THEIR NEEDS THEY WANT
TO BE IN THE CLASS WITH THE
SUPPORT OF BY PUTTING AND
PRESIDENT THIS FALL WE ARE
ROLLING OUT SOME INNOVATIVE
SCHEDULING. THAT MEETS THE
STUDENTS NEEDS NOT JUST FACULTY
WE'RE TURNING AROUND AND WE WILL
SEE SUCCESS DATA IN THE SPRING.
NOT TEN YEARS OUT AFTER WEAVER
RECEIVED ACCREDITATION SOLANO
WAS RECEIVED FULL SEVEN YEAR
TERM ACCREDITATION THAT IS NOT A
CONCERN IT CAN BE DONE WITHIN
THE CURRENT SYSTEM OF A
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS JOHNSON LIGHTMAN A
BEHALF OF THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION CATHARINE COMMUTER
COLLEGE THE FIRST ONE I THINK
YOU FOR HOLDING THIS HEARING.
AND I ALSO WANT TO THANK YOUR
STAFF FOR THEIR TREMENDOUS
ANALYSIS AND WE'VE DISTRIBUTED A
LETTER OUTLINING OUR CONCERNS
AND WOULD VERY MUCH LIKE TO
ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH THE LA
SHOW.
WE HAVE HEARD FROM FACULTY.
IN ADDITION TO THE SPEAKER WHO
JUST AS SPOKE. THAT HAVE
EXPRESSED THE SAME CONCERNS AND
IF ASKED THE QUESTION.
THAT WITH THE O. E. AYE THE
STRONG WORK FORCE AND EVEN OUR
OPPORTUNITIES WITH CONTRACT
EDUCATION.
DON'T WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DO THIS TO GO TO MISLEAD MOUNDS
QUESTION AS WELL. THE IDEA THAT
WE START A PROGRAM WE SAY THAT
WE'RE NOT GONNA GROW WHEN LAST
WE MEET CERTAIN CONSIDERATIONS
AND YET WE SEE TIME AND TIME
AGAIN WHERE THE POLITICAL.
CONSIDERATIONS COME AND THEY
OVERWHELM THAT
AND THE PROGRAM GOES AND SO THE
IDEA THAT WE'RE THINKING NOW
THAT IT'S NOT GOING TO COMPETE
IN THE FUNDING STRUCTURE BUT
THEIR EXISTING COLLEGES. CHANGES
OVER TIME BECAUSE THERE ARE
CONSTITUENCIES THAT SAY THAT WE
CAN BENEFIT FROM EXPANSION NOT
WITHSTANDING WHATEVER ANALYSIS
HASN'T BEEN DONE. AND I WOULD
JUST LIKE TO ECHO ON IT MISTER
CHAIRMAN JUST AS YOU WERE
POINTING OUT YOUR IPHONE SAYING
THAT THERE WERE SOME CONCERNS.
THAT WAS THE MOMENT I PULLED OUT
MY IPAD AND AND NOTED THAT THE
WIFE IN THIS ROOM IS NOT
WORKING.
AND IT'S I JUST SAID TO MYSELF
WELL CAN YOU SPELL IRONY THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING
THIS HEARING. MY NAME IS LIKE
TONY ON MY FACULTY OF CONSUMERS
THROUGH THEIR COLLEGE.
AND SO I HAVE BEEN TEACHING FOR
FIVE YEARS AND I HAVE SEEN A
STUDENTS WHO ARE ON THE GROUND
AND ALSO HAVE ME THEN ALSO ON
NINE. AND THE MOST COMPLAIN I
HEAR IS FOR THAT ONLINE IS
STUDENTS THAT'S HOMELESS TIMES
LISA. TO GET CLINICS TO TRY
ONLINE TO MAKE POSTERS THAT ARE
NOT NECESSARY THEY NEVER USE IT
IN THE REAL LIFE. SO TO BE
HONEST I FEEL LIKE THIS MUCH
MONEY TURNED F THERE IS ANY OF
THE SENT TO CHANGE ANY ONLINE
COURSES NEEDS TO BE DONE ON THE
CURRENT ONLINE CLASSES NOT
MAKING A WHOLE NEW COLLEGE. AND
I BELIEVE JUST JUST THAT TO BE
THE LEAST OF TOTAL MUCH.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS JEANETTE
MULHEARN AND I'M HERE
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATORS IN WHICH WE
DID SEND A POSITION STATEMENT
AGAINST THE ONLINE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE.
SO JUST TO BRIEFLY LET YOU KNOW
OUR POSITION IS THAT THE NEW
ONLINE COLLEGE WOULD NOT PROVIDE
NEW OPPORTUNITY BUT WOULD
INSTEAD COMPETE WITH A HUNDRED
NINE EXISTED. VIBRANT EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION AND CHILD
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS OFFERED
THROUGH THE STATE. EIGHTY FIVE
OR MORE OF WHICH CURRENTLY OFFER
VIABLE DISTANCE ONLINE ACCESS TO
DEGREES CERTIFICATES IN CHILD
DEVELOPMENT.
AND WHICH ALREADY SERVE OUR
DIVERSE POPULATION IN VERY
CAREER TRAINING NEEDS
FOR QUALITY TEACHERS OF YOUNG
CHILDREN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I CAN MORNING I LYRICAL EASIER
WITH THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA WE
REPRESENT ALL SEVENTY TWO
DISTRICTS THE LEADERSHIP THE
TRUSTEE OF THE CHANCES THE
PRESIDENT'S. ARE THOMAS GREEN IS
THE PRESIDENT OF A ARE SEIZE
THEM ONE OF THE MEMBERS OF THE
CEO WORKING GROUP LOOKING AT
THIS ONLINE AND THEY HAVE SOME
DESIGN PRINCIPLES ME FIRST OF
ALL. THERE'S A DIVERSITY OF
OPINION THROUGHOUT THEIR THE THE
SYSTEM AS YOU AS YOU KNOW.
BUT EVERYONE I THINK AGREES
WITH THE IDEA OF STRENGTHENING
OUR PUBLIC OPTION OR OPTIONS FOR
ONLINE EDUCATION BECAUSE WE'VE
SEEN WHAT'S HAPPENED A
PRIVATIZATION SOME OF THE DESIGN
PRINCIPLES AND WE. WE CERTAINLY
SUPPORT GOVERNOR'S.
PROPOSAL DO EXPLORE INNOVATIVE
APPROACHES FOR SOME KIND OF A
REDESIGN PUBLIC ONLINE AN
ECOSYSTEM IN IN TOTO.
AND ALSO. THERE IS UNANIMITY
THAT WHATEVER IS FINALLY DECIDED
THAT THIS WORKS WITHIN THE
ECOSYSTEM THAT INCLUDES THE
ONLINE EDUCATION INITIATIVE IN
OTHER WORDS.
THIS SHOULD BE IN AND NOT AND
NOT IN OR. OUT THERE WAS A
MENTION ABOUT REGULATIONS AND
CONCERNS ABOUT FINANCING
CONCERNS THAT THOSE ARE
CERTAINLY THROUGHOUT THE.
THROUGHOUT WE ALSO HAD ONE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE ARE IN IN WEST
HILLS TALKING ABOUT CONNECTIVITY
AND THAT'S ALL THAT'S A LARGER
CONCERN. ON.
THE THE.
AREN'T DE UNIT IS A VERY
EXCITING THING TO REALLY LOOK
AND DO AN ANALYSIS OF HOW TO
DESIGN ONLINE EDUCATION THAT
COULD HELP AGAIN. CALIFORNIA'S
PUBLIC COMMUNITY COLLEGES OR AS
A WHOLE AND IF THIS ENTITY CAN
PRESENT PREVENT. OUR PRESENT
DESIGN PRINCIPLES BETTER THAN
PROTOTYPE AND THEN CAN BE
UTILIZED THROUGHOUT THE SYSTEM
THAT'S A FANTASTIC. SO THERE'S
SUPPORT FOR THE IDEA OF
INNOVATIVE APPROACHES WE HAVE TO
A WE HAVE TO OFFER A PUBLIC
OPTION.
SO.
AB AND APPRECIATE ALL THE
QUESTIONS.
HELLO GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S
PAUL VOTES MORE EACH HISTORY I'M
HAS REPRESSOR IT.
THREE COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN THE
SACRAMENTO AREA.
AND I'M HERE TO SAY THAT.
I DEFINITELY THINK THAT THIS
MONEY WOULD BE BETTER SPENT ON
EXISTING PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE
IN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND.
MOSTLY BECAUSE WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT THIS TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION STRANDED WORKERS.
ARE THERE ALSO MEMBERS OF
COMMUNITIES SO THERE THERE'S THE
IDEA OF A STATEWIDE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE THAT THEY REPRESENT THAT
WOULD BE BETTER SERVED IF YOU
ADDRESS THEM AS MEMBERS OF.
COMMUNITY
THE I'VE TAUGHT ONLINE ONE
GROUND HYBRID CLASSES AND
WITHOUT A DOUBT THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL STUDENTS OF THE WANT
TO HAVE SOME SORT OF FACE TO
FACE ACCESS.
WHETHER IT'S A HYBRID CLASS OR
EVEN AN ONLINE CLASS
SO WHAT REALLY NEEDS TO BE DONE
IS ENCOURAGING MORE DEVELOPMENT
OF THESE ONLINE CLASSES ON THE
COMMUNITY LEVEL. AND MORE FULL
TIME TEACHERS OF CHANGING THE
PART TIME FULL TIME RATIO AND
ALSO MORE COUNSELORS. FOR DIRECT
CONTACT THIS IS WHAT. I THINK
LEADS TO MORE.
MEASURE WILL.
.
DEGREES OF SUCCESS FOR STUDENTS.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS.
BRIAN HOW WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS I VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE QUESTIONS BEING
RAISED BY THE CURRENT COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. ABOUT THIS PROCESS.
.
LAST YEAR OBSCENE IF HE TOOK THE
LEAD IN ASKING FOR SOME A PART
TIME OFFICE HOURS MONEY WE WERE
TOLD THAT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
WAS ALL IT. WAS A FORTY.
BUT THIS YEAR SOMEHOW WE WERE
ABLE TO FIND HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS.
DOORS AT YOU UNPROVEN
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE AND SOMEWHAT
UNNECESSARY PROGRAM.
IF YOU'RE REALLY OUT IF YOU
REALLY WANT AND AND AND HANDS
STUDENT SUCCESS AND ACCESS THERE
ARE OTHER WAYS.
FOR US TO IMPROVE.
WE KNOW A THING OR TWO ABOUT.
STUDENT SUCCESS AND ACTS AS WE
WE TEACH THE STUDENTS.
ARE WE WANT YOU TO CONSIDER
EXPANDING THE CURRENT ONLINE
EDUCATION INITIATIVE IT'S OF
EIGHTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT THAT THE STATE HAS.
.
INVESTED IN.
PLEASE CONSIDER ARE MOVING
FORWARD ON SOME OF THE OPTIONS
THAT ALREADY EXIST AND. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
HI I'M JEFFREY MICHAEL'S I'M THE
PRESIDENT OF TRIPLE SAY I THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
INDEPENDENCE AND I TEACH AT
CONTRA COSTA COLLEGE.
TEACHING THEM HYBRID ENGLISH
CLASS THIS SEMESTER AND IF YOU'D
ASKED ME A YEAR AGO YOU COULD
LEARN ANYTHING ONLINE AT A
LAUGHED.
BUT NOW WE KNOW THAT MY STUDENTS
CAN ACTUALLY WATCH ME TEACH ON A
LITTLE VIDEO RIGHT ON THEIR
BONES AND I THINK IT HAS SOME
POTENTIAL I THINK SHORT TERM
CERTIFICATES HAVE SOME
POTENTIAL.
I THINK WE CAN DO IT BETTER AND
CHEAPER.
BY WORKING THROUGH OUR EXISTING
STRUCTURES BUT MOSTLY I JUST
WANNA SAY THIS IS NOT HOW WE
SHOULD WORK.
WHEN WE IDENTIFY A PROBLEM OR A
NEW GROUP OF STUDENTS THAT WE'RE
NOT SERVING WE SAY HEY WE WANT
TO SERVE THE STUDENTS.
WHAT ARE THE IDEAS WE SHOULD BE
SITTING DOWN WITH FACULTY AND
ADMINISTRATORS AND STAKEHOLDERS
IN THE COMMUNITY AND COMING UP
WITH A PROPOSAL AND REACHING
CONSENSUS AND BRINGING IT TO YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT? YOU'VE HEARD
FROM ALL THE FACULTY GROUPS THE
SENATE DIDN'T COME UP BUT THEY
HAVE A POSITION AGAINST THE
ONLINE COLLEGE THE FACULTY ARE
NOT ON BOARD WHY WOULD WE START
A NEW COLLEGE. WHEN THE FACULTY
IN OUR SYSTEM ARE NOT ON BOARD
WITH THE PLAN THAT DOESN'T MAKE
ANY SENSE TO ME.
FOR WE START ALLOCATING NEW
DOLLARS TO NEW IDEAS WE SHOULD
COME TOGETHER AS A SYSTEM AND
WORK TOGETHER TO COME UP WITH
THE BEST IDEAS POSSIBLE I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY WE DON'T WORK
THAT WAY THANK YOU.
I DID ARE COMING AND PRESENT A
LOS RIOS CALLS FEDERATION
TEACHERS ALSO SEE OF TEA AND
FAT.
I'M.
AGAIN YOU KNOW THAT THEY ARE NOT
AFRAID OF INNOVATION.
THAT THEY'RE NOT AFRAID OF
IMPROVEMENT. BATTLING ARE OR ARE
NOT AFRAID OF TRYING GETTING
BETTER ACCESS FOR ALL THE
STUDENT POPULATIONS THAT ARE OUT
THERE.
WE'RE NOT AFRAID OF INNOVATION.
WE'RE ALL FOR THAT WERE ALL FOR
ONLINE EDUCATION BUT WE WANT TO
DO IT THE BEST WAY POSSIBLE THAT
EDUCATES THE STUDENTS THE BEST
WAY POSSIBLE. A WE CAN DO THIS
THAT WE CAN DO AND.
WE CAN ACCESS TO STUDENTS AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL.
WE COULD DETERMINE WHETHER
STUDENTS ARE GOING TO. ENROLL IN
THEM OR NOT WE CAN DETERMINE
WHETHER THEY ARE THE THE
STUDENTS ARE DOING WELL ARE
BEING SUCCESSFUL OR NOT. WITHOUT
COMMITTING A HUNDRED TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS.
THEY WE DO THIS WITHIN EXISTING
PROGRAMS WITHIN EXISTING
STRUCTURES AND WITH FACULTY
INPUT EMPHATICALLY LEAD THE WAY.
THIS IS THE PROBLEM WITH THIS
ONLINE COLLEGE IS THAT DOES THAT
IT WAS.
PUT TOGETHER WITHOUT REAL
FACULTY INPUT WITHOUT REAL
FACULTY.
VOICE.
YEAH I KNOW GOVERNANCE NO
TRANSPARENCY.
THIS IS NOT THE WAY TO PUT
TOGETHER A PROGRAM AND EXPECT TO
GET BUY IN FROM EVERYBODY THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
HI AND MANY SILVA FROM SAITEK
WERE NETWORK OF A.
SCHOOLS SERVING OPPORTUNITY
YOU'VE WHERE COMPETENCY BASED
AND WE OVER THE LAST FOUR YEARS
HAVE BEGUN DOING SOME WORK
ONLINE AS WELL WE'RE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL. I'M AYE AND THAT THE
BIG POINT IS OUR STUDENTS ARE
USING THESE OF THIS TECHNOLOGY
OUR STUDENTS ARE CAPABLE IT'S
THE SAME STUDENTS THAT YOU'RE
LOOKING AT VERY LOW INCOMEKIDS
OF COLOR AND FIRST GENERATION.
I'M WATCHING I KNOW THAT THAT
WE'RE READY TO TAKE THIS.
I AM DON'T FEEL FOR VENTURA
COUNTY I THINK A NICE BUMPY RIDE
UP HERE THIS MORNING TO SEE YOU
ALL AND I'LL I HAVE BEEN AN
INSTRUCTOR FOR TWENTY TWO YEARS.
TAUGHT ONLINE HYBRID AND ON
GROUND AND. IT YOU DON'T BECOME
A GOOD ONLINE INSTRUCTOR
OVERNIGHT SO ONE OF MY CONCERNS
IS WHERE THESE FOLKS COMING FROM
FOR THIS ONE PARTICULAR COLLEGE.
IT TAKES YEARS TO GET UP TO
SPEED THE ONLY AYE HAS HELPED.
ONLINE INSTRUCTORS ALREADY THAT
ARE AT THE Q. LOCAL COLLEGES TO
EVEN BUMP UP THEIR GAME. SO THAT
CONCERNS ME BUT YOU KNOW I HAD
SOME OTHER THINGS TO SAY BUT I
WAS LISTENING TO YOU ALL TALK
ABOUT TRYING TO GET A GOOD
HANDLE ON THINGS. AND IT
OCCURRED TO ME THAT HE SAID
SOMETHING ABOUT.
COMMITTEE COLLEGES HAVE A LOT ON
OUR PLATE WE WANT TO DEDICATE
THIS SO THAT WE CAN JUST FOCUS
ON THE SPECIAL POPULATION KIND
OF THING. AND I SOUND PRETTY
GOOD AND THEN LATER ON. IT WAS
ASKED WAIT A MINUTE SO IF THEIR
ONLINE STORE ONLINE INSTRUCTION
DENISE SOME HELP THE GOING TO
THEIR LOCAL PEOPLE LOOKING FOR
LOCAL JOBS AND SO THERE'S GONNA
BE SOME LABOR PARTNERS. BUT ARE
THERE GOING TO BE SOME NEED FOR
THE CAN LOCAL COMMUNITY COLLEGE
TO GET INVOLVED AND I HEARD
SOMEBODY SAY WELL SURE WHERE
THAT WE EXPECT THEM TO PARTNER
IN AND WORK WITH US ON THIS.
SO I DON'T SEE HOW YOU'RE TAKING
THINGS OFF THE PLATE AND PUT IT
BACK ON.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS REBECCA
MILLER AND S. YA YOU DENIED
HEALTHCARE WORKERS WEST.
WE WRAP AND I THINK I WON'T BE
THAT POPULAR HERE FROM LABOR BUT
I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT.
WERE COMPLETELY DEDICATED TO
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING WE EXPECT
AS PART OF THIS PROPOSAL THAT
THERE WILL BE NO EROSION OF THE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING OR UNION.
JOBS
THAT BEING SAID WE REPRESENT A
HUNDRED THOUSAND.
HEALTH CARE WORKERS ACROSS THE
STATE PEOPLE WHO CANNOT GET TO
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES DURING
THE DAY AND EVEN EVENINGS AND
WEEKENDS SOME OF THE MORE TO
JOBS.
I THINK THIS IS A GAME CHANGER
FOR WORKERS. I HAVE A LOT OF
HOUSEKEEPERS DIETARY WORKERS
REALLY WANT TO GET INTO. ARM.
THE MEDICAL CODING THE HIGHER
PAID ALLIED HEALTH JOBS AND THE
SHORT CREDENTIALS AND THEY
CAN'T.
AND IT MEANS THAT ARE.
IT'S A PROBLEM FOR WORKERS.
HI GOOD MORNING I'M REBECCA
HANSON I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE FBI U. HW JOINT
EMPLOYER EDUCATION FUND WHERE
JOINT LABOR MANAGEMENT
PARTNERSHIP SERVING HUNDRED
THOUSAND WORKERS ACROSS EIGHTEEN
DIFFERENT EMPLOYERS. I'M IN THE
HOSPITAL SECTOR IN CALIFORNIA
AMENABLE TO SAY WE ARE ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF THIS.
THIS IS IT LIKE REBECCA SAID A
GAME CHANGER FOR OUR MEMBERS WHO
ARE REALLY.
LOOKING FOR OPPORTUNITIES TO
ADVANCE THEIR CAREERS AND HEALTH
CARE AND CURRENTLY WE WE OPERATE
AN ECOSYSTEM OF BOTH PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE OPTIONS. AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO DO THAT BUT THIS
WOULD.
REALLY.
HELP TO ADDRESS A AREAS WHERE
WE CURRENTLY HAVE TO SEEK FOR
PROFIT I'M EDUCATOR SUPPORT I'M
IN THE SHORT TERM CREDENTIALS SO
WE REALLY SUPPORT THIS EFFORT
THANK YOU.
WELL MY NAME IS PETER SAID SEE
I'M LIBRARIAN IT ENTER COLLEGE
BUT I'VE ALSO BEEN TEACHING
THEIR ONLINE FOR FOURTEEN YEARS.
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT THIS SEEMS
LIKE THIS IS A SOLUTION IN
SEARCH OF A PROBLEM. WE HAVE
HUNDRED FOURTEEN COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND ALL OF THEM READY
SERVE ONLINE POPULATION. AND
YOU'VE INVESTED EIGHTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS AN ONLINE
EDUCATION INITIATIVE WHAT WOULD
YOU GIVE A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS TO A NEW INITIATIVE THAT
LACKED ANY SORT OF PARTICIPATORY
GOVERNANCE PROCESS.
RECENTLY.
THE FALL PLENARY THE STATEWIDE
ACADEMIC SENATE TOOK FIVE
RESOLUTIONS TO THEM UNANIMOUSLY
BY ACCLAMATION AGAINST THIS
PROPOSAL SO WHY ARE WE GOING
FULL SPEED AHEAD WITH PROPOSAL
LACKS.
CONSTITUENTS INPUT THAT WOULD
COST MORE MONEY THAN WHAT YOU'VE
ALREADY INVESTED ON A SYSTEM
THAT IS PROVEN TO WORK.
HI MY NAME'S WES DAVIS I'M HERE
REPRESENTING THE FACULTY OF THE
VENTURA COUNTY COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT THAT IS VENTURA MORE
PARK AND OXNARD COLLEGE. AND WE
ARE OPPOSED TO ONLINE COLLEGE
THINK.
GOOD AFTERNOON MONEY GRIMACE
SOMEHOW THE FIRST FIVE LA. WE
SUPPORT THE ONLINE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE PROPOSAL BECAUSE WE
THINK IT'LL ADDRESS SOME OF THE
NEEDS FOR OUR WORKFORCE IN BEING
ABLE TO ACCESS.
CLASSES A LOT OF OUR FOLKS WORK
ALL DAY PROVIDING CHILDCARE TO
TO CHILDREN AND HAVE NO ABILITY.
TO BASICALLY TAKE THESE ON CALM
ONLINE COLLEGES CLASSES EXCUSE
ME.
IN ADDITION.
WE THINK PARTICULARLY FOR FOLKS
WHO ARE MOVING FROM UNLICENSED
CARE TO LICENSE CARE. THIS COULD
BE A GAME CHANGER AS WELL AS FOR
FOLKS WHO ARE RUNNING CENTERS
OUT OF THEIR HOMES AND BASICALLY
HAVE NO ACCESS TO.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ON A
PRICE ON BEHALF OF NEXT GEN WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL.
.
OUR SUPPORT THOUGH IS
RECOGNIZING THAT WE DO HAVE A
FEW QUESTIONS THAT NEED ANSWERS
HERE THE NEEDS ME SOME
THOUGHTFULNESS AND DELIBERATION
BUT I DO WANNA RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE ARE. A NUMBER OF STRANDED
WORKERS INSTEAD OF CALIFORNIA
THAT COULD. BENEFIT FROM HAVING
THIS LEVEL OF ACCESS.
AT HOME AND ONLINE WE LOOK
FORWARD TO HAVING THE
DELIBERATION CONVERSATION.
GOV THINKS.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS GINNY
MAE AND I'M WITH THE ACADEMIC
SENATE FOR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
OUR POSITIONS HAVE BEEN STATED
PREVIOUSLY I IN LETTERS
RESOLUTION A PLENARY SESSIONS.
AND WE DO SUPPORT THE IDEA OF
SUCH PROGRAMS COMING THROUGH THE
ONLINE EDUCATION INITIATIVE AND
USING THE RESOURCES. AND
GROUNDWORK THAT WE CURRENTLY
HAVE IN PLACE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN MCCARTY
CHAIRMAN MEDINA MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE WRITINGS KARRUECHE AND
THE DIRECTOR OF STATE GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS FOR CANCIO WHICH IS MORE
FORMALLY KNOWN AS THE COMPUTING
TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION.
WERE HERE TODAY TO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S HUNDREDS AND
FIFTEENTH COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
I'VE CUT MY TESTIMONY I'M
INTERESTED TIME BUT I DID WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT FOR YOU THAT COUNTY
IT'S PRIVILEGE TO PARTNER WITH
THE COLLEGE OF THE CANYONS DOWN
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. AND WE
WELCOME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
EXPAND IT COURSE OFFERINGS
THROUGH THE NEW ONLINE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE.
TO MEET THE GROWING DEMAND FOR
IT TRAINING THIS DEMAND IS
DRIVEN BY THE CHANGING NEEDS. OF
THE DIGITAL WORKPLACE AN
INNOVATION ECONOMY COMES HERE
WORKS WITH EDUCATION OUTLETS TO
SUPPORT THEM AND OFFERING IT
COURSES. THAT MEET THEIR
STUDENTS NEEDS IN SECURING YOUR
JOB OPPORTUNITIES SO WE ACTUALLY
WORK WITH THE COLLEGE OF THE
CANYONS RIGHT OUT A WHOLE HOST
OF IT CERTIFICATIONS. THAT
STUDENTS CAN ROLL IT UP ALLOWS
THEM THE FLEXIBILITY I'M ANNA
AND IT'S VERY VERY AFFORDABLE
THAT THEY CAN ENROLL IN THESE
COURSES. ON A MONTH BY MONTH
BASIS DEPENDING ON WHAT WORKS
BEST FOR THEIR SCHEDULE AND SOME
WERE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. AND AND YOU
KNOW THE SIX LARGEST ECONOMY IN
THE WORLD IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT
CALIFORNIA INVEST IN EDUCATING
AND TRAINING MORE ADULTS MEET
THE INCREASED DEMAND.
FOR THE SKILLED WORKFORCE FOR
THE FUTURE IS THAT WITHOUT WE
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND
ABOUT THE KILL.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMEN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE OUT
NICOLE RICE CALVARY MANUFACTURES
AND TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION AND
WE TO YOU ARE ALSO HERE IN
SUPPORT.
OF THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT PROPOSAL THAT YOU HAVE
BEEN DISCUSSING THIS MORNING. WE
THINK THAT THIS PROPOSAL
ADDRESSES TO CONCERNS THAT I
HAVE HEARD FROM MY MEMBERSHIP
ESPECIALLY MY SMALL AND MEDIUM
SIZE MANUFACTURERS AND THAT IS
ACCESS INFLEXIBILITY. WE WANT
ACCESS STATE WIDE NO MATTER
WHERE THE LOCATION IS OF THE
STUDENTS TO THE TRAINING THAT
THEY NEED TO UPSTATE.
UP SKILLED THERE AT CURRENT
SKILL SET AND ALSO THE
FLEXIBILITY FOR INCUMBENT
EMPLOYEES AND OUR NEW HIRES. TO
BE ABLE TO WORK WITH IN THEIR
LIFE AND WORK SCHEDULES SO THAT
THEY DON'T HAVE TO SACRIFICE
THEIR CAREER IN TIME WITH THEIR
FAMILY IN ORDER TO GET THE
SKILLS AND TRAINING THAT THEY
NEED. AT THESE ARE DESIRABLE
OUTCOMES NOT ONLY FOR
MANUFACTURERS BUT ALSO FOR OUR
EMPLOYEES. AND WHAT WE DO
RECOGNIZE THE DISCUSSION THAT'S
BEEN HAD IN THE LEGISLATURE AND
SOME OF THE CONCERNS ABOUT
IMPLEMENTING THIS PROGRAM. WE DO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THERE ARE IS
WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE TO
BUILD OUT THESE PATHWAYS TO
ACHIEVE OUR DESIRED OUTCOME. BUT
THIS IDEA IS INNOVATIVE AND WE
ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
MOVE FOR WITH DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
THIS INNOVATIVE AYE OPPORTUNITY.
BECAUSE IF THERE'S ONE THING
THAT CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS
UNDERSTAND AND RESPECT ITS
INNOVATION SO FOR THOSE REASONS
THE MTA SUPPORTIVE OF THE
PROPOSAL AND I WE LOOK FORCE
WORKING. NOT ONLY CONTINUOUSLY
WITH COMMUNICABLE EDGES BUT ALSO
WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO ROLL
THIS OUT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE TODAY MY NAME IS YVONNE
SANDOVAL AND I'M WITH THE BUT
THE PROJECT AT SACRAMENTO CITY
COLLEGE I SERVE AS A STUDENT.
ASSISTANT AS WELL AS A PEER
MENTOR AND WE FEEL THAT ONLINE
COLLEGE SHOULD BE AND AND NOT AN
OR ALSO BECAUSE I SHOULD NOT BE
COMPETING WITH MY FELLOW
CLASSMATE WHO LEARNS BETTER M.
ONLINE COLLEGE. AND I AND WE
FEEL THAT THAT BEING SAID THAT
OF FUNDING FUNDING SHOULD BE
ALLOCATED AS SUCH WHERE. IT IS
FAIR AND EVERYTHING IS EQUITABLE
AND I DON'T HAVE TO AGAIN
COMPETE WITH MY FELLOW
CLASSMATES WHO ARE AFTER DEGREE
JUST AS I AM. EXCEPT FOR THEY
LEARN BETTER ONLINE AND I MY.
LEARN BETTER AND I HAVE BEEN
RETAINED BY THE BUT THE PROJECT
AND MY ACADEMIC JOURNEY HAS BEEN
SUCCESSFUL BECAUSE OF THE BUT
THE PROJECT AND ALL OF THE
RESOURCE THAT THE RESOURCES THAT
I'D BEEN FURNISHED THEIR.
AND THAT'S WHERE I STAND THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THEIR ROBUST.
PUBLIC COMMENT BATES THEY YOU
KNOW WERE DELIBERATING WE WE
MAY.
POSTPONE THE NEW FUNDING FORMULA
BECAUSE THAT I KNOW IS THAT THE
CONVERSATION AS WELL. BUT I DID
WANT TO ASK YOU TO IT I THINK.
WHY DAYS THERE ANYBODY THAT
SPECIFICALLY?
BUT TO GREAT LENGTHS TO TO COME
TODAY.
YES.
OKAY.
YEAH JUST. YES I THINK OR I DO
IS FOR THE.
NEW FUNDING FORMULA.
IT'S LITTLE UNORTHODOX BUT.
.
WE'RE NOT GONNA HERE THE ITEM
SPECIFICALLY FROM THE
DEPARTMENTS AND GO OVER IT WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE.
THAT PEOPLE CAME HERE TODAY
TALKING ABOUT THAT. AT THE
JAPANESE TO DO SOME.
WE'RE JUST GONNA HEAR PUBLIC
COMMENTS.
ON THE NEW FUNDING FORMULA.
GOOD MORNING AND.
I'M HERE WITH TWENTY MY NAME IS
WHATEVER DATA AND I AM THAT CO
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF SIN THANK
YOU AT CHAIRMAN MCCARTY IN
MEDINA AFTER HAVING THIS YEAR.
AM BEFORE I CONTINUE WE DID WANT
TO SAY A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING AND LIKE
TO REITERATE HOW IMPORTANT IT IS
FOR BY AND THEN FOR OTHER
PROGRAMS LIKE WHEN THEME MOSHE.
TO NOT BE A PART OF THE LOCAL
CONTROL FORMULA AS AREA AS AN
ORGANIZATION. WE COULD DO MORE
FOR THE STUDENTS AND THE FACULTY
IF WE KEEP THE FUNDING AS IT IS
CURRENTLY MANAGED.
RATHER THAN IF IT WOULD BE
DISTRIBUTED AT THE SITES AND I
THINK WE'VE HAD THIS
CONVERSATION.
TODAY WERE ACTUALLY HERE AFTER
HEARING A HUNDRED MILLION TWENTY
MILLION EIGHTY SEVEN MILLION
WE'RE JUST HERE TO ASK FOR SIX
MILLION.
SO WE ARE ACTUALLY ASKING FOR
INCREASED BY NEED TO PROVIDE
MORE SERVICES TO STUDENTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
AND MORE ARE FINALIZING UP SAW
AND WE'LL BE SUBMITTING IT FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING ON MY
DIRTY WERE LEFT FROM THE E. OPS
ASSOCIATION ON I ALMOST HAD A
HEART ATTACK WHEN YOU SAID YOU
WERE GOING TO POSTPONE THE.
DISCUSSION BECAUSE THERE'S ABOUT
THIRTY TO FORTY E. OPS WHAT IS
THAT CAME DOWN TO THIS HEARING.
ARM WORK CONCERNED ABOUT THE
LANGUAGE FROM THE GOVERNOR THAT
THAT TALKS ABOUT CONSOLIDATION
OF CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS UTOPIA
SERVES FIRST GENERATION COLLEGE
STUDENTS AS ME DOING SO FOR
ALMOST FIFTY YEARS. ASA WE DO
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT TO MAKE
SURE THAT YOUR PS IS NOT
CONVINCING TOP PROGRAM. BECAUSE
OF IT IS WE SEE END OF THE
ELIMINATION OF YOUR PS LAST YEAR
ALONG WITH HER ALMOST A HUNDRED
THOUSAND STUDENTS SO HUNDRED
THOUSAND THINGS COULD BE LEFT
WITHOUT THAT KEY SUPPORT. THAT
CAN TAKE HIM TO GRADUATION AND
SUCCESS THANK YOU.
MORNING JANE ALLSOP CODE CHO
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
POINTED PROJECT ON THANK YOU
CHAIRS MCCARTY AND MEDINA AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS FOR GIVING US
THIS EXTRA LITTLE MOMENT.
YOU WILL HEAR TESTIMONIES.
ON BEHALF OF THE PLAINTIFF
PROJECT AND FOR MANY STUDENTS.
AND ASKING THAT YOU CONTINUE TO
FUND THE POINTED PROJECT AS IT
HAS BEEN FUNDED.
I'M HAVING A STATEWIDE PROGRAM
INFRASTRUCTURE ENSURES
ACCOUNTABILITY AND UNIFORMITY
AND EQUITY IN EXPECTATIONS OF
STUDENTS AND PRACTICES OF
TEACHERS AND COUNSELORS.
WE WILL BE SUBMITTING A
PROPOSAL TO EXPAND SERVICES
PARTICULARLY THROUGH
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT FOR
FACT.
AND FOR.
DO DUAL ENROLLMENT DEVELOPMENT
THAT WE SEE AS PARTNERING.
SAYS COLLEGE CAN'T.
AND OUR HIGH SCHOOLS AND
A MIDDLE SCHOOL
PROGRAM.
SO MUCH FOR ALLOWING US.
IF YOU.
CALLUM. DISTRICT COALITION
CALIFORNIA ME COLLEGES THE
LARGEST HARD TO.
VERY COMPLEX FUNDING MODEL.
WE BELIEVE WE NEED A NEW
FUNDING MODEL. WE BELIEVE WE
NEED MORE TIME TO DO IT RIGHT
YOU'VE HEARD FROM POINT DAY ALL
THE APPLICATIONS.
CHAPTER TALK ABOUT ACCESS WE
HAVE FUN FUNDED A BASIN ACCESS
AND THEN CATEGORICAL HOW MUCH WE
WANT TO FIND AN ACCESS WHAT IS
THAT. WHAT WE PROJECT IN ACCESS
DO YOU WANT TO TARGET THOSE TWO
AND A HALF MILLION STUDENTS IF
SO HOW DO YOU PUT A FUNNY MAN
MODEL TOGETHER?
WHAT CATEGORICAL DO GET
CONSOLIDATED IS APPOINT DANIO PS
MAYBE NOT? DOES TAKE A LOT OF
DECISIONS WE THINK WE NEED ABOUT
TWO YEARS TO DO THAT IN A THREE
YEAR APPLICATION TO DO IT WITH A
HOLD HARMLESS IN THE FIRST YEAR.
THANKS.
HELLO HONORABLE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS BECAUSE IF YOU MAKE AND
TURNED I I ALSO WORK FOR THE BUT
THE PROJECT I'VE BEEN BLESSED
WORK FOR THE POINT THAT. FOR THE
LAST SIXTEEN AND A HALF YEARS
BUT I STARTED AS A VOLUNTEER
WITH A COMMA WITH THE
ORGANIZATION. TWENTY FIVE YEARS
AGO.
SO IT'S THE PROGRAM HAS A
MISSION THAT I TRULY BELIEVE IN
I ALSO REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
CENTER THE MCCARTY COMMITTEE HAS
AN APPOINTMENT MEMBER. OF THE
FIFTY SEVENTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
AND IN THAT ROLE I'VE SEEN THE
NEEDS OF OUR STUDENTS IN A IN A
PARTICULAR GEOGRAPHIC AREA BUT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND I THINK I ALWAYS
THINK TO MYSELF Y. YOU KNOW
START A BRAND NEW PROGRAM WHEN
YOU HAVE A PROGRAM THAT HAS A
THIRTY FIVE YEAR. PAST HISTORY
AND CALIFORNIA THAT SHOWS DATA
THAT IF THAT SAID IT'S EFFECTIVE
SO I ASK YOU TO REINVEST THEM
POINT BAY AND TO US SUPPORT US
WITH AN AUGMENTATION THAT CAN
ALLOW US THE OPPORTUNITY. TO
SERVE DOUBLE THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA THAT
REALLY NEED A FIRST JAN
UNDERSERVED STUDENTS THINK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S BETH WILLIAMS I'M
AN ENGLISH FACULTY COORDINATOR
FOR THE POINT TASTE IT OFFICE.
I AM I'VE BEEN A TEACHER AN
ADVISER FOR UNDERPRIVILEGED
COLLEGE STUDENTS FOR THE LAST
TWELVE YEARS. AND IN THE LAST
THREE YEARS I'VE GOTTEN TO SEE
FIRSTHAND HOW POSITIVELY IMPACT
WILL THE POINT A PROJECT IS FOR
BOTH THE STUDENTS AND AS AN
EDUCATOR FOR TEACHERS.
AND I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO
THE POINT A PROJECT SO THAT IT
MAY BE ABLE TO CONTINUE TO GROW
AND POSITIVELY AFFECT THE LIVES
OF MORE UNDERREPRESENTED LOW
INCOME FIRST GENERATION
STUDENTS.
AS APPOINT THE INSTRUCTOR EL
CAMINO COLLEGE I RECEIVE SOME OF
THE HIGHEST QUALITY TEACHER
TRAINING AND SUPPORT THAT I'VE
EVER RECEIVED I'M IN THE FIELD
EDUCATION. AND TRAINING ON HOW
TO CREATE CULTURALLY RELEVANT
INCLUSIVE CURRICULUM HOW TO USE
AN ENRICHMENT MODEL RATHER THAN
DEFICIT MODEL HOW TO PROVIDE
MEANINGFUL FEEDBACK TO STUDENTS
AND HOW TO MAKE STUDENTS MORE
LIKELY TO TRANSFER BANQUET BRING
THEIR FAMILIES INTO THE PROCESS.
AND AND THIS THIS AYE TRAINING
ACTUALLY AS AFFECTED NOT ONLY
HOWEVER APPROACH TWENTY STUDENTS
BUT ALSO HAS COMPLETELY IMPACTED
THE WAY I APPROACH ALL OF MY
STUDENTS.
AND IT IS MAYBE A MORE EFFECTIVE
INSTRUCTOR AND ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR POINT A WOULD MEAN
MORE EDUCATORS COULD BE EXPOSED
TO AND TRAINED IN THE
PEDAGOGICAL PHILOSOPHIES AND
PRACTICES CHAMPIONED BY POINT
DAY.
AND WE WOULD BE ABLE TO HAVE
MORE WIDE REACHING A FAX AS
THOSE TEACHERS WOULD GO ON TO
POSITIVELY IMPACT THOUSANDS OF
STUDENTS.
THROUGH THAT PEDAGOGY THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S JOSH
ROBERTS I'M AN ENGLISH FACULTY
MEMBER AT SACRAMENTO CITY
COLLEGE I'M OPPOSED TO THE
PROVISION IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET IT BASED TWENTY FIVE
PERCENT OF A COLLEGES FUNDING ON
SUCCESS BASED METRICS.
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNICATIVE
SYSTEM HAS ACTUALLY SEEN
SIGNIFICANT CHANGE AND LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS WILL CONTINUE TO
SEE SIGNIFICANT CHANGES COLLEGES
SEEK TO.
COMPLY WITH A. B. SEVEN OH FIVE
AND ALSO TO IMPLEMENT THE
CALIFORNIA GOT PATHWAYS
FRAMEWORK.
AND WE ARE WELL THOSE ARE
ABSOLUTELY WELCOME CHANGES WERE
NOT ENTIRELY SURE ABOUT WHAT THE
EFFECTS ARE GONNA BE
PARTICULARLY FOR A MOST DIS
ADVANTAGED.
STUDENTS SUCCESS BASED FUNDING
IS LIKELY GOING A PREFERENCE SO
STUDENTS THAT COME TO US MOST
PREPARED AND MOST LIKELY TO
SUCCEED. AND ACTUALLY
DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS WHO ARE
NOT.
MY CONCERN ULTIMATELY IS FOR
ACCESS
I AND THAT.
ANY KIND OF MODEL THAT DOES
PREFERENCE ONE SUBSTANCE OVER
ANOTHER AYE IS NOT GOING TO BE
APPLICABLE. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS BECAUSE
THEY LOVE YEAH I MEAN TWENTY SIX
YEAR OLD SINGLE MOTHER KNOW
FIRST GENERATION COLLEGE
STUDENT.
THIS IS MY SECOND YEAR ATTENDING
SAN JOAQUIN DELTA COLLEGE AND I
AM PURSUING A ENTRANCE FOR US AS
A COLLEGE MAJOR. BUT PLAN TO
ATTEND LAW SCHOOL ONCE I HAVE
RECEIVED MY BACHELORS I
CURRENTLY HAVE IT BUT MCMILLIAN
AT THREE POINT SEVEN. GPA
VOLUNTEER SIX TO EIGHT HOURS A
WEEK AS A MEDIATOR AT THE
COURTHOUSE.
WHILE ALL WHILE THEM COMPLETING
SIXTEEN UNIONS UNIT SAYS BRUCE
MASTER DID TO MY CURRENT
SITUATION AND IS VERY DIFFICULT
FOR ME TO FIND A FULL TIME JOB
TO FINANCE MY STUDIES. FOR THAT
REASON I JOINED THAT YUP YES
CARE AND PUBLIC TO OUR PROGRAM.
THE.
THANK YOU FOR NOT AUDIO PS IN
CARE PROGRAM TO THE BLOCK GRANT
FUNDING IN ASSURING THAT IT IT
IS THAT WAY BECAUSE IT WILL
AFFECT THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS.
THAT ARE.
IN THE THING IN THE SUMMER
SITUATION AS I AM.
THESE PROGRAMS ARE HELPING US
OBTAIN A CAREER WERE.
WHERE WE CAN BECOME POSITIVE
CONTRIBUTE MEMBERS OF SOCIETY
ONCE AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME?
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS LISA
GOMEZ VAZQUEZ SAME PART OF THE
LEADERSHIP TEAM AT THE POINT
OFFICE IN BERKELEY WHERE I HAVE
THE HONOR OF TRAINING AND
MENTORING BUT THE COUNSELORS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
PRIOR TO THIS I WORK CLOSELY
WITH THE BUT THE PROJECT A THREE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CAMPUSES AS A
COUNSELOR AND CLASSMEN
STRUCTURE.
I TOO AM A PRODUCT OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM. I WAS
RAISED BY A SINGLE PARENT IT
COMMUNITY COLLEGE COUNSELOR WHO
HAPPEN TO BE HIRED TO IMPLEMENT
POINT IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
THERE IN THE EIGHTIES. THIS
MEANS I HAVE BEEN ACTIVELY
INVOLVED THROUGHOUT MY LIFETIME
AND PERSONALLY WITNESSED
GENERATIONS OF STUDENT SUCCESS
EVOLVING OUT OF WHAT THE
CLASSROOMS.
OUR STUDENTS ARE OF THE UNDER
REPRESENTED POPULATIONS YOU
SPEAK OF ON THEIR CAMPUSES THEIR
STUDENTS OF COLOR OFTEN FIRST
GENERATION AND OR NONTRADITIONAL
STUDENTS.
BUT THE STUDENTS ARE GUIDED.
THEIR PERSONAL DISCOVERY HOW TO
BREAK DOWN BARRIERS HOW TO SEEK
OUT TOOLS AND RESOURCES FOR
ACADEMIC SUCCESS. REDUCTION
PLANS AND STRIVE TO BUILD
EMOTIONAL MENTAL READINESS FOR
THE JOURNEY AHEAD. BUT THESE
THIS TRANSFER AT DOUBLE THE RATE
OF THEIR NON POINT APPEARS. BUT
THESE US NOW HOLD GRADUATE
DEGREES THEY ARE INSTRUCTORS IN
GRADUATE PROGRAMS THEIR ELECTED
OFFICIALS THEY ARE YOUR
CHILDREN'S ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
TEACHERS. ALL AWARE OF THE
IMPORTANCE OF CULTURALLY
RELEVANT INSTRUCTION.
THERE WERE THAT REPRESENTATION
MATTERS AND THEY SHOW UP WITH
THESE DOES RETURN TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES AS LEADERS. THEIR
YOUR INTERNS YOUR NEIGHBORS AND
YOUR LOCAL BUSINESS OWNERS
EQUALLY IMPORTANT THERE NOW
MENTORING AND YOU GENERATION OF
WHAT THE STUDENTS BECAUSE WE
LEFT AS WE CLIMB KNOWING GETS
THE TOP ALONE.
WHEN THEY IS A PREMIER PERKED UP
NEAR PROGRAM THAT HAS PAVE THE
WAY FOR WHAT WE KNOW TODAY IS
THERE ANY COMMUNITIES AND
STUDENT CENTERED LEARNING.
JUST YESTERDAY JANET APOLLO
TUNNEL COMMENTED THAT THE STATE
MUST DO ITS PART TO WHITEN
ACCESS FOR CALIFORNIANS
REINVESTING. IN THE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM AND CALLED FOR GUARANTEED
YOU SEE ADMISSION OF.
QUALIFIED COMMUNITY COLLEGE CAN
OF STUDENTS.
SHE ALSO COMMITTED COMMENTED.
A ARE COMMITTED TO NOT DISEASE
DIMINISHING OUR STUDENTS ABILITY
TO SUCCEED BY FORCING A ONE SIZE
FITS ALL EDUCATIONAL MODEL THIS
OF COURSE REQUIRES ACADEMIC
PREPARATION. WHAT THE WORKS THE
TRUTH OF THE MATTER IS WITH ITS
SUCCESS RATE OF AT LEAST DOUBLE
THE AVERAGE AND MORE THAN THIRTY
FIVE YEARS OF PROVEN SUCCESS?
ARE COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA SIMPLY CANNOT AFFORD
TO GO WITHOUT BONTA THINK THANK
YOU FOR SUPPORTING OUR MISSION
AND PURPOSE.
GOOD MORNING NICOLAS CHVEZ ON
BEHALF OF LONG BEACH COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT IS ON A MAKE
THREE POINTS.
I WON WE SUPPORT THE NEW FUNDING
FORMULA.
TO WE WANT.
LAURIE ASKING FOR PERMANENT.
THOSE STABILIZATION AND COLA.
AND THEN THREE.
WE WILL ASK FOR AN INCREASE BUT.
FLEXIBILITY SO THAT WE CAN HAVE
OUR AT FTA A SUMMER.
OUR SUMMER CLASSES BE COUNTED
NEITHER THE CURRENT OR THE
BUDGET YEAR FOR F. T. YES THANK
YOU.
HELLO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED CREEL YOUR TIME
MONEY WAS ON A DAVIS SOME
ACTUALLY A CURRENT.
MODESTO JUNIOR COLLEGE STUDENT
ALSO ON THE E. OPS PROGRAM AND
TO ME WAS BEEN A MAJOR BLESSING
BEFORE I WORKED THREE JOBS. NO
COMPETITIVE WAGES MOST THEM WERE
VERY STRENUOUS AND WITH.
BEING IN THE ILL WITH PS
PROGRAM IT'S ALSO ALLOWED ME TO
ACTUALLY NOT WORK SO MUCH
CONCENTRATE MORE ON MY STUDIES
AND NOW DO THAT I'VE ALREADY
EARNED TWO CERTIFICATE TO
SCHOOLS RECOGNITION AND I'M
WORKING ON MY A. S. DEGREE.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S MAKAYLA GREEN FROM
MODESTO JUNIOR COLLEGE I AM IN
THE O. P. AS PART ON PROGRAM AT
MY COLLEGE.
BE WITHOUT MADE THE DECISION TO
GO TO COLLEGE MY BIGGEST CONCERN
WAS FINANCES BEEN A SINGLE
MOTHER AND HAVING TO WORK FOR
THE LAST TWO YEARS SPENDING LESS
AND LESS TIME WITH MY CHILD. NOW
THAT I'M A FULL STUDENT AND THAT
UPS'S HELP ME WITH THE BRIDGE
PROGRAM AND EVERYTHING ELSE HE
HAS ASSISTED ME WHERE. I'M ABLE
TO. FOCUS ON MY SCHOOL AND BE A
MOTHER TO MUCH I WITHOUT SENDING
HIM OFF AND TODAY CARE ALL THE
TIME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING.
OBJECT FROM ON WITH THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY
NOT WITH YOUR PS BUT I'M HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE STUDENT FOCUSED
FUNDING FORMULA BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE IT WILL HELP. THE
STUDENTS THAT UPS SERVES UP WE
STILL AT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ARE FACING COMPLETION RATES THAT
WE LOOK AT OVER SIX YEARS THREE
TIMES THE PROGRAM DURATIONS AND
WHERE MOST STUDENTS WILL LEAVE
WITHOUT HAVING OBTAINED A
DEGREE.
BUT TRANSFERRED REQUIREMENT
COMPLETION OR CERTIFICATE SO WE
BELIEVE THAT IS THE FUNDING
FORMULA FOR OUR COLLEGES SHOULD
REFLECT ALL OF THE PRIORITIES
FOR OUR STATE AND FOR STUDENTS
CERTAINLY ACCESS BUT ALSO
IMPROVING EQUITY. CLOSING THOSE
GAPS AND IMPROVING THE SUCCESS
AND COMPLETION RATES FOR ALL OF
OUR STUDENTS THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MANY RODRIGUEZ FROM
THE EDUCATION TRUST WEST HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE NEW FUNDING
FORMULA WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
PROPOSAL CARRIES. MAJOR
POTENTIAL TO ADVANCE EQUITY IN
THE STATE BY PRIORITIZING SNEAK
ASSESS STUDENT SUCCESS AND
FOCUSING IN ON LOW INCOME
STUDENTS. WE BELIEVE THAT THERE
GENERAL CONSENSUS CONSENSUS THAT
WE NEED TO MOVE AWAY FROM
ENROLLMENT FUNDING DUE TO
DECLINING STE A. BUTTON ROOM IT
STATEWIDE WE WE THAT NEW FUNDING
FORMULA WILL PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR LOW INCOME STUDENTS
IT CAN ALIGN INCENTIVIZE.
CURRENT REFORM EFFORTS BY
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
AND COULD POTENTIALLY BRING
ABOUT INSTITUTIONAL CHANGE OF
FOR THE COURTROOM BEHAVIOR FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO PRIORITIZE
STUDENT SUCCESS.
A WE STAND READY TO HELP OUT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THIS. PROPOSAL IS
BEST HERE TO SUPPORT LOW INCOME
STUDENTS AND STUDENTS OF COLOR.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING WITHOUT EVER WITH
ME COLLEGE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
AIBILEEN BELIEVES IT'S THE RIGHT
TIME FOR THOUGHTFUL EVALUATION
OF A NEW COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FUNDING FORMULA. WE BELIEVE THAT
PROPERLY STRUCTURED AND I
ADEQUATELY FUNDED AYE ANY
FUNDING FORMAT CAN PROVIDE THE
POTENTIAL TO LEAD TO A MORE
ACCOUNTABLE STABLE AND
SUCCESSFUL SYSTEM THERE ARE A
FEW CONCEPTS THAT.
WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO LOOK AT ONE
IS THAT YOU MAINTAIN OUR
COMMITMENT TO AYE CALIFORNIA'S
COMMITMENT TO ACCESSIBLE QUALITY
EDUCATION. THE OTHER IS THAT
IT'S THOUGHTFUL IN PHASE DAN ON
THAT THERE'S TIME FOR ANALYSIS
AND EVALUATION OF THE METRICS
THERE UTILIZED IN ANY FUTURE
FORMULA. AND THEN LASTLY THAT.
YOU ALSO HAVE USED A BETTER
DEFINITION FOR ECONOMICALLY
DISADVANTAGED WE ENCOURAGE THE
PERKINS DEFINITION WHICH ARE
BETTER CAPTURES THE STUDENTS
THAT ARE SERVED BY OUR COLLEGES.
ALMOND DOESN'T JUST PROVIDE TWO
MORE NARROW DEFINITIONS OF THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO THE WORK HAD.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS THE
NEED OF SCOTT AND THE DIRECTOR
OF STUDENT SUPPORT SERVICES OF
SAN JOAQUIN DELTA COLLEGE. I'M
ALSO THAT UPS ASSOCIATION VICE
PRESIDENT I HAVE SOME STUDENTS
WITH ME THEY WANT YOU TO SEE
THEM BUT THEY ARE AFRAID TO TALK
TO YOU. ARE SO OUR FIRST THAT
GIVE ME IS THAT WE WANT YOU TO
ENSURE THAT HE APPEARS CARE
REMAIN SEPARATE AND DISTINCT
FROM ANY BLOCK GRANT FUNDING
PROPOSALS THE STUDENTS WILL TELL
YOU THE REASONS WHY. I E. OPS
HAS DISTRIBUTED A LETTER SEEKING
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO COVER
THE EXPANSION OF QUE FEES NOW
CALLED NEXT STOP TO SERVE FOSTER
YOU. UPS'S CENTRAL TO THIS
EFFORT BECAUSE QUE FEES IS
HOUSED IN YOUR PIASTS
THE PROGRAM BEGAN AT TWENTY
FOURTEEN FOLLOWING THE PASSAGE
OF SENATE BILL TEN TWENTY THREE.
AS A PILOT AND TEN DISTRICTS
THE BUDGET IN TWENTY FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN GAVE US FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS AND I'M GOING FUNDS.
OUR BUT LAST YEAR YOU APPROVED
SENATE BILL TWELVE TO DOUBLE THE
PROGRAM.
EXPANDING THE THAT FROM TWENTY
SIX.
AND TEN DISTRICT UP TO TWENTY
DISTRICTS WERE NOT SURE HOW MANY
HIGH CAMPUSES THAT IS YEAH. ARE
BUT THERE'S NO NEW BUDGET MONEY
OUT WE BELIEVE THE EXPANSION
LEAVES THE PROGRAM DEPLETED IF
WE'RE TO MAKE DIFFERENCE FOR
THIS POPULATION. WE'RE WORKING
WITH THE COMMITTEE STAFF AND
OTHERS TO HELP EXPLAIN THIS
REQUEST AND ARE AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE.
BUT YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MARSHA COMMANDO. I
AM A SIXTY YEAR OLD GRANDMOTHER
MOTHER GRANDMOTHER. AND A
CURRENT STUDENT AT DELTA COLLEGE
I HAVE BEEN THERE SINCE TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN AND HAS BEEN A
STRUGGLE FOR ME. MY FIRST YEAR I
DIDN'T HAVE THE FUNDS SO I WORK
PART TIME AT SAFEWAY WHICH
CAUSED ME TO NOT.
BE ABLE TO FOCUSED ON STUDYING.
THEN I APPLY PRETTY OPS MISTER
NEEDHAM'S PAM HAVE BEEN VERY
INSTRUMENTAL IN THIS GROUP WHICH
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE TO WORK
NOT HAVE TO HAVE TO WORK. BUT TO
ABLE TO FOCUS MORE ON MY STUDIES
WHICH I HAVE BEEN ON THE DEAN'S
LIST. I AM NOW THE CURRENT
PRESIDENT OF THE STUDENT BODY.
NO SOME LEARNING TIME MANAGEMENT
AND I WOULD LIKE TO WHEN I
OBTAIN MY A. ENTRANCE PRETTY YOU
LP WHICH I WILL DO. TO BE ABLE
TO GO BACK AND HELP MY COMMUNITY
BUT ALSO BE AN ASSET.
TO SAN JOAQUIN DELTA COLLEGE WHO
HAS HELPED ME THAT'S BAR WITH
MARK CAREER AND NOT BUYING THAT
HAVING.
BECAUSE I WANT TO WORK IN THE
FIRST PLACE JUST TO BUY MY BOOKS
HAVING MET NOT TO BE A WAIT ARMY
HAS BEEN BETTER WHERE'S. THE
BOOKS THAT THEY GIVE ME I DON'T
MAKE BACK FOR THE NEXT TO THE
SAUCER LET'S KEEP PLANET FORWARD
SO THAT WE CAN ALL. YOU KNOW
BUILT CALIFORNIA BACK I THINK
YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS STOCKTON LEHMAN A BEHALF
OF THE FACULTY ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
LET ME FIRST A LINE.
FAQ IN SUPPORT.
OF KEEPING YOU AWAKE UPS AT OUT
OUTSIDE A CATEGORICAL AS WELL AS
FOR THE FIVE MILLION.
TO.
FIND SENATE BILL TWELVE.
RELATIVE TO THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL WE HAVE SUBMITTED OUR A
LETTER.
THAT OUTLINE OUR OBJECTION TO
THE TWENTY FIVE PERCENT PER
PERFORMANCE SPACE FUNDING AND WE
HAVE CREATED AN ALTERNATE IDEA
FOR YOU TO CONFERENCE CENTER. AT
LEAST FIFTY PERCENT BASED ON
ENROLLMENT AT LEAST HALF OF THE
REMAINDER ON A BROADER
DEFINITION OF POVERTY THAT WOULD
BE A BLEND OF FORMULA A
PROMISING PELL GRANT.
REGIONAL UNEMPLOYMENT PLUS
FOSTER YOUTH PLUS MILITARY AND
MILITARY VETERANS.
PLUS PARTICIPATION IN ETHIOPIA
S. D. S. PS CAL WORKS IN OTHER
SKATE Y. PROGRAMS.
THE FINAL PORTION WE WOULD.
SWAP OUT THE GOVERNOR'S IDEA
FOR THOSE METRICS THAT WE KNOW
LEAD TO STUDENT SUCCESS WHICH
WOULD BE UP LAND. ON A
ACHIEVEMENT OF SEVENTY FIVE
TWENTY FIVE FULL TO PART TIME
FACULTY. ACHIEVEMENT OF THE
DISTRICT'S LOCALLY BARGAIN
DEFINITION OF PART TIME PARITY.
AND ACHIEVEMENT OF A LOCALLY
BARGAIN DEFINITION OF A
COUNSELOR TO STUDENT RATIO I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO CONCLUDE
THERE IS ROUGHLY NINE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN CHANGE
BETWEEN. ONGOING AND ONE TIME
FUNDS IN THE BUDGET WITH ZERO
DEDICATED TO ADVANCING THE FULL
TO PART TIME FACULTY RATIO WHICH
TODAY'S DANCE A FIFTY SIX
PERCENT. AND ZERO DEDICATED TO
PART TIME FACULTY WE THINK THAT
THAT NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS WHO LISA PERRETTE.
AND I IT'S AND.
MODESTO JUNIOR COLLEGE.
AND I AM FROM I'M AN E. OPS
STUDENT WHICH TAUGHT ME.
DISCIPLINE DEDICATION AND
DESIRE.
SO IF THE THREE D. THAT STAND
FOR.
GONNA.
THE DISCIPLINE AND MY EDUCATION
AND I WANNA DEDICATE MYSELF AND
I'M DESIRE TO GET US A SOCIOLOGY
DEGREE.
AND.
IF IT WASN'T FOR E. OPS I WOULD
NOT HAVE BOOKS TO FURTHER MY
EDUCATION AND I'M JUST THANKFUL
FOR ALL OF YOU GUYS AND I ASK
YOU TO VOTE NO ON BLOCK TWENTY.
GOOD MORNING WE WE WENT WITH THE
THREE D. IS BECAUSE ALL MY HIGH
SCHOOL GRADES.
I WANT TO SAY.
I I'M A MY NAME'S ACTED WALKED
UP FROM THE DUSTER JUNIOR
COLLEGE.
AND I'VE BEEN THE SYSTEM
DIRECTOR FOR MANY MANY YEARS.
THIS MY SWEATSUIT TWENTY
SEVENTH YEAR OF BEING A SERVANT
NOTHING SIR BECAUSE I'M THERE TO
SERVE STUDENTS.
I DOUBT Y. WORK WITH A RUNWAY
YOUTH SEXIST PUT IT YOUTH. KIDS
AT THE SHELTER A HISPANIC GANGS
THAT'S BUT SPECIFICALLY NOTHING
AGAIN MEMBERS LATTE THERE'S NO
OTHER PROGRAM MY TWELVE TWENTY
SEVEN YEARS OF SERVICE. THAT
DOES
BUT THAT THE SERVICE THAT YOU'RE
PASSED AS WE CHANGE LIVES.
AND SO WE HAVE A HISTORY OF
CHANGING LIVES AND EMPOWERING
AND I USE THE TWENTY TWELVE TO
BUY FOR EXAMPLE.
THE NUMBER TO TWENTY ABOUT THE
TWO BY FOUR THEORY.
THE GUY SIX FIVE IN YOUR FIVE
TWO ROBERT TWO BY FOUR.
EVEN IF THE PLAYING FIELD AND
EDUCATION FOR STUDENTS IS THAT
TWO BY FOUR.
SO PLEASE DO NOT BLOCK GRANT
FUNDING FOR YOUR PS WERE POSTED
THAT UPS HAS BEEN WORKING DON'T
PICKS UP IN THE US NOW BROKE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THERE'S YOU WHERE HE SAID MY
NAME AS WELL AS SOME.
I'M FROM ADDRESS A JUNIOR
COLLEGE US APART YOUR* TO
BRIDGE PROGRAM AND I'M NOT GONNA
LIE UPS IS A VERY VERY GOOD
BLESSING FOR US FINANCIALLY GAS
MONEY I CAN EVEN HELP MY MOM
SOMETIMES A HITMAN TO PAY THE
BILLS AND IT REALLY BRINGS ME
JOY AND ONE'S. A HEART WHEN SHE
SMILES AT ME AND US ALL THAT.
AND.
I POSE THIS.
.
COLLEAGUES
ONLINE COLLEGE STAFF ARE NOT
VERY TEDIOUS.
AND THAT'S PRETTY MUCH IT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO I'M MY NAME IS NATALIA
ERROR I DO COME FROM THAT AYE
SIR JUNIOR COLLEGE I'M CURRENTLY
MAJORING MEN COME OUT JUST AS.
.
I'D I AM A PART OF THE BRIDGE
PROGRAM LIKE.
MY MY COLLEAGUE ULTRAVIOLET
JUST HAD.
NOT I'M A PART OF THE E. OPS
PROGRAM AS WELL WHICH CONTAIN
COMES FROM THAT BRIDGE PROGRAM
ARE SHOULD RAISE THE. THAT'S
WHERE WE GET OUR FINDINGS FROM
AND NOT ONLY ARE WE CONSIDERED.
A PROGRAM BUT A FAMILIES THAT
WOULD NOT BE IN THAT IT FLAKE WE
HELPED EACH OTHER OUT AND I'M
SURE YOU KNOW I'VE HEARD YOU
GUYS TALK ABOUT PROGRAM. AND
WHERE LIVING PROOF OF A PROGRAM
LIKE WE COME TOGETHER OF THE
FAMILY EVERY SINGLE DAY.
AND IT'S LIKE A FAMILY YOU KNOW
HAVING OF. A FAMILY OUTSIDE OF.
HOME AND I LOOK FORWARD TO IT
EVERY DAY IT LIKE A LIFE
CHANGING BEING. IT'S CRAZY BUT I
LEFT SCHOOL I LOVE IT AND.
I OPPOSE YOU KNOW THAT IF TO
THAT FUNDING TO.
ELP HAVE BECAUSE ILL PAY AS. FOR
ME HEART BREAKING IN.
IF CONTINUE TO BREAK BARRIERS I
AM VERY STERNER GENERATION AND
MY FAMILY AND I WANNA CONTINUE.
DOING THAT FOR MY FAMILY FAMILY
AND THE LITTLE KIDS IN MY FAMILY
SO THEY CAN LOOK UP TO ME AND BE
LIKE YEAH I WANNA BE LIKE NOT BY
YEAH. OR HEY WANNA BE YOU KNOW
THOUGH IN THE LAKER WHO LOOK UP
TO ME. BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE A
LOT OF THOSE IN MY FAMILY AND
WITHOUT YOUR PF I DON'T KNOW
WHAT I DO. THINK YOU'VE COME
ACROSS.
THANK YOU.
HI I'M MY NAME IS MONIQUE ME
CHERYL AND THE FIRST GENERATION
COLLEGE STUDENT AND I'M FROM AND
AND A SEAT.
MODESTO JUNIOR COLLEGE AND I
MEAN THAT YOUR PS PROGRAM AND
ALSO DISABILITIES.
AND I OPPOSE THE BLOCK GRANT
FUNDING BECAUSE WITHOUT EUROPEAN
ES I WOULD YOU BE IN COLLEGE
BECAUSE I AM A LONG INCOME
FAMILY.
AND I'M.
I WOULDN'T KNOW WHAT TO DO
WITHOUT IT LIKE MY LIKE. NOT
HOLLY HAD SAID.
IT'S LIKE A FAMILY I FEEL AT
HOME THAT I CAN FEEL I CAN TRUST
EVERYBODY THERE JUST ALMIGHTY
AIDS I CAN TRUST.
MY COORDINATOR I CAN TRUST
ANYBODY THERE AND WITH MY WITH
ISSUES AND LIKE.
I DON'T HAVE TO FEEL LIKE.
SCHOOL I FEEL LIKE I'M JUST.
I'M WHAT I'M LEARNING AND I FEEL
LIKE I'M HAVING FUN AND I DON'T.
WANT THIS TO GO AWAY AND I WANT
THIS TO BE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR.
A LOT OF OTHER PEOPLE AS WELL
THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS WATER GARCIA
I'M A PROUD STUDENT AT NJC I'M
INVOLVED IN THE UPS PROGRAM.
AND.
ME A GIVES ME.
GREAT PLEASURE TO SAY THAT IS
VERY EFFECTIVE IN A FORM OF.
BEING.
CHANCE IT'S GIVEN ME A SECOND
CHANCE. AND I'M GONNA BE A VOICE
FOR IT SO IT COULD BE HEARD
THAT.
.
IT WERE WITH YOU WILL REALLY
WORKS AND EFFECTIVE TO PEOPLE
THAT.
COME FROM A DOUBLE A DUB I
DIVERSE BACKGROUNDS AND.
IT WORKS.
BUT I GOT TO SEE.
GOOD MORNING OF MY NAME IS
BRENDA JONES AND I AM A
SPECIALIST.
IN THE EUROPEAN AS PROGRAM AT
MODESTO JUNIOR COLLEGE.
I'M WE LIKE TO CONSIDER
OURSELVES EXPERTS IN HOW WE
SERVE OUR AMAZING STUDENTS IT'S
A CHALLENGE FOR THEM SOME
MIRACLE THAT THEY SHOW UP
EVERYDAY AT SCHOOL.
IBM AND WE WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO CONTINUE TO SERVE THEM TO THE
BEST FOR ABILITY AND WE THINK
THAT FINALLY WE CAN DO THAT. IS
IF YOU CAN US IS NOT PART OF THE
SPOT FUNDING GRANTS OF PLEASE
EXCLUDE EVEN LPS FROM THIS
GRANT.
GOOD NOT. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS HOLLY HUNTER RUBIO I AM FROM
MODESTO JUNIOR COLLEGE I AM ALSO
AN LPN AS STUDENT ALSO FORMER
BRIDGE STUDENT.
ALMOST IMMEDIATELY OPEN AS IT
HAS HELPED ME ACADEMICALLY AND
HAS ALSO GIVEN ME THE EXTRA
SUPPORT THAT I LACK OF.
IF IT WASN'T FOR E. OPIUM AS
HELPING ME AND THE REST OF US
FINANCIALLY AND ACADEMICALLY. I
WOULDN'T BE WHERE I AM NOW AYE
AND THREE SEMESTERS AWAY FROM
TRANSFERRING. PLEASE BOW AGAINST
BLOCK GRANT.
HELLO MY NAME IS DESTINY FOR
GOLLY AM ALSOS A AND GC I AM
PART OF THE BRIDGE PROGRAM WHICH
COMES FROM EUROPEAN AND AND.
EUROPEAN US HAS DONE MANY THINGS
FOR ME AND I APPRECIATE IT AND
I'M NOT SURE WHERE I WOULD BE IF
IT WASN'T FOR ELP AND. SO PLEASE
VOTE AGAIN.
LIKE FOR ME.
THINK.
HI MY NAME IS ADAM REDUCE GOMA
CURRENT STUDENT AT MJC IF YOU
OFFER YOUR* PROGRAM I WOULD
MEAN GETTING MY EDUCATION.
PLEASE VOTE NO FOR ROCK FUNNY
THINK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
BECAUSE GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
GOING TO SURVIVE A FIRST
GENERATION COLLEGE STUDENT AT.
MODESTO JUNIOR COLLEGE AND ALSO
PART OF THE BRIDGE PROGRAM FROM
WITH EUROPEAN ES.
AND I FEEL THAT EUROPEAN HAS
REALLY LIKE.
CHANGED MY LIFE BECAUSE.
NOW LIKE EVERY DAY I WAKE UP
LOOKING FOR GOING TO SCHOOL THE
BEFORE TO SEE EVERYBODY ELSE.
AND I REALLY CARE A LOT ABOUT MY
EDUCATION NOW BECAUSE I HAVE SO
MUCH SUPPORT AND I'M.
.
LIKE I AM ABLE TO AFFORD TO GO
TO SCHOOL BECAUSE OF ALL THE
HELP THAT I GET FROM UPS.
SO PLEASE VOTE ON NO ON BLOCK
FUNDING IT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M WITH THE
SIMPLON GO I'M REALLY NERVOUS
AND I'M ON THE LIFE I AM. I AM A
FORMER STUDENT OF AYE NGC ALSO A
FORMER BRIDGE STUDENT AND NOW I
AM THREE CLASSES AWAY FROM A
BACHELORS DEGREE IN SOCIOLOGY
ASSIST YOU STANISLAUS.
.
BEFORE SCHOOL AND LET'S JUST SAY
MY NORM WAS INCARCERATIONS.
INCARCERATION IN AND DRUGS JUST
BECAUSE I COME FROM.
GENERATIONS OF INCARCERATIONS
FOR EXAMPLE BOTH MY PARENTS BEEN
INCARCERATED OLD MIKE.
SIDES OF MY GRANDPARENTS BEEN
INCARCERATED AND I WAS HONESTLY
DOWN THAT SAME PATH BUT IT
WASN'T IF IT WASN'T FOR THE U.
* PROGRAM. AND THE SUPPORT
NOT EVEN THE SERVICES BUT THE
SUPPORT THAT THEY GAVE ME.
I WOULDN'T BE STANDING HERE
RIGHT NOW OPPOSING B. M. AND
THANK HER THRACIAN SYSTEM.
AND I JUST CAN'T IMAGINE YOUR
* CHANGING AND HAVING OTHER
PEOPLE DECIDE WHERE THE MONEY
SHOULD GO BECAUSE LIKE I SAID.
IS LITERALLY CHANGED MY LIFE
AND I WOULDN'T BE HEARING ON.
HELLO MY NAME IS CHRISTINA LOPEZ
I AM A FIRST GENERATION COLLEGE
STUDENT AND I AM ATTENDING
MODESTO JUNIOR COLLEGE AND I'M
CURRENTLY IN THE OPS STUDENT AS
WELL AS A PART OF THE BRIDGE
PROGRAM. AND BECAUSE OF THESE
PROGRAMS I CAN HAVE A LIFE I
NEVER THOUGHT I'D HAVE. BEFORE
SCHOOL I WAS A PARTY GAINES AND
WAS INCARCERATED HOWEVER HAVING
A PROGRAM THAT IS NOT WILL NOT
ONLY SUPPORTING US FINANCIALLY
AS WELL AS GIVING US ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT SUCH AS COUNSELING.
TUTORING SUPPLIES AND POSITIVE
RELATIONSHIPS WHICH HELPS
MOTIVATE ME TO STAY AWAY FROM MY
PREVIOUS LIFESTYLE I NEVER HAD
ANYONE BELIEVE ME THE WAY THESE
PROGRAMS DO. YOU OPS HAS CHANGED
MY LIFE PLEASE VOTE AGAINST
BLOCK FUNDING THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS SHIRLEY LOPEZ I AM
CURRENTLY A STUDENT AT MODESTO
JUNIOR COLLEGE AS WELL AS IN THE
RPF STUDENT. I'M HERE TO SAY I
VOTE AGAINST BLOCK GRANT FUNDING
UPS HAS HELPED ME TREMENDOUSLY
DUE TO THE FACT THAT BOTH OF MY
PARENTS DO NOT WORK. WITHOUT THE
UPS PROGRAM I WOULD NOT BE ABLE
TO FURTHER MY EDUCATION THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS NICK PRATA DISLIKE
THANK EVERYONE FOR GIVING US THE
OPPORTUNITY COME UP HERE AND
SPEAK.
I AM A MODESTO JUNIOR COLLEGE
STUDENT AS WELL AS THE EP UTOPIA
STUDENT OF.
AGAINST BLOCK GRANT FUNDING
BECAUSE WITHOUT UPS THEM.
NAY WOULD HAVE GAY MY WHOLE
FAMILY SECOND CHANCE TO CORRECT
THEMSELVES.
THANK YOU YES.
HELLO ANY MINUTES WITH THE
HISPANIC ASSOCIATION OF COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES WHILE WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE FUNDING
FORMULA WE HAVE THE FOLLOWING
CONCERNS. FIRST THIS UP WE
BELIEVE THE SUPPLEMENTAL GRANT
SHOULD BE SHOULD INCLUDE FOSTER
YOUTH FIRST GENERATION DOC AND
DREAMERS STUDENTS. SECONDLY
THOSE LAWS OF WOMEN TOOK GRANT
FUNDS SHOULD BE TARGETED
SPECIFICALLY FOR SUPPORT
SERVICES.
AND THREE GIVEN THE LACK OF
POSITIVE OUTCOMES SHOWN FOR
PERFORMANCE FOOD THAT TARGETED
POPULATIONS
AND RECOGNIZE PROGRESS TOWARDS
DEGREE METRICS.
.
AND THEN.
WE NEED CLARIFICATION ON THE
NUMBER OF YEARS THE WHOLE HOLD
HARMLESS PROVISION WILL BE IN
PLACE AS NEEDED.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS NOT
CONCH HERNANDEZ I'M AYE YOU YES
YOU AND JC.
.
I DON'T REALLY KNOW MUCH ABOUT
THE FUNDING AND ALL THE MONEY
AND STUFF BUT I I DO KNOW THAT
ON.
UPS WORKS SO EFFECTIVE GONNA
MEAN IT'S IT'S ON.
IS IT HELPED ME A LOT BECAUSE I
WAS JUST YOU KNOW JUST LIKE
EVERYBODY HAS BEEN TALKING
ANNOUNCES THE STEREOTYPE AMONG
YOU KNOW WHERE I LIVE.
AND.
.
IT KIND IT WILL BE A NO YOU OPS
WOKE ME UP YEAH LET ME KNOW THAT
YOU KNOW THERE'S THERE'S A
CAREER FOR YOU YOU KNOW AND AND
THEIR SKILLS THAT YOU KNOW YOU
HAVE. BUT YOU HAVE AND USE THAT
FOR.
SO.
YEAH KNOW DON'T BUST UP ON YOUR
PS YOU KNOW HOW THE PROGRAMS ARE
HELPING KNOW THE THE STUDENTS
THAT ARE GOING THROUGH THE SAME
THINGS THAT WE ALL GO THROUGH.
IN LIFE THANK YOU.
LOW COUNCILMEMBERS MEANINGS OF
THE ROMAN THOSE OF YOU KNOW AND
I'M.
NUMBER I'M JUST A STUDENT OF ONE
PART OF THE BRIDGE PROGRAMS YOU
CAN SAY.
THIS PROGRAM HAS BEEN A
BLESSING TO ME PERSONALLY
BECAUSE
MY BACKGROUND IS LOVE BIG ABOUT
MY FIFTH MY FAMILY'S HISTORY
WITH MENTAL DISABILITIES SONG
DISABLED TO.
BUT I WAS ABLE TO OVERCOME MY
MENTAL DISABILITIES NAM YOU'RE
STANDING BEFORE YOU. BEEN ABLE.
SO THE GOOD TECHNOLOGY ON
RECOGNIZE EVERYTHING THAT'S
GOING ON.
AN UNKNOWN WITH.
WHAT THE HELL FROM THE AOP UP
IT'S LIKE A MUCH AND OF BEEN OF
LESSEN THE PAIN FROM MY BOOKS
WERE EVERYTHING THEM THE BRIDGE
PROGRAM? THE PAY FOR EVERYTHING
IS SOMETHING THAT MY FAMILY CAN
DO ANYMORE.
BECAUSE MY DEATH US WHEN HE WAS
THE ORIGINAL HOME.
THE ORIGINAL MONEY MAKER AGO
AGAINST THE BREAD MAKER YOU
COULD SAY. ANNOUNCES HE'S NOT
AROUND ANYMORE IT'S IT'S JUST
WITH THIS MORE ON OUR OWN TOY DO
WHATEVER WE CAN FOR. FRANK
AHMANSON SPEAK OF THEM DUE TO MY
MENTAL DISABILITY I HAVE A
REALLY WEEKLY WORK HISTORY.
SO ANOTHER A PART OF THE
EUROPEAN US PROGRAM I HAVE A
CHANCE TO GET A JOB GET GET THE
TRAINING ON GET THE BECAUSE I
NEED.* GET THOSE JOHN SECOND
OF THOUGHT BEEN RELY ON THE JOB.
AND AFTER THAT I PLAN TO OWN UP
THE MIDDLE ON THE JOB WITH THOSE
WITH THE WITH THE TO THE TICKET
THEM GO FAR ENOUGH. A PLAN OF
GOING TO HOME.
GOING TO LIKE GOING TO LIKE A
THERAPIST OR A COUNSELOR FOR
PEOPLE MENTAL DISABILITIES
BECAUSE.
BECAUSE I KNOW WHAT THEY WANT TO
HAVE BEEN THROUGH EVERYTHING
THEY'D BEEN THROUGH. ANNA AND I
UNDERSTAND WHERE PEOPLE WANT IN
THIS MODES COME FROM SO A BLOCK
AND UPLAND. WITH THE HELP OF THE
LPS AND PROGRAMS LIKE THE S. P.
S. IMPRINTS.
TRUE ON ALL OF PROGRAMS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE SO PLEASE.
DO NOT BLOCK GRANT FUNDING THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS DAVE OKAY I
TEACH MATHEMATICS AT YUBA
COLLEGE IN HAYWARD AND IN MOST
OF THE INCOMING PRESIDENT OF THE
SHOVEL LAS CASITAS FACULTY
ASSOCIATION.
WE ARE FIERCELY OPPOSED TO THE
PROPOSED FUNDING MODEL AND THE
BIGGEST CONCERN IS BECAUSE OF
THE WAY IT ROBS FROM PETER TO
PAY PAUL. AND WHERE PETER.
AT YOUR BOW WE HAVE CERTAINLY A
VERY GOOD TRANSFER RATES AND WE
ALSO CERTAINLY SERVE A LARGE
NUMBER OF DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS
AND YET SOMEHOW ACCORDING TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE MARKUPS.
ARE DISTRICT WOULD BE SLATED TO
TO BEEF TO FACE A FOURTEEN
PERCENT FUNDING CUT. AND THAT IS
ON TOP OF THE STAIRS AND PURRS
INCREASES THAT WE HAD A
INCREASED COSTS THAT WE HAVE TO
UP TO PAY FOR.
BECAUSE THE THAT IS WORSE THAN
WE EVER FACED DURING THE HEIGHT
OF THE RECESSION AND BECAUSE OF
THAT WE WOULD BE CUTTING BACK.
O. WE ACTUALLY HAVE PRETTY GOOD
ENROLLMENTS BUT WE WOULD BE
CUTTING ACCESS OF WHO IS HARD TO
AMEND WE HAVE PROGRAMS THAT ARE
VERY EXPENSIVE TO OPERATE LIKE
NURSING A DENTAL HYGIENE THAT
WHICH WE OPERATE AT A BIG LOSS
AS IT IS. OF IS A GOOD CHANCE WE
WOULD HAVE TO PUT THOSE ON THE
CHOPPING BLOCK WE WOULD
CERTAINLY BE DISCUSSING IT ARE
ALSO WE SEE THAT THE FUNDING
MODEL AS AN ASSAULT.
ON OUR WORKING STUDENTS PART
TIME STUDENTS TO TAKE MORE THAN
THREE YEARS TO COMPLETE.
THAT OF THE FOR THE PART TIME
AN EVENING STUDENTS AYE
UNDERPREPARED STUDENTS
ESPECIALLY WE WOULD BE FORCED TO
CUT ACCESS FOR THOSE STUDENTS
BECAUSE WE BECAUSE AGAIN THE
FUNDING CUT WOULD BE SO GREAT.
THAT WE WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
AFFORD TO MAINTAIN THAT ACCESS
AND WHATEVER HAPPENED A LIFELONG
LEARNING. BUT THE MASTER PLAN
UNTIL THIS MODEL SEEMS LIKE IT
COMPLETE ABROGATION OF THE OLD
MASTER PLAN IN TERMS OF WHAT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WERE DESIGNED
TO DO SO IT'S IT'S A WELL
ESPOSITO'S.  WE DO SEE THE
MODEL IS AN ASSAULT ON OUR
WORKING STUDENTS ESPECIALLY
THANK YOU.
HI JEFFREY MICHAEL'S TRIPLE SEE
I YOU KNOW LEARNING COMMUNITIES
LIKE WEDNESDAY AND EXTRA SUPPORT
SERVICES LIKE UPS OR SOME OF THE
VERY BEST THINGS WE DO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THE TO SUGGEST
WE SHOULD ALLOCATE TWENTY FIVE
PERCENT OF THE TOTAL FUNDING.
BASED ON OUTCOMES MEASURES THIS
IS A A REAL PROBLEM AND I HOPE
YOU WILL REJECT IT I'M READING
FROM A RECENT RESEARCH BOOK THE
EXTENT RESEARCH LITERATURE HAS
FOUND THE PERFORMANCE BASED
FUNDING HAS LITTLE IMPACT ON
STUDENT OUTCOMES.
BUT THERE ARE HUGE A SIZEABLE
UNINTENDED NEGATIVE IMPACTS
INCLUDING RESTRICTING
INSTITUTIONAL COOPERATION
LIMITING OUR MISSION UNDERMINING
MORALE. UNDERMINING QUALITY
STANDARDS
THERE'S A LOT TO BE WORRIED
ABOUT HERE AND.
OF EVERYTHING EVERYBODY HAS
LEARNED FROM PERFORMANCE SPACE
FUNDING THE KEY IS TO BUILD
CAPACITY FOR INSTITUTIONAL
CHANGE WE NEED TO WORK ON
CAPACITY BUILDING AND THE
BIGGEST WEAKNESS OF THE SYSTEM
IS OUR OVER RELIANCE ON PART
TIME FACULTY.
UNTIL WE INVEST IN FULL TIME
FACULTY AND MORE COUNSELORS.
ALL OF THESE INITIATIVES ARE AND
WHERE I COME UP HERE EVERY YEAR
AND MAKE THIS.
THESE INITIATIVES ARE NOT GOING
TO PRODUCE THE OUTCOMES WE WANT
BECAUSE WE DO NOT HAVE THE
CAPACITY.
TO MAKE THE CHANGES THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO INCENTIVIZE.
START BY IMPROVING YOUR FULL
TIME FACULTY RATIOS AND WE WILL
HAVE MORE AND BETTER AT
TRANSFERS INSECT
I THINK IT.
AND DON'T FEEL.
I WANNA TALK ABOUT THIS SIX
STUDENT SUCCESS INCENTIVE GRANTS
PART OF THE NEW FUNDING FORMULA
FOR DISTRICTS AND EXPEDITE TO
GREECE IN THREE YEARS OR LESS.
INVENTOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT OR I'M THAT I'M ALSO
THE VICE PRESIDENT AT IT THE
LOCAL AREA SEE IF THEY HAVE TEA.
AND WE'VE HAD A ONGOING PROBLEM
FOR THE LAST COUPLE YEARS WITH
SOMETHING THAT THE NEW DEANS AND
SOME THE NEW ADMINISTRATORS ARE
CALLING PRODUCTIVITY. WHAT IT
AMOUNTS TO IS CLASSES THAT HAVE
TWENTY TO TWENTY FIVE STUDENTS
ARE BEING CANCELED SO THAT THEY
CAN JAM INTO ANOTHER SIMILAR
CLASS AT A SIMILAR TIME? SO NOW
YOU HAVE FIFTY TO FIFTY FIVE
STUDENTS.
AT THE SAME TIME THIS IS
HAPPENING WERE CONSTANTLY ON THE
PAGE OF STUDENT EQUITY IN
STUDENT SUCCESS. WELL YOU KNOW I
AS AN INSTRUCTOR YOU MUST
UNDERSTAND THAT YOUR ABILITY TO
IDENTIFY STUDENT NEEDS AND
PROMOTES STUDENT SUCCESS IS
DIMINISH IS WHEN YOU HAVE FIFTY
FIVE STUDENTS AS OPPOSED TO
TWENTY FIVE TO THIRTY.
SO WHAT I SEE HAPPENING WITH
THIS IT.
INCENTIVE TO EXPEDITE THE THREE
YEARS IS MORE OF THIS PILE ON
PRODUCTIVITY INCREASE THE CLASS
SIZES DAM AS MANY PEOPLE AS YOU
CAN THROUGH AS QUICKLY AS YOU
CAN.
AND STUDENT SUCCESS IN STUDENT
EQUITY NOW JUST BECOMES YOU KNOW
MEANINGLESS.
THANK YOU.
PETER SEXY LIBRARIAN OF INTER
COLLEGE BUT ALSO CHIEF
NEGOTIATOR FOR A HEFTY LOCAL
EIGHTEEN TWENTY EIGHT FOR
PRINTER COUNTY COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT.
WINTER UP MORE PARKING LOTS ARE
COLLEGES SEEMS LIKE LEGISLATURE
LIKED ZIG AND ZAG COUPLE YEARS
AGO THERE'S A LOT OF MONEY THAT
WENT DIRECTLY TO STUDENT SUCCESS
IN EQUITY. AND NOW IT SEEMS TO
BE PERFORMANCE BASED FUNDING.
AND EVERY COUPLE YEARS IT SEEMS
LIKE THE DIRECTION CHANGES IT'S
VERY DIFFICULT FOR US TO REALLY
WORK ON OUR CORE MISSION WHICH.
ABLE TO GET STUDENTS THROUGH OUR
COLLEGES AND IF THEY WANT TO GET
A DEGREE TO TRANSFERRED TO WORK
ON THAT OR FOR CERTIFICATES TO
WORK ON THAT.
WHEN THINGS KEEP ON CHANGING ON
A REGULAR BASIS
WHAT DO YOU GUYS REALLY WANT US
TO DO. SO I IMPLORE YOU TO NOT
GO FORWARD WITH THE PERFORMANCE
BASED FUNDING WILL HAVE
DELETERIOUS CONSEQUENCES AN ILL
GO CONTRARY TO WHAT LEGISLATOR
APPROVED JUST A FEW YEARS AGO
WITH TRIPLE SP AND WITH EQUITY
FUNDING.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS JACQUELINE YEAH
YES I ACTON I WAS PART OF THE
WHAT THE PROGRAM I USE LOS
ANGELES COLLEGE NOW I AM
ATTENDING UC BERKELEY I BELIEVE.
I STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT WHEN
THERE WAS A KEY FACTOR FOR ME.
TRANSFERRING TO UC BERKELEY
PART OF THE BUT THE PROGRAM I
HAVE PLANTS MOVE THIS ENCOURAGE
ME TO ATTENDING.
COLLEGE I.
REALLY ARE YOU DISREGARD ME GONE
GOING TO SCHOOL BECAUSE I DIDN'T
HAVE THOUGH FUNDING I DIDN'T
QUALIFY FOR FUN FOR.
FUNDING.
.
TO HELP ME PAY FOR SCHOOL AND SO
THERE'S CONSERVE THAT DON'T KNOW
HOW TO HELP STUDENTS LIKE ME ASK
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS I.
WHEN I GOT INTO THE POINT THE
PROGRAM THEY WERE ABLE CALL ME
GIVEN THE TOOLS AND SHOW ME HARD
WHAT IS NEEDED TO TRANSFER AND
HOW. HOW IT IS TO DO OUR I SEEM
REALLY CLOSE?
?
EX PEOPLE THAT HAVE NOT BEEN
THROUGH SO. WHEN THE PROGRAM
I'VE SEEN HOW THEY STRUGGLE AND
HOW THEY HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO
SUCCESSFULLY TRANSFERRED BECAUSE
THEY DON'T HAVE THOSE TOOLS THEY
DON'T HAVE THE.
THOUGH SUPPORT THE POINT THE
GIVES TO STUDENTS.
I SEEN THIS IN WITH MY SISTERS
I SEE THAT WHAT FRANCE AND I AS
MUCH AS I TRY TO HOPE IS NOT THE
SAME AS. GOING INTO THE
PROGRAMMING GETTING THE RIGHT
HOPE THAT.
.
GETTING THE RIGHT HOPE TO GET A
TRANSFER GET YOU TO GET THE
DEGREE THAT YOU ONCE AGAIN. I
URGE YOU YEAH I IMPLORE YOU TO
HALT CONTINUE SUPPORTING POINT
THAN.
.
HOPE POINT THE CONTINUE TO
EXPAND BECAUSE THIS IS A PROGRAM
THAT HELPS A LOT OF STUDENTS THE
HOPES.
NIGHT THIS OF THE PERSON WHO'S
GETTING THE GETTING GOING
THROUGH THE BUT THE PROGRAM BUT
THE STUDENTS.
ITHIN THE COMMUNITY PEOPLE
AROUND THEM GET THE BENEFITS OF
THE PROGRAM TO THANK YOU.
HI THERE MY NAME IS GRACE I AM
FROM A RESIDENT OF BERKELEY THIS
IS ARTHUR MY SERVICE DOG AND I'M
HERE TO REPRESENT THE POINT THE
PROGRAM AT COLLEGE OF MARIN
WHERE I'VE SERVED AS. A
VOLUNTEER FOR THE PAST. EIGHT OR
NINE YEARS.
IN THE COURSE OF THAT TIME I
WORK WITH ABOUT SIX OR SEVEN.
UNDER THE SIX OR SEVEN UP
FRESHMAN A STUDENT'S FIRST
GENERATION STUDENTS AND I'VE
SEEN ON THEM BLOSSOM FROM. A
VERY NERVOUS VERY UNSURE OF
THEMSELVES NOT FEELING THAT THEY
BELONG IN A COLLEGE SETTING AND
THEN IN THAT TIME TRANSFORM AND
ONE YEAR COURSE THE PROGRAM JUST
TRANSFORM AND BLOSSOM INTO.
JUST VERY CONFIDENT VERY I'M.
IT'D JUST VERY ASSERTIVE I
YOUNG PEOPLE AND VERY SHORT OF
THEIR GOALS AND AND NOW I'M
HAVING HAVING WORKED WITH THEM
I'VE SEEN THEM GRADUATE OF
SEEING THEM TRANSFERRED TO
VARIOUS COLLEGES. AND THEN COME
BACK AS MENTORS TO OTHERS AROUND
THAT AND SO I REALLY BELIEVE IN
THE PROGRAM AND I HOPE YOU'LL
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THIS.
THANK YOU.
AFTER YOU COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TAKING THE
TIME TODAY SAMANTHA SAYING THE
NEXT GEN CALIFORNIA. WERD
SUPPORT WITH THE FUNDING FORMULA
CUT CHANGE PROPOSALS ARE
PRIORITIES AND HIGHER EDUCATION
ARE ACT IMPROVING ACCESS.
AFFORDABILITY IN TIME COMPLETION
WE SEE THIS LINE WITH THAT THANK
YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DUH TO THE.
PUBLIC TESTIMONY THANK YOU TO
THE STUDENTS.
.
WE WILL BE CLOSING UP HERE OF
THIS RARE SU CHI.
ANY ANY REMARKS CLOSING REMARKS
IF NOT.
.
I WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY FOR
COMING. I WILL I WANT TO THANK
THE STUDENTS AGAIN BOTH THE E.
OP STUDENTS AND WENT THERE.
I I I. RECOGNIZE A PROGRAM THAT
WORKS WHEN I SEE IT. AND I KNOW
THAT BOTH WEDNESDAY AND YOU'LL
P. ARE PROGRAMS THAT WORK.
SO I'M MUCH MORE CONFIDENT IN.
PUTTING STATE MONEY IN PROGRAMS
THAT HAVE A TRACK RECORD THEN
AND PROGRAMS THAT ARE. NOT
SHOWING THAT THAT THEY CAN WORK.
THANK YOU FOR BEING YOU OKAY.
THANK YOU ALL JUST KNOW THAT WE
WILL HEAR THIS ISSUE.
LATER I I DO THINK IT HAS SOME
PROMISE TO TALK ABOUT.
HUESO WE COULD PUT MORE.
RESOURCES INTO THE PROGRAM THE
STUDENTS THAT NEED THE MOST
ABOUT HELP LIKE THE ONES WE
HEARD FROM TODAY.
AYE CRYSTAL CLEAR THAT WE HEAR
FROM SOME OF THE PROGRAMS LIKE
WENT DAY EUROPEAN ESTAMOS JAB.
OUR ART ART SPECIAL IN THEIR
EFFORTS AND MAYBE SHOULD BE
CONCERT OUTSIDE I THINK THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE WE'RE CONSIDERING.
BUT WILL HEAR THIS ISSUE AGAIN
WITH MORE DISCUSSION
DELIBERATION ON SOME OF THE
BIGGER PICTURE.
ISSUES AND.
THE COMING WEEKS
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION WITH THAT WE WILL
ADJOURN